AN ENERGY WILL BEGIN- NOW
IMMEDIATELY AND THE MEETING WILL
COME TO ORDER. GOOD MORNING IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES
WE MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES AND COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE.
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THAT LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING HERE IN
SACRAMENTO ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED AT THE- STREET STRING
SPACE BUILDING. IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WITH ME TODAY I'M HAPPY TO
BE JOINED BY MIGHT SENATE
PARTNER SENATOR JOSH NEWMAN
REPRESENTING SENATE DISTRICT
TWENTY NINE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. WE ALSO HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IF OF BUSINESS
AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT. ALL TO SEE
GREEN HYDROGEN COALITION.
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY
SEMPRA UTILITIES SUNLIGHT
TRANSIT AGENCY AND THE
CALIFORNIA HUNDRED COALITION.
WHO ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
FOR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS.
THIS WILL GREATLY AID IN THE
LIMITING ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I
ASK THAT EVERY TIME YOU WISH TO
BE RECOGNIZED THAT YOU USE THE
RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE. IN THE
PROGRAM. EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO BE ON MUTED.
PLEASE SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU
BEGIN SPEAKING. R. I. T. T.
PERSONNEL WILL BRING YOU BACK I
AM NOT ON MUTE AND- YOU WILL BE
DONE AND READY TO GO. A ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU'LL BE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING
ROOM TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILLED WE WILL BE USING
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
HERE TODAY. FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT. THAT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED ON
THE SCREEN AND I WILL ANNOUNCE
IT NOW. TODAY'S PARTICIPANT
NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. TWO
TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX THREE. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN THREE
SIX TWO EIGHT THREE THREE FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES FROM WORKS
PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE AND
OR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AGAIN THE
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS ONCE AGAIN. SEVEN THREE SIX
TWO EIGHT THREE THREE. FOR
TODAY'S HEARING WE WILL BE
HEARING ALL THE PANELS OF
WITNESSES ON THE AGENDA PRIOR TO
TAKING ANY PUBLIC COMMENT. ONCE
WE HAVE HEARD ALL THE WITNESSES
AND THE COMMITTEE HAS HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO QUESTION THE
PANELISTS WE WILL HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD FOR THOSE WHO
WISH TO COMMENT ON THE TOPIC ON
TODAY'S AGENDA. PLEASE NOTE IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY
AND TO AVOID ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK
YOU MUST MUTE THE DEVICE YOU'RE
WATCHING. THE HEARING ON PRIOR
TO GIVING TESTIMONY OVER THE
PHONE. IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
HEAR FROM YOU AND WE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
PARTICIPATION TODAY. I WILL
MEDITATE I WILL MAINTAIN THE
DECORUM. DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS
MUTED. THANK YOU CALIFORNIA IS A
WORLD LEADER WHEN IT COMES TO
HYDROGEN ADAPTION AND TECHNOLOGY
AND THAT IS WHY AS THE STATE WE
ARE SO EXCITED TO SEE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT BEGAN TO
INVEST IN HYDROGEN. ON NOVEMBER
FIFTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY ONE
PRESIDENT BIDEN SIGNED A ONE
TRILLION DOLLAR INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL THAT INCLUDED NINE POINT
FIVE BILLION FOR CLEAN HYDROGEN
PROGRAMS. THE GOAL OF TODAY'S
SELECT COMMITTEE HEARING IS TO
PROVIDE A PLATFORM FOR HYDROGEN
STAKEHOLDERS IN CALIFORNIA TO
PRESENT THEIR WORK IN THE
HYDROGEN SECTOR AND TO PRESENT
THEIR PLANS FOR OUR STATE MOVING
FORWARD WITH THIS FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE MONEY. RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN WILL PLAY A VERY
IMPORTANT ROLE IN CALIFORNIA IF
WE'RE TO REACH OUR AMBITIOUS
CLIMATE GOALS THIS IS UNDENIABLE
. AS WE NEED TO BUILD OUT THIS
NEW HYBRID THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THE RIGHT WAY THIS MEANS
BRINGING TOGETHER ALL THE STAKE
HOLDERS. WE NEED TO RESPECT AND
HONOR THE WORKERS PAST AND
PRESENT WHO HAVE HELPED MAKE
CALIFORNIA A GLOBALLY ECONOMIC
POWERHOUSE THE FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY IN THE WORLD. WITH
TRAINING AND EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES IN THIS NEW
HYDROGEN SECTOR. WE ALSO NEED TO
MAKE SURE LOW INCOME EARNERS OR
PEOPLE OF COLOR WE HAVE JUST
BEEN DISPROPORTIONATELY SUFFERED
THE NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES OF AIR
POLLUTION AND CLIMATE CHANGE ARE
WITH US IN THIS NEW GREENER
VENTURE. AND THE FUTURE OF
GREENER ENERGY. THESE ARE THE
COMMUNITIES WHO COMPEL US TO
SEEK THE BEST ALTERNATIVE. FOR
OUR CARBON BASED ECONOMY.
CALIFORNIA IS A TREASURE CHEST
OF ENERGY AND WE NEED TO LOOK AT
ALL ASPECTS AT ALL OPTIONS TO
GET US TO ZERO CARBON. HYDROGEN
WILL BE A MAJOR PART OF THIS
EQUATION AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH EVERYONE TO MAKE
OUR PLANE ZERO CARBON HYDROGEN
FUTURE A REALITY. NOW LET'S
BEGIN WITH OUR FIRST PRESENTER-
TYSON ACKERLEY. DEPUTY DIRECTOR
OF ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE MARKET
DEVELOPMENT WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. GOOD MORNING
MISTRETTA LATE AND WE'RE GONNA
HAVE ALL THE SPEAKERS- AT ABOUT
A TWELVE MINUTE INTERVAL SO-
RIGHT ABOUT THEN WE'LL WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND LET YOU KNOW THAT. YOU
CAN- CLOSE WITH YOUR REMARKS
YOU'RE GONNA TRY TO KEEP
EVERYONE DOWN TWELVE ROCKNE
TWELVE MINUTES CHAU WELL WELCOME
ONCE AGAIN AND PLEASE AGAIN.
RIGHT WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
CENTER AFTER A LOT OF THINGS FOR
CONVENING THIS IMPORTANT
HEARING. IT'S OUR YOU KNOW
REALLY SAID I WANT TO ACTUALLY
START WITH AN ANECDOTE FROM THIS
WEEK IN FACT AND WE HAD A AN
EXECUTIVE BOARD MEETING FOR THE
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL PARTNERSHIP.
I'M IN IT IN CENTER TO NEW MAN
ALSO AT THAT WAS GRACIOUS ENOUGH
TO ATTEND AND SPEAK AT AND IT'S
REALLY GREAT INSIDE. ONE OF THE
LINES OF INQUIRY THAT CAME
THROUGH WAS REFERRING TO STATION
DEVELOPERS AS COMPETITORS AND-
THEY STATED ONE OF THE STATE OR
CITY AND- STOOD UP AND SAID YOU
KNOW I LOOK FORWARD TO THE DAY
WHEN WE ARE COMPETITORS. I THINK
THAT THAT'S NOT IN MY MIND AND
IT IT REALLY STOOD OUT AND IT
TALKED ABOUT WHERE WE ARE IN THE
MARKET REALLY IN A COOPERATION
PHASE. A MARKET CREATION PHASE
AND SO WITH THAT IN MIND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AT SCHOOL BIDS
TO TAKE THE LEAD REALLY IN
FIGURING OUT THE BEST ROUTE IF
YOU CAN MAKE YOUR CALIFORNIA
TRACKS A LOT OF THIS FEDERAL
INVESTMENT. THEBILL THE WORLD'S
LEADING YOU NEVER KNEW WILL
GREEN HYDROGEN HUB. AND TAKING A
STEP BACK THIS ONE IS TALKING A
LITTLE BIT WHAT DOES THAT MEAN
AND- TO HAVE GO BASED YOU IT
MEANS YOU KNOW DRIVING TOWARDS
CONSENSUS WORK WITH ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS YOU KNOW ACROSS ALL
OF OUR AGENCIES. AND THAT
PRIVATE AND PUBLIC AND WORKFORCE
ALL THIS IT MEANS ENABLING. OUR
PRIVATE CAPITAL TO SCALE THE
MARKET AND IT'S REALLY A FOCUS
ON IMPLEMENTATION YOU DO A LOT
OF WORK ON BERMAN STREAMLINING
AND MAKING SURE THAT THIS.
INVESTMENT TRANSLATES INTO STEEL
IN THE GROUND AND A GROWING
MARKET PLACE. THE SENATE
REGULATED MENTIONS DAY I'M THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BILL AND I JUST.
BUT IT'S GOOD TO PUT IS THAT
WE'RE NOT GONNA READ THROUGH
THAT LANGUAGE HERE BUT WE JUST
HIGHLIGHTED IT THE PLACES WHERE
CALIFORNIA HAS A LOT OF STRENGTH
IT'S IN THE RENEWABLES. YOU KNOW
IT'S AN ELECTRIC POWER
INDUSTRIAL NET AND PARTICULARLY
IN THE TRANSPORTATION SECTOR FOR
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK. FOR US.
AND YOU KNOW YOU REALLY
CALIFORNIA IS. IN A VERY STRONG
POSITION- AS THEY- AS A- TO WIN
A- OF THIS. IN THIS IS IT A
SLIGHT BIT IS THAT THE DEAL WE-
TOGETHER. AND RESPOND TO THE
HIGH TO IT I DON'T. SHOT AND
IT'S HAVE. AND IF YOU LOOK IT
THIS THAT'S THE- OUT YOU HAVE A-
REGION'S. ALTHOUGH AND BANNED.
AND SO IN CALIFORNIA HOW BY FAR
THE MOST RESPONSES. AND IT'S
SIGNIFICANT THAT YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIA'S CALLED OUT IN THIS
CALIFORNIA REALLY IS RATHER
EARLY MARKET IS. SPECIALLY WORK
RENEWABLE HYDROGEN. AND IT I
WANNA REMIND US YOU KNOW WE NEED
A NATIONAL MARKET SIXTY FOR THIS
ALL THE BEEF OF TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. BUT IN MANY WAYS AND
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
GREEN HYDROGEN THE NATIONAL
MARKET NEEDS CALIFORNIA SIXTY.
AND I THINK AS YOU HERE THIS
MORNING WE REALLY HAVE A NUMBER
OF ADVANTAGES I THINK YOU KNOW
FIRST OFF ARE STAKEHOLDER
COMMUNITY AND HEAR FROM ANY OF
THEM IS AMAZING. YOU KNOW
THERE'S A LOT OF EXPERIENCE IN
ENERGY BEHIND THAT- OUR POLICY
ENVIRONMENT THINGS THAT IT
LEADERSHIP THE LEGISLATURE ENDED
AND- AND- ADMINISTRATIONS. THIS
CURRENT AND PAST IS REALLY
ROBUST. AND YOU KNOW WE HAVE THE
BIGGEST REALLY MARKET. IT'S
REALLY UNDENIABLE AS FAR AS THIS
PLACE IS GOING TO. THINK ABOUT
IT WHEN WE WANT TO GET. OUT OF
THIS IS THAT AS THE STATE. I
THINK IT'S THREE FOR. THAT I
HAVE TEN YEARS. GETS SORRY THIS
IS. BUT THAT. YOU KNOW REALLY
IT'S TIME. IT'S MONEY AND THAT'S
ENOUGH THEY AND THAT'S- OUT
NUMBER HOPE THIS BETTER. MONEY
WE CAN LAUGH. IN A WAY THAT IT.
OUR TRANSIT TO ZERO. I HAVE.
URBAN TRANSPORT. ENTITIES I'M
MONEY SIDE WERE. AFTER A
FINANCIALLY SELF SUSTAINING
EXPANDING LOW CARBON FREE
HYDROGEN MARKET AND REALLY.
INDUSTRY TELLS US IS THE ONLY
PLACE BECAUSE OF OUR POLICY
ENVIRONMENT THAT THAT YOU CAN
REALLY HAPPEN IN THE NEAR TERM.
AND THEN THE THIRD THING IS AN
INNOVATION OUT YOU KNOW THAT YOU
WANT CALIFORNIA'S HYDROGEN HUB
TO. ACCELERATE GLOBAL ADOPTION.
OF LEAN HYDROGEN SO YOU WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT. THE NATIONAL
NETWORK IT'S SUCCESSFUL THAT
WE'RE PARTNERING WITH HUBS
ACROSS THE NATION TO DO THIS
BILL. AND THE INNOVATION IS YOU
KNOW BOTH IN TERMS OF
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION BUT
IT'S ALSO POLICY INNOVATION. AND
ORGANIZATIONAL INNOVATION. AND
YOU'LL HEAR YOU KNOW FROM THE UC
SYSTEM FOR EXAMPLE. AND HOW WE
CAN PULL THAT TOGETHER. I THINK
EVERYTHING NEEDS TO BE BUILT ON
OUR CORE PRINCIPLES AND SO AS A
STATE IF IT GROUP OF AGENCIES WE
GOT TOGETHER TO DRAFT A FEW WET
WINTER FOR PRINCIPLES FOR.
HYDROGEN WE'RE PRIORITIZING ZERO
LOW CARBON HYDROGEN OR GREEN
HYDROGENS THAT INCLUDES YOU KNOW
BROAD DEFINITION. REALLY FOCUS
IN ON CARBON INTENSITY- WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
INVESTING IN THE SYSTEM. TAKING
A MULTI SECTORAL APPROACH THE
OPTIC THAT YOU'LL HEAR A LOT
EVEN FOR THREE HUNDRED A
COALITION ABOUT HOW THAT. PULLS
TOGETHER- IT'S THE IDEA THAT
PUBLIC POLICY ENABLES REALLY
MARKETS AND PRIVATE CAPITAL
REALLY SCALES THAT. AND WE WANT
TO PRIORITIZE THE HARDEST TO
BATES SECTORS WITH THE BIGGEST
EMISSIONS PROFILES AND THAT'S
OF. HYDROGEN SWEET SPOT AND
REALLY FOCUS ON READING
ECONOMICALLY SUSTAINABLE MARK AT
THIS. YOU KNOW ALL INCLUDES- YOU
KNOW. ROBUST WORKFORCE AND
CREATING ACTED THAT ACCESS IS
LIKE HE SAID SENATOR ARCHULETA.
FINALLY WE WANNA MAKE SURE
FOCUSING OUR EFFORTS ON
COMMUNITIES OF. THE LARGEST
POLLUTION- AND SO WHAT ARE THE
HARDEST TO BE EXACT. I BUT FORCE
A LOT OF WORK ON THAT AT HERB
HAS. A RESOURCE FOR AND MAY WORK
ON THIS BILL BE PLAN. I'M NOT
GONNA THROUGH ALL THE OF THIS%
LIFE AT THE IS FROM MODEL- AND
SO YOU KNOW WHERE DO WE NEED.
NEEDED NEEDED ELECTRIC ELECTRIC
POWER WE NEED AN INDUSTRIAL. AND
THEN ALL OF THAT IT'S GOING TO
BE ABLE HYDROGEN IS ENERGY
STORAGE THAT'S REALLY ACROSS
SECTORS THANKS WE'VE GOT INTO
DETAILS BUT- EVERYTHING GOING
FORWARD WILL BE BUILT ON THE
FOUNDATION. OF THE ANALYSIS OF
THE SCHOOL BEING PLANNED OF SB
ONE HUNDRED ANALYSIS. TO MAKE
SURE THAT HYDROGEN IS BEING PUT
TO ITS BEST. AND THEN. WHAT'S
THE STATE'S ROLE IN THE
APPLICATION AND PARTICULARLY
WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION'S ROLE
AND THAT'S IT. I'M WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE. WE REALLY NEED
TO SET CLEAR OBJECTIVES AND
CRITERIA FOR STATES THE FORKS.
WHO FIND THE PROJECT IN
CALIFORNIA HAS A ROBUST BUDGET.
THAT PUTS US IN A IN A HUGE
ADVANTAGE TO COMPARED TO OTHER
STATES- YOU KNOW WE'RE TRYING
TO. CONNECT PARTY STANFORD
COLLABORATION THIS IS ONE OF THE
RISING TIDE LIFTS ALLBOATS AND
IT'S GONNA TAKE ALL OF US ARE
TRYING TO BUILD AN ECOSYSTEM
THAT WILL DRIVE. A FOR A LONG
TIME. RIGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR APPLICATION IS POSITIONED TO
WIN. I'M IN YEAH THAT MEANS
CONNECTING THE DOTS
COMMUNICATING WHY CALIFORNIA AND
THEN IT'S BRINGING REGIONAL
PARTNERS WITH OUR NEIGHBORING
STATES. I'M TO GO BEARS ARE ROLE
YOU KNOW THE LEAD ORGANIZER BUT
IT'S REALLY IN COLLABORATION AND
CONSENSUS WITH MULTIPLE STATE
AGENCIES AND PARTNERS SO YOU'LL
HEAR FROM TODAY. AND OUR TARGET
YOU KNOW WE'RE WORKING TOWARDS
THIS IS HAVING ONE UNIFIED.
STATE WIDE STATE ENDORSED AND
WHO FIND THAT APPLICATION. WITH
YOU KNOW REGIONAL SPECIFICITY WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU DON'T LOSE
ANY OF THAT MONEY COMING IN AND
SO THAT THAT. THIS REGIONAL.
OPPORTUNITIES CREATE. BROADER
OPPORTUNITY PLUS STATE WE DO
WANT TO MAKE SURE WE BRING IN
ALL PARTS OF THE STATE. AND THE
GOAL IS RE AGNES FAR AS THIS IS.
IT'S ORGANIZATION IS BUILDING A
SELF SUFFICIENT MANAGEMENT
STRUCTURE WITH CLEAR ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT WILL
THRIVE LONG INTO THE FUTURE AS
LONG AS IT'S NEEDED AND THEN
DISSOLVED WHEN THE MARKET.
FORCES ULTIMATELY TAKE OVER. AND
THOUGH. THIS WHEN I PRAY SHOULD
MAKE THIS LITTLE EIGHTY EIGHT.
BUT I. THIS HELPS LIKE HOW WE
THINK ABOUT THAT'S WE'RE GOING
TO BE WITH. CIRCLE OF WE ARE
PROUD TO PROPOSE IN THE MID
THESE OF THE A LOT OF- IF YOU'RE
FROM. WHO ARE OR- STAPLE. TRYING
TO IT YOU KNOW AROUND THIS
OPPORTUNITY. MANY LATER AND
SUPPLIERS WHO HAVE SOMETHING TO
OFFER TO THE AND MARKETPLACE
VIA. ELECTROLYZER SUPPLIER. AT
THE HIDERS FLYER VEHICLE
SUPPLIERS- WITH. ALL THE END END
IT'S THE DEMAND TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE DEMAND IS THERE. AND
PULLING ALL THESE PIECES
TOGETHER WE MADE IT POOREST
BECAUSE THESE ALL HAVE TO
INTERACT BUT IT'S REALLY GOING
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE PROJECT
PROPONENT. IN MANAGEMENT
STRUCTURE IS CLEAR. YOU ON THE
STATE SIDE WE NEED TO SEND A
CLEAR SIGNALS. GET MONEY TO
ENABLE THAT HELPS THAT I'M
ORGANIZED. AT THAT STAKEHOLDERS
I'M INDUSTRY CITING US REALLY
RESPONDING TO MARKET NEEDS
RESPONDING TO STATE POLICY NEED
IT'S MATCHING SUPPLY AND DEMAND.
BUT BOTH OF US NEED TO MAKE SURE
WE FOCUS ON IMPLEMENTATION THIS
NEEDS TO BE SUCCESSFUL. I'M IN
SO I IN TERMS OF FUNDING WE JUST
ORGANIZED YOU KNOW KIND OF WHAT
WITHIN IS WITHIN OUR CURRENT
AUTHORITY AS THE ADMINISTRATION
TO PUT FORWARD I'M NOT GONNA GO
THROUGH AND ALL THE DETAILS BUT
WE HAVE A LOT OF RESOURCES
BECOME FULL FROM AND HAVE TO BE
SURE THE SLIDES AFTER TO BE
GREAT TO WORK OBVIOUSLY WITH THE
LEGISLATURE ON THIS THAT YOU
KNOW IT'S MONEY FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE FROM THE ENERGY
COMMISSION VEHICLES FROM HARPER
WE ALSO HAVE YOU KNOW HOW FIRE
HEALTH HEALTHY FORCES OR THAT-
DEPARTMENT OF CONSERVATION OF
BIOMASS. ENERGY STARTED LATER
THESE THINGS ONLINE AND IT
CREATES A LOT OF PRETTY
COMPELLING STORY THAT WE CAN
PERSPECTIVES HERE AND- YOU KNOW
PROVIDE THAT OF COURSE THERE'S
THE CALIFORNIA BLUEPRINT PLAN
WITH THE GOVERNOR- AN OUNCE IN
JANUARY AN ENEMY REVISED COMING
UP WITH THAT HAD MONEY FOR
ELECTROLYSIS WHICH IS ANOTHER
REALLY IMPORTANT INVESTMENT AND
pWE'RE THINKING WE'RE ALSO
THINKING BEYOND MONEY YOU KNOW.
WE BRING A LOT TO THE TABLE AT
THE STATE YOU KNOW IT'S THE
MARKET CERTAINTY FROM OUR
REGULATIONS IT'S WORKING ON A
MASTER SERVICES AGREEMENT THREE
DTS WHERE WE HELP TRANSIT
AGENCIES- HAVE CLEAR
TRANSPARENCY IN THE HYDROGEN
PRICING THE MATCHING SUPPLY AND
DEMAND YOU KNOW IT'S THE PERMIT
STREAMLINING WORK AND THEN
THERE'S SOME YOU KNOW OTHER
STUFF IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S IN
DEVELOPMENT THINKING THAT'S THE
HEADLINE INJECTION AT THE TERROR
FOR ELECTROLYSIS IS KIND OF TO
BE DETERMINED BUT RATHER
THINKING ABOUT BUILDING CODES
YOU KNOW PERHAPS MAKING SURE
THAT. ARE RECYCLED WATER IS
AVAILABLE ONSITE FOR EXAMPLE
FINALLY I JUST WANT TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT TIGHTENING- AND
THIS YOU KNOW IT IT'S A BIT OF A
MOVING TARGET YOU MAY HEAR FROM
OTHERS THAT MORE RECENT INTEL
BUT YOU KNOW WE'RE EXPECTING THE
FEDERAL OPPORTUNITY ANNOUNCEMENT
COME OUT IN MID MAY THEY'RE
THINKING YOU KNOW LAUNCH ONE
WOULD BE FORTY SIX AWARDS YOU
KNOW KIND OF FORTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS TO BE YOU KNOW FORTY SIX
WEEKS TO RESPOND WITH A CONCEPT
PAPER AND WE DO A FULL
SOLICITATION- IN AT LUNCH TO- IT
WOULD BE IS TO BE DETERMINED AND
THREE AND BORIS KIND OF BUILDING
ON THOSE LAUNCHES ONE INTO THIS
HOW WE UNDERSTAND. THAT SO IF
THEY IS ANYTHING TO TAKE AWAY
THIS LIFE. WE TO BE IN. ONE AND
WE WANT AWAY TO LUNCH BY
ANYTHING WAY MAKE SURE THAT ARE
ORG. AROUND THAT INGREDIENT NOT
SHOPPERS. AS AND SO. WITH THAT-
THERE'S MY CONTACT INFORMATION.
RETREATED AS UP WITH FOR EACH.
TO STATE. YOU KNOW BECAUSE AS
RETHINKING ABOUT HYDROGEN
STRATEGY WILL BE UP. ON STUFF
OUT BUT I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY AND I'LL HAND IT
BACK TO YOU SENATOR ARCH ALETTA
. IN ALL THE CO. WILL COME FROM
THE PANEL AND THE PEOPLE-
CALLING IN. SO YOU DON'T GO
AWAY. OKAY WE NEED YOU TO STAND
BY. SO LET'S GO ON TO OUR NEXT
SPEAKER. AND OUR NEXT BAKER DR
SCOTT BRANDT- SPECIAL ADVISER TO
RESEARCH AND INNOVATION AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT. AND WELCOME
MISTER BRANDT OF BLOOD HAVE YOU
BOARD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING. LET'S SEE ONE SECOND
THANK YOU. YOU FOR DIVIDING THE
UNIVERSE IN CALIFORNIA THIS
CONVERSATION GIVEN THE CHANCE TO
SPEAK ON OUR BEHALF- MY COMMENTS
TODAY WILL ADDRESS THREE
QUESTIONS WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. HOW CAN
THE STATE LEVERAGE THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND
WATCHING A CALIFORNIA PUBLICLY.
AT FIRST WHAT'S IMPORTANT TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN A LEADER IN ADDRESSING
CLIMATE CHANGE AND A HOST OF
DIFFERENT WAYS THAT'S EVIDENT IN
THE LARGE NUMBER OF POLICIES
PROGRAMS AGENCIES AND
ORGANIZATIONS INVOLVED IN
LEADING AND OVERSEEING
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE EFFORTS.
CALIFORNIA'S ROADIES ARE OBVIOUS. GOVERNOR'S NEWSOM'S BLUEPRINT
HIS PRIORITIES ARE EQUALLY CLEAR
AS ARE THE SENTENCE BY VIRTUE OF
THIS HEARING TODAY GREEN
HYDROGEN IS AN IMPORTANT ELEMENT
OF OUR PLAN FOR THE FUTURE. THAT
WE SAW THIS LIGHT ALREADY.
ORDERLY AND I ASSUME EVERYBODY
HERE HAS SEEN IT BEFORE- IT
MAKES CLEAR THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS ALSO PUTTING HIGH
PRIORITY ON CLEAN ENERGY AND
HYDROGEN THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT
OF ENERGY'S HYDROGEN PROGRAM.
THE DEAL WE RECENTLY ANNOUNCED
AN EIGHT BILLION DOLLAR PLAN TO
FIND A HANDFUL OF REGIONAL CLEAN
HYDROGEN HUBS- IN THE WORDS OF
US SECRETARY ENERGY JENNIFER
GRANDHOMME. THIS IS TO SCALE UP
THIS CLEAN AFFORDABLE ENERGY
SOURCE THE CLEAN UP AMERICAN
MANUFACTURING AND SLASH
EMISSIONS FROM CARBON INTENSIVE
MATERIALS WHILE CREATING GOOD
PAYING JOBS FOR AMERICAN WORKERS
. SO WE AGREE WHAT IT SAYS ABOUT
CALIFORNIA. BUT TAKE EXCEPTION
ABOUT WHAT IT DOESN'T SAY. IT
DOESN'T MENTION THE CALIFORNIA
IS THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD IT DOESN'T MENTION
THAT IT'S ABOUT 12% OF THE US
POPULATION IT DOESN'T MENTION
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE GEOGRAPHY
ECO SYSTEMS. DEMOGRAPHICS AN
ECONOMY DOESN'T SAY THAT
CALIFORNIA IS A NATIONAL LEADER
IN CLEAN ENERGY AND CLIMATE
CHANGE MITIGATION AND IT DOESN'T
SAY THAT CALIFORNIA'S OBJECT
OBVIOUS LOCATION FOR HYDROGEN. I
CERTAINLY DIDN'T WANT TO JUST
KILL HER FAVOR BUT IT'S REALLY
CLEAR THAT THE HYDROGEN OF
BELONGS HERE. SO HOW CAN THE
STATE LEVERAGE THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA WELL YOU SEE IS THE
PREMIER RESEARCH UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM IN THE WORLD. IT
COMPRISES TEN CAMPUSES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE THREE
NATIONAL LABORATORIES TO IN
CALIFORNIA. EXTENSIVE STATEWIDE
NATURAL RESERVE SYSTEM IN
AGRICULTURE NATURAL RESOURCES
PROGRAM YOU SEE HEALTH SYSTEM
AND MORE. UC'S RESEARCH
ENTERPRISE REPRESENTS ABOUT
SEVEN BILLION IN ANNUAL
EXPENDITURES. YOU SEE HAS THE
PEOPLE THE TOOLS THE BIG IDEAS
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE WILL TO
HELP THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
NEEDED SCREEN ENERGY GOALS. THIS
IS ALSO DEEPLY COMMITTED TO
CLIMATE SOLUTIONS INTO PUTTING
THAT COMMITMENT INTO ACTION BY
DEVELOPING ENACTING CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS. IT DEMONSTRATES THAT
COMMITMENT THROUGH ITS ACTIONS
INCLUDING THE UC CARBON
NEUTRALTY INITIATIVE. USING
GLOBAL CLIMATE LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL AT LEAST YOU SEE APPLIED
RESEARCH WORKING GROUP. YOU SEE
DOES MORE GREEN ENERGY UC USES
MORE GREEN ENERGY THAN ANY
UNIVERSITY IN THE NATION AND IS
FULLY DIVESTED FROM FOSSIL FUELS
. I DON'T KNOW IF WE WERE THE
FIRST UNIVERSITY TO DO THAT BUT
I'M CERTAIN WITH LARGEST. YOU
SEE PRESIDENT DRAKE IS SPECIFIED
FOR PRIORITIES THAT WILL BE AT
THE FOREFRONT OF HIS EVERYDAY
WORK AT UC. AFFORDABILITY ACCESS
EXCELLENCE IN COMBATING CLIMATE
CHANGE. I THINK THAT'S PRETTY
EXTRAORDINARY FOR UNIVERSITY
SYSTEMS THE FOURTH ONE THE FIRST
THREE ARE KIND OF MOTHERHOOD AND
APPLE PIE. FOR UNIVERSITIES THE
FOURTH ONE IS REALLY
EXTRAORDINARY. IN HIS WORDS AS A
GLOBAL AS A NATION. IT'S REALLY
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
WORK TO REVERSE THE CLIMATE
CHANGE THAT WE SEEN CHANGING ECO
SYSTEM RIGHT BEFORE OUR EYES.
AND THE UNIVERSITY IS MEANT TO
BE A LEADER. UNDER PRESIDENT
DRAKE AND VICE PRESIDENT FOR
RESEARCH AND INNOVATION- DOCTOR
THERESA MALDONADO. THIS IS A
BRACING A COLLABORATIVE ALL OF
YOU SEE APPROACH HOLD YOU SEE
APPROACH TO ADDRESSING THE GRAND
CHALLENGES FACING OUR STATE IN
THE NATION. THIS IS COME OUT
THERE ARE DEEP PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE KIDS CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH- THE- AROUND
THE STATE'S COLD RESPONSE. IT'S
ALSO COME OUT MORE RECENTLY. IN
THE INITIATIVE TO HELP
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES BECOME
MORE RESILIENT TO THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. YOU SEE IS
COMMITTED TO PARTNERING WITH THE
STATE AND OTHERS TO ACHIEVE THE
STATE'S GREEN HYDROGEN ENERGY
GOALS AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE
TODAY TO TALK WITH YOU ABOUT
THIS. YOU SEE IS A NATIONAL
LEADER IN GREEN HYDROGEN
RESEARCH DEVELOPMENT
DEMONSTRATION. TO GATHER WITH
THE UC MANAGE NATIONAL LEAD YOU
SEE HAS A LONG HISTORY OF
APPLIED RESEARCH IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH INDUSTRY GREEN HYDROGEN. I
DON'T HAVE TIME TO GO THROUGH
EVERYTHING THAT WE'RE DOING. BUT
THER ARE MANY MANY EXAMPLES OF
MAJOR GREEN HYDROGEN PROJECTS
AROUND ONE SUCCESSFUL. AND IF
ANYBODY WANTS TO TALK ABOUT IT
AFTER WE'RE DONE I CAN GO
THROUGH MANY EXAMPLES BUT- JUST
A FEW OF THE USER UC IRVINE HAS
PARTNERED WITH SO CAL GAS AND
OTHERS FOR NEARLY A DECADE. TO
DANCING SALARY GROWTH IN GREEN
HYDROGEN ECONOMY. UCLA IS
WORKING THROUGH LA GRAND
CHALLENGES INITIATIVE. OF
INTELLECTUAL CITY TO A DIGITAL
VERSION STORAGE. AND LAWRENCE
BERKELEY NATIONAL LAB PARTY
COLLEAGUES MULTIPLE HYDROGEN
ARGUED PROGRAMS FOR VIDEO WE
SPENDING A PLATE TECHNOLOGIES TO
BASIC RESEARCH. AND I COULD
PROBABLY GIVE YOU A DOZEN MORE.
THAN I'VE GOT SLIDES. WE DON'T
HAVE TIME. TO GO THROUGH THE
COMMERCIAL. THE BOTTOM LINE IS
YOU SEE PLAY PIVOTAL ROLES COULD
BE A ORGAN. CATALYZE HYDROGEN
HUB HUNDRED HUB. PROVIDING THE
RESEARCH UNIT OF- NECESSARY TO
REACH TECHNO. MARKET COMMUNITY
GOALS AND PROVIDING THE TRAINING
AND WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
NECESSARY TO DEVELOP ABOUT THE
ROBUST WORK FORCE. TO SUPPORT
EMERGING EMERGING HYDROGEN
ECONOMY. SO HOW WE MOVE FORWARD. THIS IS WHAT WE ENVISION- FOUR
HUNDRED CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN HOW
THE PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP
FOR CLEAN CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN
NECKLACES THE- WE ENVISION
ABROAD PEOPLE CENTERED
COLLABORATION IT WAS PARTNERSHIP
ISN'T IS KEY TO COME TO SEE AT
LEAST. STATE AGENCIES WHO
REPRESENT THE STATE'S INTERESTS
NEUTRAL NON POP PROFITS LIKE
NOBLES ONE HUNDRED POLICY
INSTITUTE WE'RE FOCUSED ON OUR
COMMON GOALS INDUSTRY PARTNERS
WITH THE CAPACITY TO MOVE
TECHNOLOGIES INTO PRACTICE AT
SCALE AND WILL DO SO SPENDING
PRODUCERS CONSUMERS TRANSPORTERS
AND STORAGE LABOR UNIONS
COMMUNITY REPRESENTATIVES
PARTNERS IN DEVELOPING
APPROPRIATE CODES AND STANDARDS
PARTNERS IN WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AND OF COURSE YOU
SEE ANOTHER CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER AT. WE
ALSO IN HOUSTON VISION FOCUSED
INCLUDES GREEN HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION HYDROGEN
TRANSPORTATION HYDROGEN STORAGE
AND HYDROGEN NEWS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. GOING FORWARD.
THERE'S PLENTY OF WORK TO DO.
BUT THE IMMEDIATE NEXT STEPS IF
WE'RE REALLY GOING TO DO WELL
YOU'RE A STATEWIDE EFFORT INTO
FOUR REALLY GOOD AT. IT INVOLVED
EVERYBODY IN THIS EFFORT WE
REALLY NEED TO WORK ON
ESTABLISHING THE KERR CALIFORNIA
PROPOSAL T. AND GO SHOOTING
TEAMING ARRANGEMENTS ARE DOUBLE
THE GOVERNANCE FRAMEWORK- I
THINK THAT EVERYBODY HERE HAS
ALREADY BEEN TALKING ABOUT HOW
THEY'RE GOING TO PUT TOGETHER
PROPOSAL WHO THEY'RE GOING TO
WORK WITH. BUT IF WE'RE GONNA DO
A STATEWIDE EFFORT TO WORK
TOGETHER WE HAVE TO START
WORKING ON THAT IMMEDIATELY. AT
TO DO THAT WE ENVISION A
GOVERNANCE CONCEPT. WITH
MULTIPLE LAYERS. AN EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE A SMALL. EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE. COMPRISING HIM FOR
PRIMARY PARTNERS INCLUDING YOU
SEE A FEW REPRESENTATIVES OF THE
STATE HE CORPORATE PARTNERS AND
POSSIBLY OTHERS MUCH LARGER
STEERING COMMITTEE MEETING WITH
BROAD REPRESENTATION- THIS IS
WHERE IT BROUGHT ENGAGEMENT
COMES WITH THE STEERING
COMMITTEE MAY HAVE SOME
COMMITTEES FOCUSED ON THE AREAS
OF THE PARDONS FOR EXAMPLE OF
ENVIRONMENTALLY. ENVIRONMENTAL
AND COMMUNITY. S. THIS IS GOING
TO ENGAGE. EVERYBODY THAT NEEDS
TO BE ENGAGED AND THEN US
SUBGROUPS FOCUSING ON SPECIFIC
TECHNICAL AREAS RICHARD THE
COORDINATION AND COLLABORATION
WITH A TECHNICAL GOALS OF THE
PROJECT COMES WITH. FINALLY
WE'VE DEVELOPED TO SERVE NINE
PRINCIPLES THAT WE THINK HAS TO
GOVERN- HE CALIFORNIA. WE
BELIEVE THAT ANY CALIFORNIA HAVE
REALLY MUST BE STATEWIDE-
CALIFORNIA'S GEOGRAPHICALLY
ECONOMICALLY AND CULTURALLY
DIVERSE AND IT'S REALLY AN IDEAL
HYDROGEN TEST BED FOR THE
NATION- THE CALIFORNIA MUST BE
FREE CALIFORNIA'S LED THE NATION
IN ENVIRONMENTAL INNOVATION AND
POLICY AND GREEN HYDROGEN IS THE
WAY FORWARD FOR CALIFORNIA- THE
CALIFORNIA HOPE. WROTE MUST HAVE
RESEARCH AND INNOVATION AS ITS
ORIENTATION EXISTING
TECHNOLOGIES CANNOT GET US TO
THE TWO DOLLARS PER KILOGRAM THE
LEGAL NOR THAT ONE ONE ONE
HYDROGEN CHUCKLE. RESEARCH AND
INNOVATION HAS TO HELP DRIVERS
FOR. IT MUST BE ALIGNED THE
STATE INTERESTS STATE INTERESTS
HAVE TO BE BUILT DIRECTLY INTO
THE GOVERNANCE MODEL INSURE
THAT. THE HOBBIT IS FULLY
ALIGNED WITH THE STATE'S GOALS.
I'M IT MUST HAVE THE OBJECTIVE
AND UNBIASED. IT MUST REPRESENT
THE INTERESTS OF ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AS WE SAID
CALIFORNIA HAS A REALLY DIVERSE-
THE- CULTURALLY DIVERSE BASE AND
WE HAVE TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
ALL ENGAGED AT ALL STAGES- AND
THAT HAS TO BE IN THE GOVERNANCE
AND THEY HAVE TO BE ENGAGED
THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS AND THEY
HAVE TO BE PRIORITIZED OVER THE
DECISION. INTEGRITY AND JUSTICE
ALSO HAS TO BE CENTRAL TO THE
PROCESS THROUGHOUT IT HAS TO BE
PRIORITIZED IN ALL DECISIONS
WITH A FOCUS ON CALIFORNIA'S
DISADVANTAGED LOW INCOME IN
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES. FINALLY THE
WORK HAS TO BE MULTI
DIMENSIONAL. WE CAN JUST FOCUS
ON TECHNOLOGY INFRASTRUCTURE
ALTHOUGH THAT'S GOING TO BE A
HUGE PART OF IT THERE ARE ALSO
MAJOR QUESTIONS OF POLICY
ECONOMICS MARKETS. USER BEHAVIOR
IN SOCIOLOGY LAW EQUITY LABOR
AND-THE CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY.
UNLESS IT HAS TO BE CONNECTED.
IT HAS TO BE CONNECTED
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA IN THE
REGION. IS THE SENSE AGENCIES
UTILITIES OTHER HUBS. SO THE
CONCLUSION THAT IS WE BELIEVE
THAT THROUGH THIS- THE BIG
OPPORTUNITY THROUGH THE DELETE
WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
POSITION CALIFORNIA'S BENCHMARK
FOR THE NATION ONCE AGAIN THIS
TIME ONE THREE HYDROGEN SYSTEMS
AND NETWORKS. YOU SEE IS A KEY
RESOURCE FOR HELPING CALIFORNIA
BEACHES FREE HYDROGEN GOALS OF
THE DEAL WE TWO DOLLARS PER
KILOGRAM TARGET IN THE U. S.
HYDROGEN SHOT ONE ONE ONE CALL.
THE STATE CAN PLAY A KEY
LEADERSHIP ROLE. HERE ONE IN
DEVELOPING AND HELPING FUND A
UNIFIED CALIFORNIA PROPOSAL INTO
IN ALIGNING STATE AND FEDERAL
HYDROGEN PROGRAMS TO ENSURE
CALIFORNIA'S SUCCESS. AND
FINALLY TOGETHER WE REALLY
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN ACHIEVE
EQUITABLE SUSTAIN COORDINATED
AND SCIENCE AND FOR DEPLOYMENT
OF CLEAN HYDROGEN FOR CALIFORNIA
. THAT'S IT THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR. THANK YOU- WE APPRECIATE
YOUR PRESENTATION AND LOOKING
FORWARD TO THE- THE UNIVERSITY
WORKING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE IN THE ENTIRE STATE
OBVIOUSLY SO NOW WILL GO ON TO
OUR NEXT SPEAKER UP. AND IT'S
TERRY AND MINION CHIEF EXECUTIVE
OFFICER OF ALL TO SEE WELCOME.
THANK YOU US SENATE ARCHULETA
AND SENATOR NEWMAN AND I'M NOT
SURE IF ANY OF YOUR COLLEAGUES
TO JOIN YOUR WE CAN SEE OUR I
CAN'T SEE THE VOLUME THERE THE
DÍAS BUT- THANK YOU FOR OF THIS
CANADIAN FOR THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING WELL THANK YOU
SENATOR BEN ALLEN JUST JOINED IS
SO- CALL HE'S ON BOARD. A GOOD
FRIEND SENATOR THANK YOU FOR
JOINING AS WELL- WE JUMP RIGHT
INTO THIS AND I ALSO WANT TO
THANK GOBIZ FOR TAKING ON THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF COORDINATING
ALL OF US AND- AND- TAKING THE
LEADERSHIP POSITION HERE I'M
JUST ABOUT OUT OF THE WAY WHERE
WE GO- IS QUITE A FEW SLIDES IN
HERE THAT I USE AND OTHER
PRESENTATIONS I'M GONNA SKIP
OVER QUICKLY BUT THE STAFF WILL
BE AVAILABLE FOR. STUDY
AFTERWARDS SO FORGIVE ME IF I'M
GOING QUICKLY ON A FEW OF THESE
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME- I'M-
GOING TO GO. UP AND WE ALL
UNDERSTAND WHY WE NEED HYDROGEN
SOMEONE A SKIP THROUGH THAT- AS
YOU HEARD TYSON MENTION. THAT
THERE IS THIS NINE AND A HALF
BILLION THAT IS GOING OUT FROM
WHAT LEGISLATION FROM LAST YEAR.
OF FOR THESE HYDROGEN HUBS- AND
IT'S CLEAR WHY WE NEEDED AGAIN
I'M GONNA SKIP THROUGH THIS
BECAUSE I THINK WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THAT WE UNDERSTAND
THE POSITION OF THE
ADMINISTRATION. BUT CALIFORNIA'S
REALLY UNIQUELY POSITIONS FOR
THIS- AS YOU'VE HEARD BOTH FROM
DR BRANDON FROM TYSON- WE HAVE
THE FEEDSTOCK DIVERSITY THE AND
USED DIVERSITY. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY WE'VE GOT THE
LEADERSHIP POSITION- THAT- THAT.
YOU'VE HEARD ALREADY MENTIONED.
AND HERE IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE HAVE RECENTLY PULLED TOGETHER
WITH THE L. A. ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION. AND ALL
TO SEE A UNDER THE PORT OF LOS
ANGELES MANY OTHER PARTNERS THAT
YOU SEE HERE. COMPETING FOR
FUNDING THAT ALSO CAME OUT OF
THAT LEGISLATION AND FUNDING
LAST YEAR. FOR A BILL BACK
BETTER REGIONAL. GROUNDS AND- OF
THAT GROUP IS NOW POISED TO ROLL
UP ITS SLEEVES AND WORK ON YET
ANOTHER VERY COMPLICATED
SOLICITATION WHEN THE
SOLICITATION COMES OUT IN MAY.
BUT THEN BY ADDING. OUR
PARTNERS. FROM THE HYDROGEN
COMMUNITY THAT THAT MANY OF US
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH FOR SOME
TIME FOR THIS SPECIFIC PURPOSE.
SO WE FEEL THAT IN ADDITION TO
THE PEOPLE HERE FROM TODAY THE
PEOPLE THAT- GO BILLS WORKS WITH
THE OTHER NETWORKS. THAT YOU'LL
HEAR ABOUT THAT WE HAVE A VERY
POWERFUL ONE HERE IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA THAT CAN HELP. DRIVE
MUCH OF THE GOALS THAT WE'RE
LOOKING FOR HERE- THE KEYSTORE
LEADERSHIP AGAIN AS YOU'VE HEARD
IS THAT- WE'VE ALREADY GOT THE
RAPID EXPANSION OF RENEWABLE
ENERGY IN OUR STATE WE HAVE
THESE GOALS THAT HAVE BEEN SET.
IN POLICY. AND I THINK THAT
LEADS THE NATION IT'S SO. FAIR
TO SAY. AND ALTHOUGH CLICK
THROUGH THESE SLIDES VERY. IN A
THERE. LATER BUT HIGH. THAT
CALIFORNIA I THINK SHOULD BE
GIVEN A PRIORITY OR OTHER STATES
THAT HAVE LAID THE POLICY
GROUNDWORK AND THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WHEN WE SUBMITTED. THE
REQUEST FOR INFORMATION. TO THE
DEAL WE A WEEK OR SO AGO- ABOUT
THE HYDROGEN HUBS. WE SUGGESTED
THAT PRIORITY BE GIVEN OUR
SCORING THE GIVEN. TO ANY STATE
THAT HAS LAID THE POLICY
GROUNDWORK AND IT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT. BECAUSE OTHER STATES
THAT HAVE NOT THAT ARE GETTING
INTO THE HYDROGEN- INDUSTRY FOR
THE FIRST TIME. WILL THEN HAVE
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES ABOUT
PERMITTING AND SITING ON. SAFETY
ON ALL KINDS OF OTHER ISSUES FOR
THE FIRST TIME AND THAT WILL
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION. WHAT WILL
COME OUT IN MAY. IT'S GOING TO
EMPHASIZE THAT THIS MONEY NEEDS
TO BE SPENT ON THINGS THAT CAN
BE COMMERCIALIZEDRAPIDLY. AND
THAT'S ONLY GOING TO HAPPEN IN
STATES LIKE CALIFORNIA WHERE
WE'VE HAD. SUPPORT FROM. US
SUCCESSIVE ADMINISTRATIONS WHEN
WE'VE HAD SUPPORTING LEGISLATION
WHEN WE'VE HAD A WIDE VARIETY OF
POLICIES WHICH OF COURSE DON'T
JUST BENEFIT HYDROGEN BUT- CLEAN
AIR AND CLEAN FUELS AND-
TRANSPORTATION AND SO FORTH IN
GENERAL- WHEN WE'VE SET
STANDARDS THAT OF COURSE LEAD
THE WORLD. AND COINCIDENTLY JUST
YESTERDAY I BELIEVE IT WAS THE
FOR THE BY THE MINISTRATION.
REINFORCED CALIFORNIA'S UNIQUE
RIGHTS UNDER THE CLEAN AIR ACT-
TO SET STANDARDS. FOR VEHICLES
IN TERMS OF CLEAN AIR. ARE WE
ALSO HAVE- BEEN DEVELOPING CLEAN
FLEET ROLES AND ARE SOME OF THE
BIGGEST USERS OF HYDROGEN.
SOLUTIONS AND HYDROGEN AND
TRANSPORTATION SO I JUST DON'T
THINK ANY OTHER STATE COMPARES
WHEN YOU LOOK AT ALL OF THESE
THINGS IN GENERAL- IN TERMS OF
LEADERSHIP THAT IS THEREFORE
READY TO PUT THIS KIND OF MONEY
TO WORK. SO THE HYDROGEN HUB
THAT WE'RE ENVISIONING OUR ALONG
WITH OUR PARTNERS AND DR BRAD I
THINK YOU HAVE A GREAT OF-
OVERVIEW OF THE POTENTIAL FOR
COLLABORATION. WE'RE LOOKING AT
THINGS IN TERMS OF TECHNOLOGY
FINANCE AND THEN ONE UNIQUE
ASSET THAT WE HAVE HERE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA THE ALL TO
SEE CAMPUS. ALL TO SEE IS A
NONPROFIT THAT WAS DEVELOPED. TO
TO ACCELERATE THE BLUE ECONOMY
AND WE THINK HYDROGEN IS A VERY
IMPORTANT PART OF THAT FLOW
KANA- THE SLIDE DECK THEN GOES
INTO THINGS THAT AGAIN MANY OF
YOU MAY KNOW HOW IS HYDROGEN
PRODUCED ELECTROLYSIS IS ONE OF
THE WAYS TO DO THAT. WHICH CAN
BE DONE WITH- WITH- OF SOLAR AND
WIND. PARTICULAR ONE UP
EMPHASIZE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
WHAT WITH CURTAILED WIND RIGHT
NOW. IS THAT THERE IS WIND THAT
BLOWS AT NIGHT WHEN WE DON'T
NEED THE POWER OF THE SYSTEM
OPERATOR SENDS THAT OTHER STATES
ARE LITERALLY STEPS INTO THE
GROUND EVEN SOLAR. IS NOW BEING
PRODUCED IN. GREATER QUANTITIES
THAN WE CAN USE OUR AND- THERE'S
ENOUGH OF HYDROGEN IN THE WASTE
WATER THAT WE THROW AWAY EVERY
SINGLE DAY FROM OUR SEWAGE
TREATMENT PLANTS TO POWER THE
ENTIRE UNITED STATES
TRANSPORTATION FLEET. SO WE CAN
TAKE WASTE WATER AND THIS CHART
ARE- CURTAILED RENEWABLES AND
MAKE HYDROGEN OF AMONG THE VERY
MANY WAYS THAT THIS COULD BE
DONE IN THE STATE AND
DEMONSTRATED RIGHT HERE. WE ALSO
THINK THAT- ALTHOUGH. WE I KNOW
THAT THERE'S A- ABOUT FRESH. AND
NOW GAS AND VARIOUS OF FOSSIL
FUELS THAT WE DON'T WANT TO SEE
ALL OF OUR HYDROGEN FUTURE
COMING FROM. FOSSIL FUELS THAT
BIO GASES- IS A DIFFERENT ANIMAL
SO TO SPEAK. IT'S RIGHT NOW
GOING UP INTO THE ATMOSPHERE
FROM OTHER LAND USES LANDFILLS
AND AGRICULTURE AND- CONFINED
FEEDLOTS AND SO FORTH. AND IT'S
TWENTY SIX TIMES MORE POTENT
HEAT TRAPPING GAS AND CARBON
DIOXIDE. AND SO IT'S MUCH BETTER
WE THINK TO TURN THAT INTO A-HYDROGEN AND MAKE USE OF THAT
GAS RATHER THAN CONTINUING TO
DEVELOP THAT- IT'S IMPORTANT
UNDERSTAND THE SUPPLY CHAIN OF
HYDROGEN BECAUSE A LOT OF PEOPLE
WILL FOCUS ON GREEN HYDROGEN OR-
WHATEVER THEIR DEFINITION IS OF
HOW TO MAKE IT- AND THEN OF
COURSE THE COOL. USES AT THE END
USES THE CARS I DRIVE A HYDROGEN
FUEL CELL CAR. OF THE NEW TRUCKS
AND OTHER THINGS THAT ARE COMING
OUT USING AT OF COURSE
STATIONARY APPLICATIONS BUT VERY
FEW PEOPLE BUT LOOK AT THE
DISTRIBUTION UNDERSTAND THAT IF
WE DON'T GET IT FROM WHERE IT'S
PRODUCED TO WHERE. IT'S CONSUMED
OF THAT WE'RE GOING TO RUN INTO
BOTTLENECKS AND SO IT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO INVEST IN THAT KIND
OF INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL.
STORAGE GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO USE
HYDROGEN AS A MEANS OF STORAGE
EVERYONE THINKS BATTERIES WHEN
THEY THINK ABOUT STORING.
INTERMITTENT RENEWABLES OR EVEN
FOR TIME VARIANT PRICING AND
THINGS LIKE THAT. BUT HYDROGEN
IS SOMETHING WHICH I CAN ALSO BE
USED. AND UNLIKE BATTERIES
DOESN'T DEGRADE I THINK ANYONE
WHO'S LEFT THEIR CAR FOR TOO
LONG IN THE AIRPORT PARKING LOT
AND COME OUT THE BATTERY IS DEAD
KNOWS THAT BATTERIES DEGRADE SO-
HYDROGEN WHAT STORE DOES NOT.
AND DEEP DECARBONIZATION HEARD
FROM DR GRANT THE OPPORTUNITIES
THAT CALIFORNIA'S- OF LARGER
INDUSTRIAL SECTORS FOR
INTEGRATING HYDROGEN INTO THAT.
LIGHT DUTY TRANSPORTATION WE
ALREADY HAVE- FOURTEEN THOUSAND.
OF THE HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
VEHICLES ON THE ROAD TODAY FROM
ABOUT A HUNDRED OF THOSE OUR
TRUCKS ANOTHER HUNDRED BOSSES
THE ROADSTER LIGHTER DUTY. AND.
AND IT'S GROWING AFTER THE WAY
THIS IS AN ENVIRONMENTAL.
COMPONENT WELL IN MANY SAY THAT.
ARE TACKLE. MORE EFFICIENT.
BOUGHT OF NOT EVERYONE HAS
ACCESS TO A PLACE WHERE THEY CAN
PLUG IN AT NIGHT AT HOME OR IN
THE OFFICE DURING THE DAY. SO IF
WE WANT TO GET ELECTRIC VEHICLES
INTO THE HANDS OF EVERYBODY I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
DIVERSIFY. OF THE FUEL FOR
ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND SUPPORT
REMEMBER THAT A FUEL CELL
VEHICLE IS AN ELECTRIC VEHICLE
JUST LIKE A BATTERY CAR. IT'S
JUST THAT IT STORES THE ENERGY
AS HYDROGEN RATHER THAN IN A
BATTERY. AND WHEN WE HAVE TO
LOOK BACK A YEAR OR SO AGO TO
WIN THE TEXAS POWER GRID. WENT
DOWN FOR DAYS OF COURSE PUT THEM
IN THE DARK IF EVERYONE HAD BEEN
DRIVING A TESLA AND- IN TEXAS.
THEY WOULD HAVE ALSO BEEN-
WITHOUT TRANSPORTATION SO I
THINK IT HIGHLIGHTS THE
IMPORTANCE OF DIVERSIFYING OUR
ELECTRIC TRANSPORTATION. MEDIUM
AND HEAVY DUTY THOSE WHO DON'T
TYPICALLY CARE FOR THE LIGHT
DUTY APPLICATIONS OF HYDROGEN
EVEN THEY WILL AGREE THAT THE
HEAVY DUTY. YOU CAN EITHER MOVE
GOODS AND CARGO OR BATTRIES BUT
NOT BOTH BECAUSE BATTERIES TAKE
UP TOO MUCH WEIGHT SPACE. AND
BUT- TAKE LONG HOURS FOR
RECHARGING SO WHAT'S VEHICLES
OFF THE ROAD FOR A LONG PERIOD
OF TIME. SO IMPROVING THE-
ELECTRIC ELECTRIFICATION OF
HEAVY DUTY WITH HYDROGEN IS A
HUGE OPPORTUNITY. AND THEN OF
COURSE MARITIME AVIATION AND
RAIL- WITH LIQUID HYDROGEN WITH
OTHER FORMS OF TRANSPORTING IT
FROM WHERE IT'S PRODUCED TO
WHERE IT IS CONSUMED- PRESENTS
TERRIFIC OPPORTUNITIES AND JOBS
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT. AND-
CLEANER ENERGY. L. HANDLING
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND FUEL CELL.
IN THE U. TODAY THAT WAS AS OF
TWENTY TWENTY MORE EVERY DAY.
LOTS OF OPPORTUNITIES WITH THE
CONTAINER HANDLING EQUIPMENT
IMPORTS. TO HELP CLEAN UP THE
AIR ELECTRIFY THOSE SOURCES AS
WELL- I ONE OF THEM JUST
HIGHLIGHT BRIEFLY AS I MENTIONED
I'M THE CEO OF ALL TO SEE IN THE
PORT OF LOS ANGELES. THIS
PENINSULA THAT YOU SEE HERE IF
YOU CAN SEE MY POINTER. IS OUR
CAMPUS AND THESE ARE HUNDRED
YEAR OLD HISTORIC WAREHOUSES
THAT WE ARE NOW IN THE PROCESS
OF RENOVATING FACT I APOLOGIZE
FOR THE BACKGROUND NOISE
THERE'S- CONSTRUCTION GOING ON
HERE AT THE MOMENT. TO RENOVATE
THESE HUNDRED YEAR OLD-
FACILITIES INTO A- A
COMMERCIALIZATION CAMPUS FOR
BOTH HYDROGEN AND THE BLUE
ECONOMY. AND SO WITH THE
UNIVERSITY PARTNERS- COLLEGE
PARTNERS THAT WE ARE WORKING
WITH. TO INVENT THIS FUTURE IN
THE BLUE ECONOMY AND HYDROGEN-
THAT'S WHAT THESE. WAREHOUSES
WILL BE USED FOR AND THEN WE
HAVE THIS LARGE FIFTEEN ACRE
SITE THAT IRONICALLY USED TO BE
AN OIL TANK FARM. AND OTHER
TANK'S BEEN REMOVED THAT'LL BE
CLEANED UP AND THAT GIVES US A
PLACE WHERE FOR EXAMPLE IF WE
PRODUCE HYDROGEN. WITH THE TWO
POINT TWO MEGAWATTS OF SOLAR ON
OUR ROOFTOP. AND SEA WATER OR
WASTE WATER AS I MENTIONED
BEFORE. WE COULD PRODUCE IT HERE
ON SITE AND THEN. FUEL SHIPS ON
HARBOR CRAFT ON ONE SIDE AND
TRUCKS AND- CONTAINERIZED
VESSELS ON THE OTHER. HERE WE
ARE IN THE PORT OF. LOS ANGELES
TO GIVE YOU A SENSE OF WHERE WE
ARE. AND WHEN RENOVATIONS
COMPLETE OUR WAREHOUSES WILL
LOOK LIKE THIS WHERE INNOVATORS
CAN COME IN AND BUILD THEIR
PROTOTYPES DEMONSTRATE THAT
SCALE. OF THESE TECHNOLOGIES IN
THE BLUE ECONOMY AND THE
HYDROGEN ECONOMY. WE ALSO HAVE
ROLE UNDERWATER ROBOTICS AND BOB
BALLARD FOUND THE TITANIC HE IS-
LEADER IN UNDERWATER ROBOTICS
AND SENSORS OF COURSE AND IS
WORKING WITH US ON HYDROGEN FUEL
CELL OF VESSELS. AND THIS IS
THE- SCIENCE EDUCATION CENTER IN
FACT WERE- HOPING THAT THE STATE
WILL OF SUPPORT SOME OF THE
RENOVATION OF THIS. IN THIS
YEAR'S BUDGET. THIS IS THE PLACE
WHERE WILL HAVE- LABS AND-
CLASS. OF FOR UNITS. TO WORKING
ON THE BOOK AND HYDROGEN ECONOMY
- LAST THING I JUST WANT TO
MENTION WE'RE ALSO GOING TO BE
MAKING THIS A RESILIENCE CENTER
INTEREST OF TIME I WON'T GET
INTO THAT JUST NOW BUT THESE
WILL BE OF THESE WAREHOUSES WILL
BE A PLACE THAT IN EMERGENCIES
WILL BE POWERED BY. CLEAN ENERGY
ARE ALSO WANT TO MENTION FINALLY
THAT WE'VE ATTRACTED THE
INTEREST OF THE INVESTMENT
COMMUNITY AND WILL BE BUILDING A
FIVE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR-
HYDROGEN FUTURE FUND WITH OTHER
INVESTORS FROM HERE IN
CALIFORNIA NEW YORK THAT A
PLEDGE TO DO THIS ALONGSIDE A
HYDROGEN BOMB. SO GOVERNMENT
MONEY CAN BE USED FOR
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS FOR
INITIAL COMMERCIALIZATION BUT
THEN WE NEED INVESTORS TO COME
ALONGSIDE AND ACTUALLY- INVEST
IN THAT FUTURE. SO I THINK I
JUST TOOK MY TIME WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION AGAIN
WILL MAKE THIS A DECK AVAILABLE
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ONE TIME COSTS. WELL
THANK YOU SO VERY MUCH AND
PLEASE STAY WITH US BECAUSE WE
WILL HAVE QUESTIONS AND- WHAT A
GREAT PRESENTATION FROM- ALL TO
SEEAN END YOURSELF. NEXT UP WE
HAVE- JANICE LYNN WHO IS THE
FOUNDER AND PRESIDENT OF GREEN
HYDROGEN COALITION. OF THIS THEN
ARE YOU THERE. THE CAN YOU HEAR
ME THERE YOU GO THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH FOR BEING WITH US
TODAY. THANK YOU SENATORS I.
KNOW GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND FOR INVITING ME
TO JOIN ME. I'M HERE TO TALK
ABOUT HIGH DELOS ANGELUS HOW ARE
ARCHITECTING THE GREEN HYDROGEN
ECOSYSTEM FOR A DEEPLY
DECARBONIZE LA. I WANT TO- JUST
EMPHASIZE AGAIN AND ADD ON TO Y.
CALIFORNIA WE BELIEVE IS A GREAT
PLACE. FOR A GREEN HYDROGEN UP
AND THAT'S BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON ONE FOR ABOUT TWO
YEARS THERE WERE ALSO QUITE
AHEAD OF THE GAME- WHEN I PLAN
TO DO TODAY IS TELL YOU A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THE GREEN
HYDROGEN COALITION ARE WORK TO
DATE. AND WHERE WE PLAN TO GO IN
THE NEXT FEW MONTHS. WITH THAT
WE'LL GET STARTED SO REALLY
BRIEFLY ABOUT THE HUGE FEVER
FIVE OH ONE SEE THREE
EDUCATIONAL NONPROFIT WE WORK.
THROUGHOUT THE US BUT PRIMARILY
FOCUSED ON THE WESTERN UNITED
STATES OUR MISSION IS TO
FACILITATE POLICIES AND
PRACTICES. TO ADVANCE THE
PRODUCTION AND USE OF GREEN
HYDROGEN IN ALL SECTORS WHERE
DOES XCELERATED CARBON FREE
ENERGY FUTURE- I FOUNDED THE G.
H. TWENTY NINETEEN- I ACTUALLY
WITH THE MEETING THAT WAS HOSTED
BY TYSON AND GO VISIT IN
SACRAMENTO. AND FROM THE
BEGINNING THE G. H. C. S. FOCUS
IS TO ACCELERATE THE GREEN
HYDROGEN ECONOMY. BY LEVERAGING
MULTI SECTORAL OPPORTUNITIES TO
SIMULTANEOUSLY SCALE SUPPLY AND
DEMAND OUR PURPOSE IS TO FIGHT
CLIMATE CHANGE WE ARE ALL ABOUT
ACCELERATING CLEAN AND JUST
ENERGY TRANSITION- I DO WANT TO
DEFINE WHAT WE MEAN BY GREENHYDROGEN- WE ARE BIG FANS OF
CARBON INTENSITY AND WE HAVE A
BROAD DEFINITION. AND THAT IS
HYDROGEN THAT IS NOT PRODUCED
WITH FOSSIL FUEL FEEDSTOCKS AND
HAS CLIMATE INTEGRITY MEANING
ZERO OR TO MINIMIZE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS ON A LIFE CYCLE
BASIS. I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
PRIOR SPEAKERS FOR RECOGNIZING
THE POTENTIAL OF NOT ONLY ARE
ABUNDANT RENEWABLE ENERGY HERE
IN THE STATE BUT ALSO WERE
ABUNDANT ORGANIC WASTE
FEEDSTOCKS NOT ONLY. BY GAS BUT
ALSO BIOMASS. DID YOU CHEER FOR
THE LAST TWO AND A HALF YEARS OF
ITS EXISTENCE HAS BEEN SUPPORTED
BY A BROADER RANGE. OF GENEROUS
DONATIONS- TRULY REPRESENTING
THE ENTIRE ECOSYSTEM INCLUDING
STAKEHOLDERS FROM AS FAR AWAY AS
AUSTRALIA JAPAN GERMANY. IN
EVERY. STAKEHOLDER ALONG THE
VALUE CHAIN. IN TERMS OF ARE IN.
IN ADDITION I MANAGED ABOUT
IDEAL NORTH IN. ON IN A SECOND
BUT WE HAVE TO KEY INITIATIVES
ONE IS THE WESTERN GREEN
HYDROGEN INITIATIVE WHICH IS A
COLLABORATION BETWEEN THE GHC
NAZARIO THE WESTERN INTERSTATE
ENERGY BOARD AND THIS IS A
STATE. AND PROVINCIAL LEAD
ACTIVITY TO FOCUS ON REGIONAL
CLEAN HYDROGEN INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT. IDEAL NORTH AMERICA
IS OUR COMMERCIALIZATION
PLATFORM TO ACCELERATE- LOW COST
MASS SCALE DELIVERED GREEN
HYDROGEN IN TARGETED LOCATIONS I
DO WANNA GIVE A SHOUT OUT FOR
OTHER WESTERN GREEN HYDROGEN
ISSUE THERE- DR ANDREW
MCALLISTER- CDC COMMISSIONER.
HAS SERVED AS ITS VICE CHAIR
SINCE THE BEGINNING ALONG SIDE
OUT WYOMING AND MONTANA AND
I COMMERCIAL PLATFORM HIGH DEAL
AND- WAS THE FIRST HIGH DEAL
PLATFORM LAUNCHED IN EUROPE BY
ONE OF OUR BOARD MEMBERS. THE
IDEA BEHIND HIGH DEAL AMBITION
WAS TO ACHIEVE LOW DELIVERED
COST- THE IDEA WAS TO FORGET A
LOW DELIVERED COST WHERE YOU
KNOW YOUR VALUE PROPOSITION IN
EUROPE THEY TARGETED ONE FIFTY
EURO PER KILOGRAM DELIVERED. AND
THEN WORK BACKWARDS FIGURE OUT
WHAT'S AT WHAT SCALE WHAT THE
OUR SYSTEM PLAN AND THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT NEEDS TO BE
DEVELOPED TO ACHIEVE THAT LOW
DELIVERED COST ON WHAT HAS
HAPPENED IN EUROPE AS I'M JUST
LITERALLY TWO WEEKS AGO THEY
ANNOUNCED THE LAUNCH OF HIGH
DEAL ESPANA. WHICH IS A FUNDED
ARE VERY LARGE GREEN HYDROGEN
HUB SIX POINT SIX MILLION TONS
OF GREEN HYDROGEN OVER TWENTY
YEARS ELECTROLYTIC WE PRODUCED
WAS SEVEN POINT FOUR GIGAWATTS
OF ELECTROLYSIS PRODUCTION. TO
START IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE.
PART OF THE REASON WHY I
PERSONALLY EXCITED ABOUT GREEN
HYDROGEN IS THAT IT'S WITH GREEN
HYDROGEN WITH REIMAGINE AND
REPURPOSE THE ENERGY SYSTEM.
THAT WE RELIED ON FOR THE LAST
CENTURY WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT
EVERY ASPECT OF THE VALUE CHAIN-
WILLING GAS WE CAN RE USE SOME
CARD FOR ALL OF THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE. WITH THIS NEW
LITTLE TINY POWERFUL MOLECULE.
AND AS WAS MENTIONED BY THE
PRIOR SPEAKERS IT GIVES US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DEEPLY
DECARBONIZE ECONOMY WIDE GOING
AFTER THE SECTORS THAT ARE VERY
HARD. TO DECARBONISE AND WHAT WE
FOUND IS IT IS ENTIRELY POSSIBLE
SO WHEN YOU GO THROUGH- FIRST OF
ALL EVERYBODY KNOWS TODAY THE
GREEN HYDROGEN ECONOMY IS NOT
HERE BECAUSE IT'S TOO EXPENSIVE
THIS IS A OUR COSTS FOR ALL IN
HYDROGEN PRODUCTION COSTS NOT A
DELIVERED COST. COMPARING GREEN
HYDROGEN IN THE GREEN BARS IN
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD
COMPARING THE DOLLARS PER
KILOGRAM PRODUCTION COSTS
COMPARED TO BLUE AND GRAY
HYDROGEN. IN THE BLUE AND GRAY
BOXES AS YOU CAN SEE ACROSS THE
WORLD IT IS MORE EXPENSIVE THAN
ITS GRAMBLING COUNTERPARTS
THAT'S THE SITUATION TODAY BUT
EVERY SINGLE INDUSTRY ANALYSTS
AGREES. THAT AT SOME POINT IN
THE FUTURE CERTAINLY BY TWENTY
FIFTY GREEN HYDROGEN WILL BE THE
LOW COST ALTERNATIVE. AS SHOWN
BY THE- GREEN. GREENS AND DASHES
. THE QUESTION IS HOW DO
OVERREACH AND COMPRESSED THAT
REALIZATION WE CANNOT WAIT TILL
TWENTY FIFTY. WE HAVE A CHICKEN
AND EGG PROBLEM THE REASON THAT
GREEN HYDROGEN SO EXPENSIVE
TODAY IS BECAUSE WE HAVE NOT
SCALED IT. IS COMMERCIALLY
VIABLE AND BILLABLE TODAY BUT WE
HAVEN'T SCALED IT BECAUSE WE
HAVEN'T SCALED IT WE DON'T HAVE
THE NECESSARY STORAGE AND
TRANSPORT AND OTHER
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED FOR LOW
DELIVERED COST SO THE ANSWER IS
YOUR SCALE INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT AND ALSO IMPORTANTLY
MARKET DESIGN BECAUSE IT'S ONE
HUNDRED COSTS BUT ON THE OTHER
HAND. WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
FILL OUT TO APPROPRIATELY
STRUCTURE OUR MARKET AND
APPROPRIATELY COMPENSATE FOR ALL
THE BENEFITS AND THIS COULD
YIELD A VERY HUGE IMPACT AT THE
TIME THAT HE ACTUALLY LOOKED AT
WHERE TO START WITH HERBS WE
LOOKED AT A NUMBER OF LOCATIONS.
ON THROUGHOUT THE WESTERN UNITED
STATES AND DECIDED THAT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE- AMONG THE
TOP TOP PRIORITIES FIRST OF ALL
BECAUSE OF THE POLLUTION THAT
EXIST HERE WHEN YOU LOOKED AT
THE FIVE TOPS MOPPED UP SOURCES
OF SMOG IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
ALL FIVE OF THEM CAN BE
ADDRESSED BY GREEN HYDROGEN
INCLUDING AVIATION RAIL AND OF
LONG LONG HOMERIC TIME SHIPPING. AS JERRY MENTIONED. OUR VISION
WITH HIGH DEAL. WAS TO ESTABLISH
NORTH AMERICA'S. GREEN HIGH G.
INTO HIGH ADDS. THE FIRST TO
ACHIEVE A 100% RENEWABLE
ELECTRICITY THE CARBONIZED OIL
REFINING REDUCE SYNTHETIC
DERIVATIVE DECARBONISE FUELS FOR
SHIPPING AND AVIATION MAYBE
SOMEDAY TO PRODUCE FERTILIZER
HERE FOR CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURAL BUSINESS.
DEMONSTRATE ZERO CARBON YOURSELF
LIGHT AND SOMEDAY EXPORT MASCHIO
GREEN HYDROGEN WITH THE FLAG OF
JAPAN AND SOUTH KOREA. SEWER
CREW WHICH IS TO START WITH
OFFICERS. ON IN AND THIS IS
REALLY ACTUALLY FINDING AND I
THINK IMPORTANT FOR ANY. JOB
ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY- TO
REALLY GET STARTED IT STARTS
WITH THE OFF TAKERS YOU NEED
BANKABLE ONCE AND IMPORTANTLY
OFF TAKERS THAT ARE WILLING TO
GO FIRST. AND HAVE THE ABILITY
TO SCALE. SO WE STARTED IN THE
LA BASIN AND OUR- APPROACH WAS
CAN WE ACHIEVE SIMILAR EUROPE
THEY WENT AFTER ONE FIFTY EURO
CAN WE GET YOU. A DOLLAR FIFTY-
WE STARTED THIS EFFORT FOR PHASE
ONE IN MAY OF LAST YEAR WE
RECRUITED AN AMAZING PANEL A
VERY DIVERSE PANEL OF SUPPORTING
PARTNERS AND ADVISORS WILL SHOUT. OUT TO TYSON THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR. YOUR SUPPORT AND- OVER THE
LAST YEAR A HALF. AND I
BASICALLY IN PHASE ONE WE SET
OUT TO ANSWER THIS QUESTION. IS
IT A CRAZY IDEA CAN WE ACHIEVE A
DOLLAR FIFTY PER KILOGRAM
DELIVERED. BUT WITH THAT THE MAN
LOOKS LIKE FROM WHICH OFTEN
OCCURS WHAT INFRASTRUCTURE IS
NEEDED AND WHAT ARE THE POLICY
AND REGULATORY BARRIERS THAT
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED. SITTING
HERE TODAY WE COMPLETED PHASE
ONE AND NUMBER OF LAST YEAR WERE
ABOUT TO LAUNCH THESE TWO WHICH
ARE GONNA TALK ABOUT IN A LITTLE
BIT BUT FIRST ON PHASE ONE
FINDINGS I DID WANT TO SHARE.
THAT THIS IDEA IS ENTIRELY
ACHIEVABLE BY TWENTY THIRTY WE
CONTINUE. UNDER TWO DOLLARS PER
KILOGRAM DELIVERED BUT IT DOES
REQUIRE THE NECESSARY ASK YA
INFRASTRUCTURE. WE FOUND IT WAS
ONLY POSSIBLE WITH THE 1100%
GREEN HYDROGEN PIPELINE
CONNECTED TO UNDERGROUND
GEOLOGIC STORAGE IN THE NEAR
TERM AND THE MEDIUM TERM WE CAN
GET STARTED SOONER. IT'S GOING
TO TAKE SOME TIME WE CAN DO IN
BASS AND ELECTROLYTIC
PRODUCTION. WILL BE MASS SCALE
WE CAN DO SOME BLENDING AN
INJECTION IN THE EXISTING
NATURAL GAS PIPELINE BUT AGAIN
WE KNOW THAT THAT WILL BE MASS
SCALE. EITHER BECAUSE THERE'S A
LIMITS. HERE'S AN OVERVIEW OF
OUR HAN HE- DESIGN AT THE END
PHASE ONE SURE HERE- THE LEFT
THE OFF TAKERS CAN BE FOUND IN
THE SMALL BLACK BOX. AND ON THIS
GREEN LINE INDICATES A BI
DIRECTIONAL 100% HYDROGEN
PIPELINE THAT CONNECTS. ON VERY
LARGE MULTI SECTORAL OFF TAKERS
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. REUVEN
UNDERGROUND SALT DOMES IN
CENTRAL UTAH THAT'S THE LARGEST
PROVEN FALL DOWN IT HAS
BASICALLY UNLIMITED STORAGE.
THERE NEED BE SALT FORMATIONS IN
SOUTHERN NEVADA IF WE WERE ABLE
TO USE CLOSER SADDAM FORMATIONS.
FROM ABOUT THIRTY FIVE CENTS AND
THE DELIVER COST THIS IS AN END
TO AND COST- SO PROVEN TOTALLY
ACHIEVABLE TODAY IS A DOLLAR
NINETY FIVE PER KILOGRAMME
DELIVERED THAT'S WITH NO
INCENTIVES- NOTHING IT'S A PURE
COST- AT SCALE PROJECTION. ENTER
CAN WITH WHAT THE GOP IS TRYING
TO ACHIEVE WHAT WE SHOW HERE IN
THE MIDDLE IS A IS THAT EXPANDED
VIEW OF THIS SMALL AREA.
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE IT SHOWS THAT
WE HAVE OFF TAKERS NOT ONLY IN
AND AROUND THE PORT OF LA PORT
OF LONG BEACH AND AROUND LOS
ANGELES BUT ALSO POTENTIALLY IN
VICTORVILLE IN BAKERSFIELD AND
IT ALSO SHOWS IN THESE RED
CIRCLES THAT WE'VE UNDENGE.
RENEWABLE RESOURCE OUR STUDY FOR
PHASE ONE WITH LIMITED LECTURE
LYTIC PATHWAY IS ONLY JUST FOR
BY VIRTUE OF SCOPE. ON THIS IS A
ONE TO THREE MILLION METRIC TON
MULTI SECTORAL DEMAND PRODUCTION
PRODUCTION PER YEAR. BY TWENTY
THIRTY SERVICES- THIS VIEW WOULD
REQUIRE TWENTY SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN INVESTMENT THAT'S AN
END TO AND COST INCLUDING
UPSTREAM PRODUCTION FOR EXPORTS
DURING COMPRESSION. I WANT TO
RIGHT SIZE THAT INVESTMENT THAT
SOUNDS LIKE A LOT OF MONEY FIRST
OF ALL MISTER MEMBER A LOT OF IT
WILL BE COMING FROM PRIVATE
SECTOR. BUT IT REPRESENTS ABOUT
A QUARTER OF WHAT OUR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA UTILITIES WITH FANS
OVER THE SAME TIME PERIOD I
WANTED TO VOTE MY LAST MINUTE TO
TALKING ABOUT THESE TWO IN WHAT
WE'RE UP TO NEXT. WE ARE JUST
ABOUT TO LAUNCH ON FACED YOU
HAVE HIGH DEAL L. A. AS SHOWN BY
THIS BAR ON THE TOP. AND ON NEXT
STEPS WILL HAVE BASICALLY A
COUPLE OF REALLY BIG FOCUS AREAS
ONE IS COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT WE
HAVE TO DEVELOP THE COMMUNITY
VALUE PROPOSITION WE HAVE A
VISION FOR WHERE TO GO. THERE'S
A LOT OF WAYS TO GET FROM A TO
B. AND PART OF WHAT WE NEED TO
DO WITH THE COMMUNITY. I IS TO
EXPAND OUR GREEN HYDROGEN OXYGEN
CONTENT SO WE DID NOT INCLUDE
POTENTIAL DEMAND FOR LIQUID
FUELS FOR MARITIME SHIPPING
AVIATION. AND WE NEED TO DO
DEEPER DIVES ON THE NEEDED
INFRASTRUCTURE ESPECIALLY WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE AND WHAT IS THAT
NO REGRETS INFRASTRUCTURE WE
NEED TO INVEST IN TUESDAY. TO
ACCELERATE PROGRESS. OUR WORK
WILL BE. IN FOR MAJOR MAJOR WERE
STREAMS IN OUT WE YOU INTO TO
CORPS. VERY CLOSELY WITH EVERY
ON CALL LOCAL. AND REGIONAL. AND
OUR OUR GOAL IS TO WORK WITH A
MUCH BROADER TENT OF
STAKEHOLDERS EVERY STAKEHOLDER
IN THIS JOURNEY HAS AN IMPORTANT
AND UNIQUE CONTRIBUTION TO
PROGRESS. AND THE IDEA IS IF WE
CAN ANSWERING INNOVATIVE AND HOW
WE COME TOGETHER. AS A
COMMUNITY. AND ANSWER ALL THE
QUESTIONS THAT NEED TO BE
ANSWERED WE'RE INNOVATING IN THE
PLATFORM ITSELF AND THAT
PLATFORM CANBE REPLICATED
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
ULTIMATELY KNITTING TOGETHER A
COMPREHENSIVE NATIONAL GREEN
HYDROGEN STRATEGY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I WANT TO CONCLUDE MY
REMARKS NOW AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY FOLLOW- FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS. AND LOOK FOR
DIFFERENT COLLABORATING WITH
EVERYONE ON THIS MEETING. THANK
YOU AND THANK YOU MRS LANE AND
WE ASK YOU TO PLEASE STAY WITH
US BECAUSE THERE WILL. BE
QUESTIONS FROM THE PANEL AS WE
PROCEED SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION. NEXT WE'LL HEAR
FROM RANDY HOWARD- GENERAL
MANAGER REPRESENTING THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA POWER
AGENCY. WELCOME MISTER HOWARD.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN SENATORS FOR BY NICE TO
PARTICIPATE IN A QUICKLY GO OVER
WHAT'S GOING ON IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA YOU'VE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA SO I
ME. ME GO- ON WHAT WE'RE DOING
HERE IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA TO
GET TO THE CLEAN ENERGY FUTURE
ON THE PATHWAY TO HYDROGEN. C.
S. AS SHOWN HERE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY WHERE A
NUMBER OF COMMUNITIES IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA ARE FOR THE
SOUTH IS ONE POKE WE SUPPORT AND
SERVE ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND METERS WE HAVE ONE OF
THE CLEANEST- OF PORTFOLIOS OF
ENERGY TO SUPPLY THOSE NEEDS AND
CPA IS A POINT POWER AGENCIES SO
WE BUILD OWN AND OPERATE POWER
PLANTS ON BEHALF OF MANY
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES. OUT THERE
. AND- ARM AND CPA BELIEVES
HUNDRED IS GOING TO BE KEY FOR
THE ROLE OF OUR SUSTAINABLE
ENERGY FUTURE AND TRANSITIONING
JENNESS POINTED OUT FROM
TRANSITION EXISTING POWER
PLANTS- IN TRANSITION ROSE TO
HER PERCENT CARBON FREE ENERGY
SOURCE FROM NINETEEN NINETY A
TRIBUTE ITS- ARM OF A- DISPATCH
YLIDES FLEXIBILITY. NO NEW
TRANSMISSION REQUIRED FOR THOSE
FACILITIES AND LONG DURATION
STORAGE A WE CAN WE CAN
INTEGRATE WORTH OF RENEWABLES
HOW CAN ALSO UTILIZE. ACCESS
REMOVAL ENERGY FROM THE GROUP
THAT SUPPORTS THE PRODUCTION OUR
COMMUNITY IS REMAIN. VERY ACTIVE
IN BUILDING NEW RENEWABLE
ENERGIES WE SEE HERE IS THE CITY
OF HILLSBORO. FLOATING SOLAR
SYSTEMS THE LARGEST IN THE
COUNTRY IT'S ON THEIR TREATMENT
PLANTS WATER TREATMENT PLANT
FUND IS VERY VALUABLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. AND THE HOUSING THE
ABILITY TO PUT SORT THEIR
SELECTION UNITIES ARE STILL
DOING THINGS- ONE OF OUR MEMBERS
THE PORT OF OAKLAND WHAT AN
ACTIVITY WITHIN THE FOR LOT OF
MICRO ACTIVITY GOING ON
RENEWABLE DEVELOPMENT. THAT'S
STILL GOING TO OCCUR THAT STILL
NECESSARY. TO SUPPORT THE
HYDROGEN BUT WE ALL KNOW. WHEN
THE SUN ISN'T SHINING THE WIND
ISN'T BLOWING WE NEED TO BE ABLE
TO- PRODUCE POWER AND IF WE CAN.
WE CAN REPURPOSE SOME OF OUR
EXISTING FACILITIES SO MODI
ENERGIES WE DO NOT VOTE I
ENERGIES. THE WHAT I ENERGY
CENTER WAS CONSTRUCTED IN.
TWENTY TWELVE SO IT'S ONE TEN
YEARS OLD. IT'S A THREE MEGAWATT
UNIT WHICH- THE I FIVE. IT'S A
SEAMAN YOU'RE IT'S ONE OF THE TO
BE KIND OF. START NEEDED FILLED
TO SUPPORT RENEWABLE ENERGY IT
QUICKLY RAMPS UP BEFORE RAMPS
DOWN. YEAH SO IT HAS. THIS
REALLY GREAT HE RATE VERY
OFFICIAL COMES AND THEY ARE
QUICK. YEAH AND IT'S- IN A- TO
OUR KEY TRANSMISSIONS OF THE CAL
SELF IT'S ALSO A CHASE. TO
WESTERN- AREA POWER.
TRANSMISSION SO IT'S IN SAY CAL
. AND IT'S NEAR. THE END
CONNECTED TO EXISTING
TRANSMISSION. IT CURRENTLY HAS
THE CAPABILITY OF. 45% HYDROGEN
. IN TWENTY TWO. NCP INVESTED
ALMOST FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
TOWARDS THE INSTALLATION OF AN
UPGRADED TURBO IT IS CAPABLE OF
CO COMBUSTION OF THE 45%
HYDROGEN IS CURRENTLY
OPERATIONAL THE DAY. SO WE'RE ON
TRACK. TO TAKE THIS FIRST OF ITS
CURRENT A TO DEMONSTRATE THIS
NEW TECHNOLOGY. IN THE UTILITY
SECTOR AND THE FINAL COMPLETION
OF OUR HYDROGEN A CAPABLE
TERMINAL IS EXPECTED IN TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. SO WHY WHY WHAT I
CENTER ONE LONGTIME ENERGY
CENTER. AS I MENTIONED IT'S
LOCATED ALONG TO MAJOR
TRANSMISSION OR TRANSPORTATION
CORRIDOR AS WELL AS HAS ACCESS
TO RAIL. SO IT'S NEAR I FIVE AND
NEAR HIGHWAY NINETY NINE. SO
WITH THE INSTALLATION OF THIS A
HYDROGEN CAPABLE TURMAN NOW
ALREADY COMPLETE- WE ARE LOOKING
TO VENT AFTER PRODUCTION OF
HYDROGEN SO BUILDING OUT THE
ELECTROLYSIS SYSTEM WITHIN THE
FACILITY WE'RE J. SENT TO THE
CITY OF ROAD. A WATER TREATMENT
FACILITY THIS PLANT CURRENTLY
USES- RECLAIMED WATER SO THIS
PROJECT WILL NOT NEED TO ACCESS
IN FRESH WATER SYSTEM IT HAS
THAT CAPABILITY THERE'S EXCESS
WATER THERE ARE TWO DAY SO
HAVING A SUSTAINABLE WATER
SOURCE WE THINK IT'S KEY IS
SCALABLE WE HAVE A THOUSAND
ACRES OF CITY LAND ADJACENT TO
THE PROJECT. THAT'S AVAILABLE
FOR THE. EXPANSION THERE. YEAH
AGAIN BEING. CLOSE TO THE PARKS
OF THE NEXT WEEK NGF INSTRUCTION
ALSO HI WE HAVE NATURAL GAS
PIPELINE CURRENTLY IS FACILITY
WE HAVE UNDERGROUND STORAGE
NEARBY IT WILL BE CANCELED
COURT- HYDROGEN AND THAT WILL BE
PART OF OUR VALUATION GOING
FORWARD- LAWMAKERS. TO I HAVE
THIS HUB CONCEPT SO WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT HOBBS THIS IS OUR
CONCEPT NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. WE
HAVE NUMBER STAKEHOLDERS THAT
ARE THE JOINT OWNERS IN THIS
PROJECT. SO ONE OF THE LARGEST
OWNERS OF OUR PROJECT IS THE
STATE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES THEY CURRENTLY RECEIVE
ABOUT A THIRD OF THE GENERATION
FROM LODI AND SHE SAID. SO
THEY'RE CURRENTLY ALREADY A
PARTNER IN A- AND CONSISTENT
WITH THE STATE'S COMMITMENT TO
REDUCE GHG. ARM THAT'S THE
ORIGINAL REASON I GOT IN THIS
PLANT GETTING OUT OF SCHOOL
FACILITIES WE GOT INTO THIS
PLANT BECAUSE OF DEFICIENCY. AND
NOW BEING ABLE TO TRANSITION
THIS PLANT. TO EMISSION FREE
FUEL SOURCE SUCH AS HYDROGEN.
ISN'T FOR THE STATE'S GOALS AS
WELL. FROM NCPA WARMTH THIS SORT
OF PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
ORGANIZATIONS TO DEVELOP THE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA PACIFIC
HYDROGEN HUB. THE HOBBIT IS
INTENDED TO PROVIDE A
COLLABORATIVE UNITY BASED.
RESOURCE FOR FINDING TRAINING OF
PERSONNEL AND PUBLIC EDUCATION
AND ADVOCACY THE CURRENT
PARTNERS IN THIS HOUSE OR NCPA
IN THE OFF TAKER MORE ARE POWER
PLANTS. SIEMENS ENERGY WHICH IS
OUR TECHNOLOGY PARTNER YOU'RE
LOOKING AT THIS HOUSE AND THIS
FACILITY TO HELP WITH THEIR
EQUIPMENT DEVELOPMENT TO GET TO
THAT 100% HYDROGEN BUT ALSO
BEING ABLE TO EXPAND ON THEIR
WORK WITH REDUCING THE COST AND
EFFICIENCY OF ELECTROLYSIS. WELL
I ITSELF WHICH IS A KEY PARTNER
HERE AS THE OWNER OF THE LAND.
USE OF THE WATER. AND ALSO
IMPACTING THIS AREA THAT HAS A
NUMBER OF DISADVANTAGED.
CUSTOMERS AND- PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL WORK OPPORTUNITIES.
ONE OF OUR PARTNERS IS PACIFIC
GAS AND ELECTRIC. THEY'RE GOING
TO PRODUCE THE EXPERIENCE WAS
FINE HYDROGEN BLENDED FUELS
THEY'RE GOING TO CONTRIBUTE TO
THE EDUCATION TRYING TO
DETERMINE HOW THEY WILL IMPACT
HI PLAN STILL HAVEN'T DEDICATED
SPACE THERE TO STUDY AND
EVALUATE. HI PLANS LABOR ISSUES
REGARDING WORKING WITH HYDROGEN.
THE UC RIVERSIDE IS ONE OF OUR
PARTNERS IN THIS THEY'RE GONNA
HELP US WITH THE ADVANCEMENT OF
SCIENCE THE TECHNOLOGY
SURROUNDING THE HYDROGEN ECONOMY
AND THE IMPACT ON THE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND THEN THE
CONSULTING FIRM G. H. T. AND
WE'RE GOING TO LEVERAGE THEIR
INTERNATIONAL EXPERT EXPERTISE
WITH ESTABLISHING HYDROGEN HUBS
IN BOTH AUSTRALIA AND EUROPE.
HERE IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
TRYING TO BUILD THIS OUT. SO THE
EXISTING FACILITIES OR ARE THERE
AND ARE OUR PROPOSAL IS TO
EXPAND THOSE AT NCPA IS OWNER
OPERATOR. OF GEOTHERMAL HYDRO
SOLAR WIND WE SEE THE
OPPORTUNITY WITH THE OFFSHORE
WIND IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
FEEDING INTO THIS PROJECT AND
BEING ABLE TO USE HYDROGEN GOING
FORWARD. SO WE THINK IT'S
IDEALLY. THERE'S A LOT ABOUT
HERE IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA.
RIGHT TO MOVE THIS FORWARD- SOME
OF THE BENEFITS WE THINK. AS WE
MOVE FORWARD IS THAT WE CAN
UTILIZE AND IS JANICE POINTED
OUT IN REPURPOSE EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE. THAT WOULD BE
THE LEAST COST MOST EFFICIENT
WAY FOR US TO GET TO THIS. LOW
CARBON ECONOMY AND WE THINK WE
CAN BE BACK QUICKLY AT OF A
FACILITY LIKE THE ONE THAT YOU
CENTER AGAIN BECAUSE OF ITS
LOCATION IS ACESS TO
TRANSPORTATION. AND-
TRANSMISSION SYSTEMS SO- WERE
WORKING AS WELL AREN'T
COMMUNITIES FOR. A TO SHARE THE
FINDINGS WORK WITH OUR
COMMUNITY. TO GET THE
COOPERATION AND THE
RELATIONSHIPS WE KNOW OR CAN BE
NECESSARY TO BUILD OUT. I WILL
STOP THERE I LOOK FORWARD TO
RESPONDING TO ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MIGHT HAVE IMPROVED WELL THANK
YOU MISTER HOWARD GREAT
PRESENTATION I'M LOOKING FORWARD
TO THE QUESTIONS F THE
PANELISTS LAST TO STAY WITH US.
AND OUR NEXT- IS NEIL NAY EVEN
AND- NEIL IS THE VICE PRESIDENT
CLEAN ENERGY SOLUTIONS WITH. THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY.
WELCOME MR NEIGHBOR. YOU NEED TO
UN MUTE. THANK YOU SENATORS AND
I'LL JUST BRING UP MY
PRESENTATION AND NOW ERICA THANK
YOU WELCOME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WELL SENATORS ARCHULETA NEWMAN
IN ALLEN IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE
HERE TODAY HI MY NAME IS NEIL
EVAN AND THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
CLEAN ENERGY INNOVATIONS FOR
SOCAL GAS AND IT'S A PLEASURE TO
TALK TO YOU ABOUT HYDROGEN. AND
HYDROGEN HUBS- I AM GOING TO.
SPEND A LITTLE BIT OF TIME
TALKING ABOUT ONE OF OUR
PROJECTS THAT SO BILL GAS. WHICH
IS INTENDED TO SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO PURSUE
AND WIN. A CALIFORNIA Y.
ANDERSON HOW. OUR PROJECT IS
CALLED ENDLESSLY. IT IS INTENDED
TO BE OF THE NATION'S LARGEST
GREEN HYDROGEN OF PIPELINE. AND
WE EXPECTED TO BE A KEY PART OF
SUPPORTING ANY LARGE SCALE
DEPLOYMENT OF HYDROGEN IN THE
ECONOMY CALIFORNIA. SO GAS AS
YOU LIKELY KNOW IS A- HUNDRED
FIFTY YEAR OLD COMPANY THAT
SERVES. OF CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW
TWENTY TWO MILLION PEOPLE WE ARE
ACTUALLY THE LARGEST- GAS
DISTRIBUTION COMPANY IN THE
WESTERN HEMISPHERE- WE VERY
RECENTLY PUT TOGETHER A PLEDGE
TO BE JUDICIALLY NEUTRAL BY.
TWENTY FORTY FIVE THE PLAN
RECALLS WHERE TWENTY FORTY FIVE
AND THAT PLAN IS UNDERPINNED BY
ED AND ECONOMIC ANALYSIS AND
TECHNICAL ANALYSIS IT REALLY
PUTS HYDROGEN. AT THE CENTER OF
THAT PLAN. WHEN WE WENT TO
UNDERTAKE OUR EFFORTS TO LOOK
AT- HOW GOOGLE GAS AS AN ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE COMPANY COULD
SUPPORT. A HYDROGEN HUB. LOOK AT
THE OPPORTUNITY TO. LOOK AT SOME
KEY PRINCIPLES THAT WE THINK ARE
VERY IMPORTANT IN ANY
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT. IN ANY
PROJECT THAT ADVANCES
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE GOALS ONE
THAT IT ACTIVELY AND- VERY
DISTINCTLY SUPPORT THE WIDER
CLIMATE GOALS OF THE STATE. BUT
ALSO THAT IT'S SPECIFICALLY
SUPPORT THE CLEAN AIR GOALS FOR
THE COMMUNITIES WE SERVE
SPECIFICALLY THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE AND MANUFACTURING
. WE ALSO BELIEVE- FOR ANY LARGE
SCALE GREEN HYDROGEN- DEPLOYMENT
WE ULTIMATELY ONCE WE'RE WORKING
AT SCALE NEED TO BE LOOKING AT
THOSE HARD TO ELECTRIFY THE
FUNDING IS MANY OTHERS OF WEIRD
TO ME TO MENTION. THOSE ARE-
TRANSPORTATION ESPECIALLY HEAVY
DUTY TRANSPORTATION- WHITE
INDUSTRY HEAVY INDUSTRY THOSE
INDUSTRIES THAT NEED PROPERTIES
OF HEAT. AND LASTLY DISPATCHABLE
ELECTRIC IN A RESEARCH
SUPPORTING OUR ALREADY ABUNDANT
TRADITIONAL RENEWABLE
DISPATCHABLE ENERGY. WE BELIEVE
THAT ANY EFFORT IN THIS CASE THE
EFFORT AROUND OUR ANGELES LINK
PROJECT NEEDS TO INVOLVE
STAKEHOLDERS EARLY IN THE
PROCESS TO MAKE SURE THAT.
ARTUR'S OFF TAKERS SUPPLIERS.
THE ENVIRONMENTAL ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITY REGULATORS AND
LEGISLATORS HAVE A CLEAR VOICE
IN EVERY STEP OF THE DEVELOPMENT
PHASE. ARE ENDLESSLY PROJECT
ALSO HAS THE FULL BENEFITS OF
OPENINGUP THE DISCUSSION AROUND
THE DEPLOYMENT OF A CLEAN MODE
FEELS THAT MIGHT IN THE FUTURE
HELP FACILITATE THE RETIREMENT
OF THE LEASE OF IN. WHAT IS
ENDLESSLY ENDLESS LENGTH IS A
GREEN HYDROGEN FIVE ONE
PROPOSAL. AN INFRASTRUCTURE
PROPOSAL IT WOULD SEEK TO USE
THE CURRENTLY CURTAILED IN NEW
BUILD SOLAR AND WIND THAT'S WHAT
THE HELL FOR HIS OWN FAMOUS FOR
OVER. TO BREAK APART WATER. INTO
HYDROGEN AND OXYGEN WITH
ELECTROLYSIS IN MOVE THAT IN A
DEDICATED GREEN HYDROGEN
PIPELINE INFRASTRUCTURE. FROM
THOSE PARTS OF THE STATE THAT
ARE ABUNDANT IN IN RENEWABLE
RESOURCES. TO THE CENTRAL HEART
OF THE L. A. MANUFACTURING
INDUSTRIAL BASE SO ESSENTIALLY
OF THE LA BASED. WE NEED WHEN WE
DO THIS AT SCALE THE PROJECT
LIKE ENDLESSLY HAS THE
CAPABILITY TO REALLY MOVE THE
NEEDLE. FOR GHG REDUCING THE GST
IMPACT OF THE STATE REALLY.
THAT'S SKILLED ENDLESSLY COULD
WHEN FULLY DEPLOYED- ISSUES SHE
EMISSIONS FROM THE REGION BY
FOURTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION TONS
A YEAR. THE PROJECT ALSO HAS THE
BENEFIT OF ADDRESSING SOME OF
THE RECORDS OF THE HYDROGEN
ECONOMY THAT ALREADY COMMITTED.
TO USING HYDROGEN AS THE
DECARBONISING. BUT TO UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP OF THE LOS ANGELES
DEPARTMENT OF WATER AND POWER
THEY HAVE COMMITTED TO
DECARBONISING THEIR IN BASIN. OF
POWER GENERATION FACILITIES
CURRENTLY TODAY ARE BY NATURAL
GAS WITH HYDROGEN. WHEN YOU LOOK
AT THE OPPORTUNITY TO. REALLY
CLEAN THE AIR AND REDUCE GHGS BY
DEPLOYING HYDROGEN THEN YOU ADD
IN THE WHOLE BENEFIT OF BEING
ABLE TO DECARBONISE HEAVY
INDUSTRY AND HEAVY DUTY
TRANSPORTATION ESPCIALLY
TRANSPORTATION GOING IN AND OUT
OF THE AFFORDABILITY. IS THE
THIS IS TERRY MENTIONED. WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY REDUCE
THE USE OF DIESEL FUEL IN THE
HEAVY DUTY TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
. AT SCALE THIS PROJECT COULD
DISPLACE AS MUCH AS THREE
MILLION GALLONS OF DIESEL A DAY
. THAT IS THE CO BENEFITS OF
SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCING KNOCKS TO
THE TUNE OF. TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND. TONS PER ANNUM OF KNOX
NOTHING HE THE SITUATION OF THE
FORMS FONG. IN A REALLY
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES IN THE L.
A. BASIN AS WE ALL KNOW. THE
PROJECT OF THIS SCALE AGAIN A
LARGE GREEN HYDROGEN
INFRASTRUCTURE. BOTH PROJECT IS
THE CAPACITY TO DISPLAYS. OF UP
257% OF LA COUNTY'S LARGEST
STATIONARY SOURCE BUT THE REALLY
SIGNIFICANT OPPORTUNITY ENDED
MIRRORS MANY OF THE FINDINGS
THAT- JANET NGUYEN MENTIONED
BEFORE IT CAME OUT OF HIGH DEAL
. LOS ANGELES REGION IS THE LORD
IS THE NATION'S LARGEST
MANUFACTURING CENTER OF COURSE
WE'RE FAMOUS FOR HOLLYWOOD. IT
WAS FOR MOVIES AND SUNSHINE BUT
WE ARE ALSO THE INDUSTRIAL AND
MANUFACTURING CENTER FOR MUCH OF
THE UNITED STATES. AND WE ALSO
WILL THE TWO LARGEST PORTS IN
THE NATION. ALL OF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES INCLUDING THE
POWER PLANTS REPRESENTS
SIGNIFICANT OPPORTUNITIES TO
DECARBONISE. USING GREEN
HYDROGEN. INTERVIEW DECARBONIZE
ITS FILL WE REALLY NEED TO BE
THINKING ABOUT THE BENEFITS OF
HIGH BLOOD. I WILL ALSO MENTION
THAT WE SEE ENDS WITH LINKED IN
MANY OF THE PARTNERS YOU'VE
ALREADY HEARD FROM ON ON THE
PHONE THE NEW HEARING. IS REALLY
SIGNIFICANT PARTNERS IN PURSUING
THE FEDERAL DOLLARS HAD BEEN
MENTIONED BEFORE. WE SEE ENDLESS
LINK IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO COME
TOGETHER WITH OTHER PARTNERS IN
SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S EFFORTS TO
PURSUE THE I. A. J. FUNDS
SPECIFICALLY FOR HYDROGEN.
HYDROGEN HUBS BUT ALSO THE
BROADER FUNDING OPPORTUNITIES
AROUND HYDROGEN THREE HYDROGEN
IN RESEARCH. AGAIN WE LOOK
FORWARD TO- YOUR ONGOING EFFORTS
SENATOR GILLETTE UP. THE TO FIND
THE ROLE FEDERATION IN
CALIFORNIA AND- AGAIN I
APPRECIATE I LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR QUESTION. WELL THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH AND WE HAVE TWO
REMAINING SPEAKERS. LAWRENCE
GUYVER IN AT THERESA COOK SO
LET'S GO AHEAD AND GET LAURENCE
GARBER ON THE LINE SHE IS THE
CEO AND GENERAL MANAGER OF
SUNLINE TRANSIT. AGENCY MRS
GUYVER ARE YOU ONE. I'M FINE
THANK YOU CENTER ARGUE LET I'M
GOING TO GET NOW THAT NEIL STOP
SHARING I WILL GET MINE UP AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
TODAY WE'RE GONNA SHIFT GEARS A
LITTLE BIT. YOU MAY BE WONDERING
WHY SMALL OPERATOR IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY ABOUT A HUNDRED
FIFTY MILES EAST OF LA IS ON THE
CALL TODAY WE ARE ONE OF THE FEW
ORGANIZATIONS THAT CAN ACTUALLY
REMINISCED ABOUT THE FUTURE. AND
REYES PRESENTATION IS NOT MOVING
IS IT MOVING FOR YOU GUYS
BECAUSE IT'S NOT MOVING FOR ME-
WE SEE A PICTURE AND THAT'S YEAH
ENABLE BY. UP THERE WE GO CAN
YOU SEE IT CHANGING NOW YEAH. SO
THE REASON I'M HERE TODAY A
SOMEONE HAS A LONG HISTORY IN
ZERO MISSION WE WERE THE FIRST
TO TRANSITION TO CNG WE'VE BEEN
USING GASEOUS FUEL SINCE THAT
TIME THE FIRST TO- OPERATE
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL BUSES IN THE
FIRST TO OPERATE DISPENSED AND
GENERATE HYDROGEN FOR
TRANSPORTATION. THIS IS A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT THE FREE RUN TODAY WE
HAVE TWENTY ONE FUEL CELL
ELECTRIC BUSES- ON THE PROPERTY
WE HAVE FIVE IN PRODUCTION WE
ALSO ARE TECHNOLOGY AGNOSTIC SO
WE DO RUN BATTERY ELECTRIC
VEHICLES INVOLVED HEAVY DUTY BUS
AND IN OUR ON. A SUPPORT FLEET
AND WE JUST GOT ALERTED THAT WE
WANT TO EIGHT POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLAR BUS AND BUS FACILITIES
GRANT FROM THE FDA FOR MORE
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL VEHICLES AND-
THE REHAB OF SOME OF OUR CNG
VEHICLES TO GET US THROUGH. THE
TRANSITION TO ZERO EMISSION. SO
WHY ARE WE GOING TO FUEL CELL-
WE'RE GOING FUEL CELL BASED ON A
LOT OF THINGS ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT IS THE REPLACEMENT
VEHICLES- CNG BUSES REPLACEMENT
OF FUEL CELLS A ONE TO ONE
REPLACEMENT. WE DO RUN BATTERY
ELECTRIC AS I MENTIONED AND THE
REPLACEMENT FOR THOSE VEHICLES
TO KEEP THE SAME ROUTE PROFILE
WE DO TODAY WOULD BE ABOUT ONE
POINT FIVE TO TWO BUSES. FOR
EVERY CNG BUS WE OPERATE TODAY
WE ALSO HAVE A CHALLENGING
CLIMENT INTO POVERTY OUT HERE IN
THE DESERT AND FIND IF YOU'LL SO
RELIABILITY. IS EXCELLENT AND
THEN IT ALSO MEETS THE
OPERATIONAL NEEDS WE DON'T
CHANGE ANYTHING IN THE FUELING
CLEANING AND PUTTING TO BED OF
OUR VEHICLES AT NIGHT WHEN WE
TRANSITION FROM COMPRESSED
NATURAL GAS TO HYDROGEN. YOU MAY
NOT KNOW BUT WE HAVE A FEW VERY
SIGNIFICANT PROJECTS- SO WHAT WE
BRING TO THE TABLE FOR
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN HUB IS
ALREADY PRODUCTION FOR HYDROGEN
USED IN THE HEAVY DUTY SPACE. WE
DO OUT ELECTROLYZER RIGHT NOW
THAT'S FOR YOU SEE NINE HUNDRED
KILOGRAMS FOR DAY. IT IS A
SCALABLE UNIT SO WE ALWAYS PLAN
ON SCALING IT UP FOR PRODUCTION
TO OFF TAKERS. WE'RE ALSO DOING
A PROJECT WITH NEIL AND HIS TEAM
AT SO CAL GAS THEY EACH TWO
SILVER STARS. WHICH WERE VERY
EXCITED ABOUT BASED ON THE
SCALABILITY THE SIZE AND THE
COST OF HYDROGEN. AND WE WERE
ALSO AWARDED A CDC GRANT TO
BUILD AID LIQUID STATION FOR
RESILIENCY FOR BOTH OUR FLEET.
AND FOR THE COACHELLA VALLEY FOR
THEIR NEEDS FOR HYDROGEN WHETHER
IT BE FOR VEHICLE USE OR
ELECTRICITY. WE JUST PILOTED A
NEW TRAILER BY NICE AMERICA-
THIS IS A GAME CHANGER IN THE
STARTER SET FOR HYDROGEN FOR
FLEET OPERATORS. SOMEONE IS NOT
ONLY INTERESTED IN HELPING
TRANSIT BUT ALSO FLEET OPERATORS
IN THEIR TRANSITION TO ZERO
EMISSION IN HYDROGEN AS A
CHOICE. AS YOU CAN SEE THIS IS A
SMALL SCALE TRAILER THAT CAN BE
MOVED- IT CAN FUEL THREE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY BAR WHICH HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES AND TRANSIT USE BUT IT
CAN ALSO AND THEY ARE DEVELOPING
A PUMP FOR NINE HUNDRED- I'M
SORRY SEVEN HUNDRED BAR AND SO
IT COULD BE A DUAL STATION. ON
WE'RE VERY EXCITED ABOUT WHAT
THIS PROVIDES TO THEM THE
HYDROGEN ECONOMY FOR BOTH EASE
OF USE AND FOR SCALABILITY. AND
IT WORKS BEAUTIFULLY SUNLINE IS
LOOKING TO PROCURE WANTED THESE
ARE UNITS TO PUT OUR INTO YOUR
FACILITY SO WE CAN MAKE HYDROGEN
AVAILABLE TO THE EASTERN
COACHELLA VALLEY. AND THE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES OF THE
EASTERN REGION. WE HAVE SOME
FUTURE PLANS I SAY WE RENT
REMINISCED ABOUT THE FUTURE HERE
IT'S ONLINE- WE HAVE WITH THE
PROJECTS THAT I JUST SHOWED YOU.
WE WILL HAVE THREE TIMES FOR
HYDROGEN AVAILABLE PER DAY I'M
RIGHT NOW OUR FLEET DOESN'T
REQUIRE THAT. AMOUNT SO WE'RE
LOOKING TO SELL HYDROGEN WE'VE
BEEN SELLING CNG FOR TWENTY
EIGHT YEARS AND USE THAT REVENUE
TO PUT BACK INTO SERVICE TO OUR
COMMUNITY. AND SO LOOKING FOR
WAYS TO CREATE RESILIENCY WELL
THAT ARE FUNDING STREAMS AND ONE
AT TO IMPROVE AND EXPAND OUR
TRANSIT COMPONENT IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO US. I WE ALL ARE
ALSO LOOKING TO MAKE OUR
HYDROGEN COMPLETELY RENEWABLE
THROUGH A SOLAR MICROGRID. I'M
WE HAVE A PIECE OF PROPERTY
THAT'S KIND OF CHEATED THERE IN
THE AREA THAT WE ONLY NOW. AND
WE'RE LOOKING AT IS IN TALKS
RIGHT NOW TO BUY A PARCEL RIGHT
ADJACENT TO OURS. FIRST THAT
WILL BE SOLAR PRODUCTION SO WE
CAN. CREATE OUR HYDROGEN USING
COMPLETELY GREEN ALL METHODS.
AND THEN WE LOOK TO BUILD A
TRUCK PLAZA ON THAT- PIECE OF
LAND. ON THIS WOULD BE FOR THE
HEAVY DUTY SECTOR TO USE- FOR AN
OPPORTUNITY FUEL IT. YOU'LL AS
THEY GET INTO THE LA BASIN AND
CONGESTION LA. AND ALSO AS THEY
LA BASIN AND POINTS EAST ON THE
I. TEN CORRIDOR- THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT- WE'RE GOING TO
USE. WITH THE ALREADY BE- THE
ATTRIBUTES WE HAVE AVAILABLE TO
US SO THEY'RE ALREADY
INTERCHANGES IN BOTH DIRECTIONS
ON THE I. TEN CORRIDOR. THAT
WOULD MAKE EASE OF USE FOR THIS
STATION FOR TRUCKS MOVING DOWN.
THE I. TEN CORRIDOR IN BOTH
DIRECTIONS AVAILABLE EASY AND
QUICK. I ALSO WANT TO SHOW YOU
WHERE SUNLINE IS IN RELATION TO
SOME OF THE OTHER PROJECTS AND
ARE SOME OF MY SPEAKER PARTNERS-
WE ARE A HUNDRED FIFTY MILES
FROM LA AND A HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE MILES FROM THE PORT OF. LOS
ANGELES MAKING US A KEY STOPPING
POINT FOR FREIGHT MOVING ITS WAY
TO THE EAST OR COMING INTO THE
PORT WITH THOSE OPPORTUNITY
FEELS AS I MENTIONED. THE LAST
THING I WANT TO TALK ABOUT IS
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT. AND WE
TALKED ABOUT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT SUNLINE IS ALSO
BUILDING A WEST COAST OF X. IT
IS COMPLETELY- DEDICATED TO THE
WORK TRANSITION OF WORKFORCE IN
ZERO EMISSION TECHNOLOGY
RENEWABLE ENERGY- WE ARE GOING
TO BUILD THIS. ON OUR FACILITY I
MEAN THIS IS JUST A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE SCHEDULE SUNLINE WON A
GRANT FROM THE FTA FOR THIS
FACILITY AS WELL AND HAS PUT
SOME OF ITS OWN MONEY BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR
TRANSITIONING. THE WORKFORCE
THAT ARE CURRENTLY WORKING
COMBUSTION ENGINE OR FOSSIL
FUEL. TECHNOLOGIES INTO ZERO
MISSION NOW WE CAN BE NOT ONLY
TRANSFER THOSE SKILLS TO. THE
WORKFORCE OF THE FUTURE BUT ALSO
INCENTIVIZE NEW STUDENTS. IN
LEARNING HOW TO OPERATE AND
MAINTAIN THESE. EXCITING
TECHNOLOGIES. I'M THIS IS WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO BUILD THE STREET
SCHOOL RIGHT ON OUR PROPERTY
GIVES YOU A LITTLE AERIAL. VIEW
LOOK THERE TO THE RIGHT OF WERE
REPLIED THIS OP STILL BEING
BURNT BUILT THAT IS OUR CURRENT
STATION. AT SOME POINT WE PLAN
FOR THAT TO BE A LIGHT DUTY
STATION FOR HYDROGEN. ARE WE
WILL SELL CNG THERE AS WELL AS
WE TRANSITION OVER- BUT THAT
GIVES US BOTH THE LIGHT DUTY
STATION AND. A HEAVY DUTY
STATION FOR THE FUTURE. WE HAVE
AN INVITE. BOARD OVER OUR SCHOOL
IT'S THE MAJOR MANUFACTURERS
WERE BUILDING HEAVY DUTY FUEL
CELL BUSES AND COMPONENTS. THEY
GUIDE THE TRAINING AND THE
DIRECTION OF THE OF THE WEST
COAST CENTER OF EXCELLENCE. AND
THEY'VE BEEN REALLY HELPFUL IN
US GETTING THIS TRAINING READY
FOR THE WORKFORCE. THESE ARE
SOME OF THE MODULES THAT ARE
ALREADY READY TO TRAIN- AND
THEY'RE INCLUDE NOT ONLY
PREPARING A TECHNICIAN TO
OPERATE ON THESE KINDS OF
VEHICLES BUT ALSO AN
ORGANIZATION FOR GETTING READY
FOR ZERO MISSION DEPLOYMENT. AND
CREATING A LEADERSHIP AND FOCUS
WITHIN THEIR ORGANIZATIONS TO
MAKE SURE THESE DEPLOYMENTS ARE
SUCCESSFUL. WE KNOW THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR AN ENTIRE
ORGANIZATION WHETHER IT'S A
PRIVATE FLEET PROVIDER OR
TRANSIT AGENCY. TO UNDERSTAND
THIS TECHNOLOGY TO ENSURE THAT
THERE'S A VISION SO THAT
SUCCESSFUL DEPLOYMENTS TAKE
PLACE. AND WITH THAT I WILL
YIELD MY TIME SENATORS LETTER
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY WELL THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH AND- JUST TO LET YOU
KNOW WE HAVE QUITE A FEW CITIES.
THAT ARE LOOKING IN THAT ARE-
HOPING TO FOLLOW SUIT. WHAT A
GREAT LEADER YOU ARE. IN YOUR-
IN YOUR CITY. OKAY LET'S GO
AHEAD AND- BRING UP OUR LAST AND
NOT LEAST- TO RESTRICT CUCKOOS A
GONNA CLOSES OUT WITH OUR
SPEAKERS. TO RESTRICT EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR. AT THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN COALITION- THIS IS GOOD
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US AND
WE LOOK FORWARD. TO YOUR
TESTIMONY AND THE INFORMATION.
THANK YOU SENATOR HI GOOD
AFTERNOON- MEMBERS TO READ THE
COOKING SECOND DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN COALITION
AND- WHEN I JUST REALLY I. FOR
US THE STAFF AND THE COMMITTEE-
APPRECIATION FOR THE
CONVERSATION AND THAT- YOU KNOW
WELL TIME VERY IMPORTANT. I AM
VERY EXCITED TO DISCUSS WAYS BE
COMMITTEE TODAY HOW HYDROGEN
MOBILITY IT INTO THE TOP
OPPORTUNITY. AND THE GOAL FROM
THE HEALTH PROTECTION COALITION-
CLUB IS NOT JUSTICE- INVESTMENT
IN HYDROGEN BUT TO BUILD A
RESILIENT HEALTH EFFICIENT AND
CLIMATE CONSCIOUS. HYDROGEN
ECONOMY THAT NOT JUST THEIR
ENERGY BUT TRANSPORTATION AS
WELL I'M ALL OF THE SPEAKERS
THAT WENT BEFORE ME I'D
DEFINITELY INCLUDED
TRANSPORTATION IS A BIG PART OF
THEIR PROJECT RECOMMENDATIONS
AND FOR THAT YOU KNOW WE
APPRECIATED WE DEFINITELY
SUPPORT. THAT ELEMENT PLAYING A
ROLE IN A CALIFORNIA HUB AS
OPPOSED TO HAVING JUST ON THIS
EXCLUSIVELY ENERGY OR ONE THAT'S
EXCLUSIVELY TRANSPORTATION LET'S
JUST I'LL BRING IT IN UNDER. THE
UMBRELLA IS ONE. I STARTING OFF
WITH YOU KNOW OUR OUR- I JUST A
LITTLE BACKGROUND ON THIS.
CALIFORNIA WE'VE BEEN. IN OF A
THERMOS BE A FROM WITH. LIKE OUR
DANCE THE PLATE REGULATION. JUST
A REMINDER OF YOU KNOW THE
REGULAR ARE GONNA BEGIN TO TAKE
IT BACK TO TWENTY FIVE FOUR SO
EACH THE QUICKLY- OUR ENEMY.
CLEAN TRANSIT REGULATION
COULDN'T FROM HER MORE ABOUT
LAWRENCE HOWEVER YOU KNOW BEING
A ROCKSTAR I'D AM SURE IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE. AND ENTERED YOUR
MACHINE PEOPLE REGULATION ARE
PASSENGER VEHICLES ON THE ROAD-
AND WITH SUPPORTING POLICIES
LIKE THE LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD AND THE GREEN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM WE ALSO
HAVE THE DEVELOPMENT OF-
CHARGING AND HYDROGEN FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IS
INCREDIBLY. IMPORTANT SO TO A
POINT MADE EARLIER BY TERRY
CANNON AND THEN OTHERS GIVEN THE
INVESTMENTS THAT CALIFORNIA
ALREADY HAS IN A REGULATORY AND
POLICY FRAMEWORK AROUND YOUR
MACHINE VEHICLES WE DEFINITELY
THINK THERE SHOULD BE A
CORNERSTONE FOR CALIFORNIA UP.
WHAT I OPERATE SECOND
RECOMMENDATION THAT WE LEVERAGE
THIS FEDERAL OPPORTUNITY- TO
TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE PRIVATE
SECTOR INVESTMENTS- THAT WE ARE
GOING TO BE IN HYDROGEN TO
CREATE A SELF SUSTAINING
HYDROGEN ECONOMY. I'M THE TYPE
AND IN YOUR ADDRESS MANY EARLIER
HE NOTED THAT PUBLIC POLICY
SUPPORT THAT SORT OF LAUNCH OF
HYDROGEN BY PRIVATE ACTORS WHAT
IS GOING TO SCALE BACK AND- THAT
WAS JUST A ROBUST YOU KNOW
AGREEMENT THAT CALIFORNIA HAD
DURING COALITION FOR THAT. POINT
YOU KNOW BETTER UNDERSCORED BY
THE FACT THAT THEIR RESOURCES
BOARD FINDS THAT 90% OF THE
HYDROGEN FUELING NETWORK COSTS
ARE GOING TO BE BORNE BY THE
PRIVATE SECTOR. AND SO IF WE CAN
ENCOURAGE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO FINISH THE LAUNCH
OF THE HYDROGEN FUELING NETWORK
THAT'LL PLAY VERY NICELY INTO
THE TUB PROJECT THAT WE'RE
HOPING TO BRING TO CALIFORNIA-
AND MANY OF YOU KNOW- WAY THREE
HUNDRED MILLION WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO FINISH THE BUILD OUT AT THE
LIGHT. AND MEDIUM DUTY HYDROGEN
FUELING THAT WORK THROUGHOUT THE
OF. THAT WOULD RESULT IN ONE.
HYDROGEN STATION HELLO OKAY AT
A- CAFES. FIGHTING NINE SEVEN
PER FUEL COVERAGE DISAPPEAR
COMMUNITIES AND 94% OF THE-
STATE. WE WOULD ALL RECOMMEND
THE STATE- LAUNCHED THE HEAVY
DUTY FUELING NETWORK- AND YOU
KNOW AGAIN JUST IN TIME FOR OUR
ADVANCE CLEAN FLEETS REGULATION-
SO WE ARE URGING THE LEGISLATURE
TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT AB TWO HUNDRED HEAVY
DUTY FUELING STATION. THANKS TWO
HUNDRED STATIONS WOULD PROVIDE
SEVENTY THOUSAND- FUELING
SUPPORT FOR SEVENTY THOUSAND
TRACKS THAT WERE ABLE TO DO
QUITE A BIT- WITH RELATIVELY
LITTLE. I'M INVESTMENT HERE-
DRIVE COST REDUCTIONS IN VEHICLE
STATION EQUPMENT AND YOU ALSO
FEEL KIND OF OUR ALIGNMENT THAT
JANET PLAN MENTIONED EARLIER
THIS IS REALLY A NO REGRETS
STRATEGY I YOU KNOW AND HYDROGEN
MOBILITY THAT WE ARE SPEAKING.
AND I WOULD ALSO ARGUE THAT IT'S
A MONTHS BEFORE WE GET INTO RAIL
AVIATION AND MARINE EITHER AREAS
THAT ARE GOING TO BE CONSUMING
AN AWFUL LOT OF HYDROGEN. USING
AN AWFUL LOT OF EQUIPMENT SO TO
THE EXTENT THAT WE CAN BE IN
THESE INVESTMENTS NOW WE ARE
BETTER ABLE TO. PROVIDE
IMPORTANT COST REDUCTION IN A
QUICK MANNER GOING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND- FUEL CELLS
THEMSELVES. I BEFORE MOVING ON
HIGHEST ONE OFFERED THAT YOU
KNOW BASED ON OUR EXPERIENCE
WOULD REALLY RECOMMEND THAT
FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE COME
FIRST AS WE HAVE FOUND IN THE
LATE TO THE MARKET. CUSTOMERS IN
PHILADELPHIA AND ATHLETE
OPERATORS ARE NOT GOING TO
TRANSITION YOU FEEL HEALTHIER
COLDER HERE EMISSION VEHICLE
ALTERNATIVE. IF THE FUELING IS
UNAVAILABLE THAT IS- TROOPER
HYDROGEN JUST LIKE IT IS FOR
CHARGING. AND I WOULD OFFER THAT
THE SIMULTANEOUS DEVELOPMENT OF
FUEL DEALING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
VEHICLE DEPLOYMENT IN SOME WAYS
KIND OF CONSTRAINED THE MARKET
AGAIN REALLY URGING WE LEAD WITH
AN INFRASTRUCTURE FIRST- POLICY
. SHINNING OVER TO- CAL HYDROGEN
. IS THOROUGHLY CAN YOUR- AND
ZERO HIGH. BUT IN THE NEAR TERM
THINK WE HAVE TO REAL. ABOUT PER
IN. SUPPLY OF HIGH THAT IS ALSO
AFFORDABLE YOU KNOW IT'S EARLY
JUNCTURE LET'S NOT PRECLUDE
OTHER PRODUCTION PATHWAY THE
LET'S BUILD TOWARD WHAT WE WANT
IN THE FUTURE. DIGGING A BIT
DEEPER ON PRODUCTION STARTING
WITH ELECTROLYTIC- YOU KNOW I
WON'T REPEAT THAT GOOD WORK THAT
THE SPEAKERS I HAD OFFERED. BUT
I DO BELIEVE THERE IS SOME
POLICY WORK THAT IS NEEDED BY
THE LEGISLATURE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION AND TIGHT SO. AROUND
THE INDUSTRIAL RATE FOR-
RENEWABLE POWER WHICH IS GOING
TO BE CRITICAL TO SUPPORT
ELECTROLYTES HERS AND TO MAKE
THAT A COST COMPETITIVE
TECHNOLOGY. SO AGAIN
RECOMMENDING SOME POLICY
WORKAROUNDS CREATING WHOLESALE
RATE FOR ACCESS RENEWABLE POWER
SO THAT WE CAN MAKE ELECTROLYZER
ELECTROLYTES OR SUCH FOR COST
COMPETITIVE. I'M USING BIO MATHS
MAKE RENEWABLE HYDROGEN- THAT
WAS DISCUSSED BY SPEAKERS-
BEFORE ME I JUST WANT TO OFFER
THAT LAWRENCE LIVERMORE IN ITS
GETTING TO NEUTRAL REPORT.
IDENTIFIED THESE ORGANIC WASTE
PRODUCTS THESE- BIOMASS PRODUCTS
IS ONE OF THE HIGHEST AND BEST
USE THAT IS AND YOU KNOW WHAT
THE METHANE EMITTING PRODUCTS
FOR RENEWABLE HYDOGEN
PRODUCTION AND SO VERY EXCITED
ABOUT. THE ROLE THAT THAT
PATHWAY WILL PLAY NOT ONLY IN
PROVIDING. RENEWABLE HYDROGEN
FUEL BUT ALSO IMPORTANT CO
BENEFITS. LIKE METHANE REDUCTION
. BEFORE CLOSING I'VE JUST ARE
THE- KNOW WORK COULD BE- Q. KIND
OF LEVERAGE THE FEDERAL HAVE
OPPORTUNITY RELATED TO THE PER.
I HAVE A HIGH FUELING STATIONS
HYDROGEN PRODUCTION PROJECT
ETCETERA- YOU KNOW WE HAVE A
GOOD. TIME IN CALIFORNIA OR WHAT
ARE KNOWN AS LEADERSHIP PROJECT
I EIGHTY NINE HUNDRED PROJECTS
AND SO I THINK THAT YOU KNOW THE
BUILD OUT OF WHATEVER HYDROGEN
HUB. IS A GOOD CANDIDATE TO
QUALIFY FROM SOME OF THOSE
REQUESTS STREAMLINING- I. AND
THEN ALSO- MORE WORK NEEDS TO BE
DONE ON FUEL DISTRIBUTION VIA
PIPELINE THAT WAS SOMETHING THAT
JANET NGUYEN MENTIONED AND HER
COMMENT IS SOMETHING THAT YOU
KNOW WE WOULD WHOLEHEARTEDLY
ENDORSED- AND BEFORE I FINISH
OFF I JUST WANNA YOU KNOW
OFFERED THAT. A COMPREHENSIVE
HAVE BEEN CALIFORNIA THAT IS
INCLUSIVE OF TRANSPORTATION AND
ENERGY WOULD BE INCREDIBLY
TRANSFORMATIVE FOR THE STATE.
IT'S A SINGULAR OPPORTUNITY TO
SCALE INDUSTRY IF WE LEAVE WITH
THE SAME ABILITY HEALTH
EFFICIENCY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
INTEGRITY AND MINES- AND TO THAT
END WE VERY MUCH LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE REST OF OUR YOU
KNOW HYDROGEN FAMILY MEMBERS I'M
TO MAKE THE MOST IT'S REALLY.
TERRIFIC OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU.
WELL THANK YOU MRS COOK- I COULD
SEE YOU'RE GOING TO BE LOOKING
OVER OUR SHOULDERS. ACROSS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT WE ALL
COME TOGETHER- TO WORK AS ONE.
FOR THIS GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE LEAD
THE NATION IN HARJIT AND
HYDROGEN. SO LET ME GO AHEAD AND
CONTINUE- SO THANK YOU ALL
PANELISTS FOR STANDING BY IN
STAYING WITH US BECAUSE WE'D
LIKE TO HEAR FROM ALL OF YOU. AS
WE BEGIN WITH QUESTIONS. SO WHAT
THANK YOU THE PRINT THE
PRESENTERS ONCE AGAIN WE WILL
BRING HIS BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WITH QUESTIONS. FOR THE
PANELISTS BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO
THE PUBLIC. I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE ONCE AGAIN THE PUBLIC. TO
PREPARE FOR THEIR PURPOSE A
PARTICIPATION. BY DIALING THE
TOLL FREE NUMBER. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE SIX
THREE. WHEN PROMPTED PLEASE USE
THE ACCESS CODE. SEVEN THREE SIX
TWO EIGHT THREE THREE. WE WILL
NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION- TO OUR
MEMBERS AND AS WE MENTIONED
EARLIER WE HAVE SENATOR JOSH
NEWMAN AND SENATOR BEN ALLEN
WITH ME TODAY SO I WILL BEGIN
WITH SENATOR. JOSH NEWMAN IF HE
HAS ANY QUESTIONS TO ANY ONE OF
OUR PANELISTS. EDITOR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU. TO ALL
OF THE PANELISTS THIS MORNING I
THINK- MISS COOK. SUMMED IT UP
WELL AT THE END BY REFERRING TO
OUR HYDROGEN FAMILY- AND SO BUT
DID YOU KNOW IT IS EXCITING-
THIS MOMENT WHERE WE ARE ON THE
CUSP. OF USE REAL BREAKTHROUGHS-
IT'S REAL BENEFITS AND SO YOU
KNOW IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
THE STATE PLAY IT'S- ROBERT
ROWLAND EXPEDITING AND
SUPPORTING. THIS TRANSITION.
I'VE BEEN VERY INVOLVED AS MANY
FOLKS KNOW IN IN THE ON THE
LIGHT DUTY SIDE IN THE EFFORT TO
BUILD OUT. THAT CALIFORNIA'S
LIGHT DUTY HYDROGEN FUELING
INSTALLATIONS- AND IT IT. I'D
LOVE TO HEAR FROM SOME OF THE
PANELISTS AND IT SEEMS THAT AS-
YOU KNOW WE START LOOKING AT.
THESE LARGER OPPORTUNITIES OR
SEEM TO A TENSION HAS GROWN UP
BETWEEN LIGHT DUTY AND HEAVY
DUTY PARTICULAR RESPECT TO- YOU
KNOW SIR. ALLOCATIONS OF THE F.
IS GOING TO POSITION DIFFERENT.
RESIDENTS IN THE INDUSTRY FOR
ABOUT FOR ALLOCATIONS AGAINST
EITHER SAVE MONEY TO THE FEDERAL
GRANTS CHAU TO IT LOVE TO HEAR
FROM- I GUESS STARTING WITH MISS
COOK- MY OWN TAKE IS THAT
THERE'S A SYNERGISTIC
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN LIGHT DUTY
AND HEAVY- BUT BUT YOU KNOW HOW
TO THINK ABOUT THIS AND HOW TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ON THE SAME
PAGE. AS IT RELATES TO BOTH OF
THESE PLATFORMS. I REQUEST THANK
YOU SENATOR I'M- IN THIS IN THE
EARLY ADOPTION PHASE. THERE WILL
BE WHILE LEVELS OF MANKIND AND
EACH THE VEHICLE CLOCK THERE I'M
L. EIGHT AND WE WORK TOWARDS
SCALING UP THE HYDROGEN ECONOMY
IN TOTAL WE NEED TO DEMAND
CREATED BY EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THOSE HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THOSE MEDIUMS.
EVERYTHING ONE OF THOSE
PASSENGER VEHICLE IN ORDER TO
ALLOW HYDROGEN FUEL PRODUCERS
YOU MAKE LARGE INVESTMENTS IN
RENEWABLE I'M PRODUCTION
PATHWAYS AT AN AFFORDABLE COST
THAT BENEFITS EVERYBODY SO WE
EITHER GROW TOGETHER OR WE FALL
APART AND YOU KNOW I BELIEVE AND
THAT WOULD BE YOU KNOW FIRST
ANSWER WOULD OFFER AND THEN THE
SECOND. IS THAT I'D- THERE ARE
TWENTY EIGHT MILLION LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLE ON THE ROAD AND ABOUT
ONE MILLION HEAVY DUTY YOUR CALL
AND WHAT WE HAVE FOUND IS THAT
WITH A ROBOT. WITH ROBUST
SUPPORT FOR PASSENGER VEHICLE
AND- LIGHT DUTY PASSENGER
VEHICLES FOR TO SCALE IN
PRODUCING THOSE HEALTH AFTER
THOSE LIGHT DUTY VEHICLE IS
TRANSFERABLE TO THE HEAVY DUTY
APPLICATIONS SO THE MORE THAT WE
CAN DO IN LIFE YOU NEED FOR OUR
COST REDUCTION IN THE- COMPONENT
PARTS OF THE HEAVY DUTY TRUCK.
CONVERSELY YOU KNOW BLACK LIGHT
DUTY CAN BE A CALL ABOUT FIVE
KILOGRAMS WHEREAS EIGHT TRACK
HAD FIFTY KILOGRAM SO B. THE
MAN'S PROFILE AND THE HEAVY DUTY
TRUCKS AND HOW MUCH FUEL IS
GOING TO CONSUME. IS GOING TO
CREATE THAT SORT OF DEMAND IN
THE MARKET AND ENTERPRISES
PRODUCERS TO COMMENT WHICH DRIVE
DOWN THE COSTS NOT JUST FOR THE
HEAVY DUTY COMMUNITY THAT THAT'S
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO SEE THOSE
MAJOR COST REDUCTIONS FOR. THE
PASSENGER VEHICLE FLEET THERE'S
A SYMBIOTIC RELATIONSHIP THAT
EXISTS WITH DEVELOPING- WHEN WE
WANT TO REDUCE FUEL COSTS AND
REDUCE COMPONENT PARTS THAT GO
INTO VEHICLES. WHICH AND WE ALL
KNOW IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
BARRIERS TO ADOPTION AND THE
HEAVY DUTY. SECTOR WE'VE GOT A
DRIVE DOWN THE PRICE YOUR
MISSION TRUCKS- IN EVERY. WAY
THAT WE CAN YOU KNOW TALK ABOUT
. I APPRECIATE LIKE LOVE TO HEAR
FROM ANY OTHER PANELS SUSPICIOUS
SOMEBODY HAS A- THAT A- VIEW OF
THIS. ANYONE IN THEIR PANELS
LIKE TO WEIGH IN ON THAT. THANK
YOU- I JUST WANTED TO BUILD ON
WHAT THERESA SAID IN HER EARLIER
COMMENTS THAT- IT'S IMPORTANT TO
THINK. ABOUT ADVANCING
TRANSPORTATION ALONGSIDE OTHER
APPLICATIONS- SHE MENTIONED IT
WAS FIVE KILOGRAMS FOR A
PASSENGER CAR. FIFTY KILOGRAMS-
TRUCK HEAVY DUTY TRUCK AND WE
KNOW THAT THOSE TRUCKS ARE
REALLY BIG SOURCES OF POLLUTION
CRITERIA POLLUTANTS. THE
CHALLENGES AT THE END AND WE DID
EXTENSIVE INTERVIEWS WITH A LOT
OF OFF TAKERS- THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS AND HIGH DEAL LA. WE
KNOW THAT THESE FLEET OPERATORS
JAHN'S ARE- IN TERMINAL
OPERATORS BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST
MOBILE HEAVY DUTY AT STATIONARY.
ANY AS WELL THEY WANT TO CONVERT
THEY WANT TO DECARBONISE AND
WHAT WE HEARD THEM SAY IS THAT
THE NUMBER ONE PROBLEM. IT
WASN'T I THOUGHT THEY WERE GOING
TO SAY IT'S THE COST OF THE
TRUCK OR THE COST OF THE NEW
FUEL CELL PLATFORM. BUT WHAT
THEY TOLD US IS THEY SAID NO
IT'S THAT'S NOT IT. THE NUMBER
ONE CHALLENGE IS THE COST OF THE
FUEL. IT'S NOT ONLY THE COST OF
THE FUEL BUT WE DON'T KNOW WHERE
WE'RE GOING TO LIKE BY ENOUGH OF
IT. SO IT'S ACCESS AND IT'S COST
BECAUSE THOSE USERS HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE TOTAL COST OF
OWNERSHIP MAKES SENSE FROM A
BUSINESS STANDPOINT. SO ON
THAT'S WHY IN THINKING ABOUT
ADVANCING R. HOBBS- WE RECOMMEND
THAT WE START WITH THE LARGE.
BANKABLE OFF TAKERS YOU NEED
JUST A COUPLE. HAVE INSTABILITY
IN PLANNING FOR. A HIGH VOLUME
COMPETITIVE. REDUCTION MARKET
AND THEREFORE YOU GETS MUCH
EASIER ONCE YOUR VISIBILITY INTO
ONE LARGE DROPPED ANCHOR IN A IN
A IN A LARGER SUPPLY CONTRACT TO
ADAM AND OTHERS. AND IT WAS OUR
CONCLUSION- AFTER DOING ALL
THESE INTERVIEWS THAT THE
STATIONARY AND MOBILE DIESEL
USERS WILL CONVERT MUCH MORE
QUICKLY ONCE THEY HAVE
VISIBILITY INTO THOSE CONTRACTS
SO IN SOME WAYS IT FROM OUR
CHICKEN AND EGG PROBLEM CAN BE
SOLVED BY. STARTING WITH SOME OF
THE LARGER OFF TAKERS
CONTRACTING WITH THEM ADDING
OTHERS WE CAN TAKING ONE BIG
LEAP FORWARD TO PUT IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO GET TO LOWER
DELIVERY COSTS AND WHEN YOU CAN
GET THIS ALTERNATIVE FUEL THAT'S
HEADS. AND NOT TIED. TO ANY WARS
IN UKRAINE OR- YOU KNOW IT'S
MADE LOCALLY- THAT'S A REALLY
ATTRACTIVE VALUE PROPOSITION I
THINK HISTORY WILL JUST TAKE
CARE OF ITSELF. AND I THINK THAT
YOU KNOW YOUR POINT IS WELL
TAKEN SO IN IN A SIMILAR AND
THERE SEEMS TO BE. TENSION WITH
RESPECT TO COLORS OF HYDROGEN
RIGHT SHOULD YOU KNOW THE GREEN
NESS I THINK EVERYBODY BUT-
THERE'S NOBODY HERE DOESN'T
BELIEVE AT LEAST ASPIRATIONAL
AND GETTING TO FULLY RECHARGING
BUT BUT THERE SEEMS TO BE. A
CONVERSATION GOING ON ABOUT WHAT
OUR TOLERANCE SHOULD BE WATER
APPROACH SHOULD BE OVER TIME- AS
AS IT RELATES TO YOU KNOW THAT A
WILLINGNESS TO MOVE THROUGH. A
PHASE WHERE WE ACCEPT AS A GIVEN
AGAIN I THANK- THAT YOU CAN'T BE
GREEN STARRED IN FACT THERE'S A
SORT OF AN INNOVATION PATHWAY
THAT HAS TO TAKE PLACE. SO HOW
TO THINK ABOUT THAT DELIBERATELY
AS AS IT RELATES TO- YOU KNOW
ALLOCATIONS AND PRIORITIES AND
POLICIES. MISATTRIBUTED ME I AM.
VERY DO I WHICH NOT CLEAR TO
THEM I'M JUST ASKING THE PANEL-
GOOD IDEAS FROM ANYBODY. I JUST
LIKE TO SAY THAT JUST BRIEFLY
THAT WE CAN ABSOLUTELY DO GREEN
. SOON NOW NOW THERE'S NOTHING
HOLDING US BACK- AND WE HAVE
SEEN LARGE HURDLE. RATE AROUND
THE WORLD IN FACT I THINK THE
PROJECT LAUREN THAT YOU
MENTIONED YOU'RE WORKING ON WITH
SO CAL GAS IS ALREADY. PRODUCING
AT THREE DOLLARS PER KILOGRAM
WHICH IS VERY EXCITING. BOB IT'S
TERRY TERMINATE YOUR CAN
EVERYONE HEAR ME YES YOU'RE
READING IT. I APOLOGIZE FOR THE
BACKGROUND NOISE COINCIDENTLY
HAD TO GO TO ANOTHER MEETING SO
I'M IN A FUEL CELL- HONDA AT THE
MOMENT DRIVING TO MY NEXT
MEETING AND- OF REALLY ENJOYING
THIS CONVERSATION. UP YOU KNOW I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT WE PRODUCE
SOMETHING OVER THREE TRILLION
CUBIC FEET OF HYDROGEN IN THIS
COUNTRY EVERY YEAR I'LL FROM
MOSTLY NATURAL GAS STEAM
REFORMATION OF NATURAL GAS A
FOSSIL FUELS WHAT WE DO THAT
HYDROGEN UP. TO VOTE. MOSTLY IS
USED FOR STRIPPING SULFUR FROM
PETROLEUM TO MAKE DIESEL AND
GASOLINE INSTEAD OF SIMPLY
PUTTING IT INTO OUR VEHICLES. SO
THE TRUTH IS IF WE SIMPLY PUT IT
INTO OUR VEHICLES WE CUT OUT ALL
OF THE NEEDS OF THE OIL. AND ALL
OF THE POLLUTION AND OTHER
PROBLEMS THAT COME WITH IT EVEN
IF WE WERE STILL USING A FOSSIL
FUEL I'M NOT ADVOCATING FOR THAT
. SHE IS A FORMER CALIFORNIA VA
SECRETARY. BUT BUT I HI I POINT
THAT OUT BECAUSE I THINK. THAT
THE- BIOGAS BIOMETHANE HAS
TRAFFIC POTENTIAL. AND THE
IMPORTANT THING IS TO MEASURE
THE CARBON INTENSITY. BECAUSE
YOU KNOW THE CARBON INTENSITY
DEPENDING ON WHERE YOU'RE
GETTING THE WATER LET'S SAY YOU
ARE DOING ELECTROLYSIS WITH THE-
SOLAR OR WIND POWER. BUT
DEPENDING ON WHERE THAT'S COMING
FROM AND WHERE THE WATER IS
COMING FROM THAT YOU'RE GETTING
THE HYDROGEN FROM. THAT COULD
HAVE A MUCH HIGHER CARBON
INTENSITY THAT IF YOU'RE TAKING.
LET'S SAY LANDFILL GAS WHICH IS
CURRENTLY BEING FLARED OR OR
EMITTED INTO THE ATMOSPHERE.
TWENTY SIX TIMES MORE POTENT AS
A HEAT TRAPPING GAS. THANCO
TWO. AND AND SO THE CARBON
INTENSITY SCORES REALLY WHAT WE
NEED TO BE FOCUSING. VERY THE
PRESSURE THAT'S ON THE LAST
QUESTION AND- THAT'LL BE TURNED
BACK OVER MY CULTURE. AND BUNCH
OF FOLKS IN THEIR TESTIMONY DAY
EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
LEVERAGING- PUBLIC INVESTMENTS
TO. INSTIGATE AN EXPEDITED
PRIVATE INVESTMENT SO THAT BY
SWITCHING STUFF GOING ON AMONG
UTILITIES- ESPECIALLY YOU KNOW
FOR FOLKS WHO HAVE PIPELINES
OTHER INFRASTRUCTURE MIGHT BE
USEFUL HYDROGEN. I DO I DO HAVE
A QUESTION FOR- THE- SOCALGAS
ROASTED IN THE IN DEATH AS SORT
OF BIG EXEMPLIFYING THESE.
QUESTIONS YOU TALK ABOUT THE
ANGELES LINK PROJECT THAT THEY
CAN AND YOU KNOW THE QUESTION
THEN BECOMES IF IT'S A PRIVATE
INVESTMENT IS THIS GOING TO BE
BORNE BY SHAREHOLDERS OR BY RATE
PAYERS- AS AS WE MOVE THESE
THINGS FORWARD. THANK YOU
SENATOR NEWMAN FROM EURO AT THE
MOMENT ARE ANGELES LANG. EFFORT
IS REALLY AN EFFORT TO SCOPE THE
PROJECT AND LOOK AT THE OFF
TAKERS AND SUPPLIERS AND-
CHARACTERIZE THE MARKET BY LET'S
SAY. EARLY ENGINEERING EFFORTS I
WILL SAYTHAT WE CERTAINLY HAVE
WORKED VERY CLOSELY UN IDEAL
AWAY WITH JANICE AND HER TEAM
AND MANY OTHERS. WE KNOW THE
MARKET EXIST TODAY- BUT OUR
EARLY EFFORT IS REALLY TO
CHARACTERIZE. WHAT PART OF OUR
OWN. HEAVY INDUSTRIAL
TRANSPORTATION. INDISPENSABLE
FUEL- COSTUMERS THOSE CUSTOMERS
THAT EXIST OR ALREADY HAVE
EXISTING NATURAL GAS WITH. WHAT
CUSTOMERS WOULD BENEFIT FROM
HYDROGEN. AND ONCE WE'VE DONE
THAT ONCE WE JUST DON'T FOR
MARKET THEN I THINK YOU KNOW IT
BE TIME TO START WITH THE
HOSPITALIZATION WORLD LEADERS OF
THE COST OF THAT WE DO THINK
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT PUBLIC
GOOD. IN THE UTILITIES OF
PROVIDING A BROAD ACCESS TO
HYDROGEN- THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT'S REALLY BEING UNDERTAKEN
IN PLACES LIKE EUROPE. AT HALF
PACE. AS YOU MAY KNOW THE AT
LEAST IN SOME PART. AS AAS A
RESULT OF THE CONFLICT IN
UKRAINE- THE EUROPEAN UNION HAS
DOUBLED DOWN ON ITS EFFORTS TO
BECOME INDEPENDENT OR FROM
RUSSIA. IN TWO WAYS ONE BY
ACCELERATING. THE ACCESS TO
AMERICAN LIQUID OF LIQUEFIED
NATURAL GAS BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
FOR THIS CONVERSATION. BUT
REALLY SIGNIFICANTLY MAKING
COMMITMENTS GREEN HYDROGEN AND
THAT GREEN HYDROGEN IT WILL
LARGELY BE- MOVED THROUGHOUT
EUROPE IN THE- LARGE SCALE
TRANSMISSION. HE IS- OPERATORS
THOSE ADDITIONAL UTILITY TYPE
OPERATORS THAT MOVE GAS ON
BEHALF OF COST SO WE SEE A THE
CUSTOMER CLASS IT WILL BE.
DISTINCTLY BENEFIT SPECIFICALLY
THOSE THAT ARE HARD TO ELECTRIFY
IN ELDERLY I THINK IT'LL BE A
CONVERSATION LEGISLATORS AND-
AND REGULATORS AS THE HOMES. I
APPRECIATE DAVIS YOU HAVE DONE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- SENATOR
BEN ALLEN YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
FOR ANY OF THE PANELISTS. WELL I
JUST APPRECIATE ALL THESE GREAT
PRESENTATIONS I'VE EVER OF
CERTAINLY LEARNED A LOT AND- IT
DID YOU KNOW THERE THERE'S A
THERE'S SO MUCH WORK UNDER WAY I
GUESS- I WOULD LOVE SOME
INSIGHTS. MAYBE FROM KOBE IS- AS
WE'RE LOOKING AT OUR-
APPLICATION AND WE GOT YOU KNOW
HOW PROPOSALS FOR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BOTH VERY WORTHY HOW
DO WE FIGURE OUT THE GEOGRAPHIC
BALANCE- AS WE AS WE APPROACH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN OUR
APPLICATIONS. THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION CENTER ALLEN AND THAT'S
WHAT WE WERE FOCUSING ON THESE
COMING MONTHS WE HAD YOU KNOW WE
HAVE TO SEE OTHER R. F. P. THE
FELLOW WHAT SHAPE THAT TAKES. I
THINK WE'RE LOOKING AT THAT YOU
KNOW IS A LOT OF GEOGRAPHIC
STRENGTHENED WE TAKE ADVANTAGE
OF THERE'S A LOT OFWORK IN LOS
ANGELES THAT UNIT GREAT IDEA OF
THE PROJECT AND IN LODI. AND SO
I THINK THE WAY I WOULD THINK
ABOUT IT IS- FIRST WE HAVE TO
FIGURE HOW MUCH MONEY THERE IS
AND THEN WE CAN THINK ABOUT IN
TERMS OF FACING RIGHT SO LIKE
WHERE IS THAT FIRST INVESTMENTS
YEAH WE DO ALL OF IT AT ONCE IS
IT MAKES SENSE TO INVEST IN ONE
REGION FIRST. AND THEN PHASE AND
THE SECOND REGION'S THOSE THESE
ARE OPEN QUESTIONS THAT WE HAVE
TO WORK THROUGH. I THINK WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE IS WE DON'T DILUTES
THE FEDERAL RESOURCES AND STATE
RESOURCES SUCH A WAIVER
ULTIMATELY. NOT SUCCESSFUL BUT I
BUT THE IMPORTANT PART IS MAKING
SURE THAT ULTIMATE PAN IS
BRINGING THIS STATEWIDE SO FOR
WORK WHERE IT STARTS AND
FINISHES YOU KNOW YOU COULD SEE
IT SO. IT REALLY DEPENDS ON THE
RESOURCES BUT I MEAN I COULD SEE
A CASE WHERE WE'RE DOING A BUNCH
OF PROJECTS ACROSS THE STATE
ONCE THERE'S ALSO POTENTIAL TO
START IN A REGION WITH A CLEAR
PLAN TO EXPAND INTO OTHER
REGIONS. SO I KNOW IT'S NOT A
COMPLETE ANSWER AT THIS POINT
BUT THAT'S EXACTLY THIS TYPE OF
QUESTIONS WE ARE ASKING
OURSELVES AND WANT TO WORK WITH
ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS TO MAKE
SURE. THAT WE COME TO A
CONSENSUS ABOUT WHAT MAKES THE
MOST SENSE AND VISIT THIS AND
AFTER THE STATE BUT ALSO THE
NATIONAL MARKET TO SUCCEED. AND
TYSON WHAT SO WHAT DO YOU KNOW
ABOUT THE CONVERSATIONS THAT ARE
HAPPENING IN- IN OTHER REGIONS
RIGHT NOW NO I WE HAD A
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE OTHER
REGIONS AS PRESENTED BY THE- THE
FEDERAL FOLKS BUT- ARE THEY ARE.
LOOKING TO DO MORE. STATE CO.
ALL OR- YEAH YEAH. LOVE TO HEAR
ABOUT THAT WE ARE INSTANTLY IN.
AN ADULT. AND MANY OTHERS HAVE I
MEAN I HAVE A WHOLE LIST OF ALL
OF THEM. I THINK JUST LAST.
YESTERDAY MAYBE NEW YORK
ANNOUNCED THE CONSORTIUM IN THE
NORTHEAST THEN THERE'S THAT
THERE'S AN- INNATE. THE
INTERMOUNTAIN. AND THERE'S LIKE
THE TEXAS LOUISIANA POTENTIALLY
NORTHWEST- AND I THINK. SO YES
THERE'S A LOT OF KIND OF- WE
NEED TO GATHER RESOURCES I THINK
EVERYBODY IN FROM WHAT I'VE
GATHERED IN OVERLOOKING THE
CALIFORNIA HAS ITS OWN. AND
UNIQUE ENTITY BUT THAT BEING
SAID I THINK IF IT STRENGTHENS
OUR APPLICATION BRINGING AND
OTHER REGIONAL PARTNERS EITHER
DIRECTLY WITHIN THE APPLICATION
OR WE PLAN TO GET THERE KIND OF
SIMILAR TO THINKING ABOUT THE
REGION'S. HIS GRADES WERE
ACTIVELY PURSUING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AS WELL YOU KNOW
WITH THE SOUTH WEST OF THE
NORTHWEST- OF COURSE UNIT IN THE
ATTIC THREE HUNDRED COLLISION
PRESENTATION STUDY PORTENTS OF
THE CONNECTION TO UTAH YOU KNOW
SO. ALL OF THESE THINGS ARE
CONNECTED THIS. OFFICE RATHER.
OR FRACKING OF LOS ALAMOS NINE.
MONTH OKAY IT IS TAKES A LITTLE
ASKEW ALSO ON WHERE WE'RE HOW DO
YOU ANSWER I'VE- THE CONCERNS
OUT THERE THAT- YOU KNOW.
ELECTROLYSIS STIRRED DERIVE
GREEN HYDROGEN IS GREAT AND
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A VISION THERE
FOR YOU KNOW FOR THE USE OF
ACCESS ELECTRICITY- USED TO DO
THAT BUT- BUT THAT BUT THAT IN
THE END OF THE DAY- OF REALLY A
SHARP PIVOT TOWARD HYDROGEN.
WILL MESSAGE WILL NECESSITATE A
DOUBLING DOWN ON NATURAL GAS AND
OTHER FOSSIL FUEL INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR A LONG TIME TO GET TO THAT
GREEN HYDROGEN VISION. THAT'S
PROBLEMATIC WHERE WHERE WHERE DO
YOU WHERE DO YOU. HOW DO YOU HOW
DO YOU- YOU KNOW. EVALUATE THAT
THAT TENSION. IT'S A GREAT
QUESTION  THINK EVEN LOOKING AT
GENESIS LIED ABOUT THE
PROJECTIONS FOR THE COST OF
HYDROGEN AND GREEN HEIDI
ALTERNATELY GREEN HYDROGEN IS
GOING TO OUTCOMPETE FOSSIL
SOURCES AND SO FROM THE STATE
PERSPECTIVES YOU KNOW WE'RE WE
WOULD LIKE TO PRIORITIZE
INVESTING IN GREEN HYDROGEN ON
THE BROAD DEFINITION I THINK YES
THIS IS A REALLY GOD ONE. AND
IT DOESN'T MEAN YOU KNOW
INDUSTRY CAN'T INVEST IN FOSSIL
BASED PROJECTS I DON'T KNOW IF
THEY WILL OR THEY WON'T IT'S ALL
PART OF THE SYSTEM BUT WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ENABLE IS THE
RENEWABLE GREEN HYDROGEN AND
ULTIMATELY THE ECONOMICS AND
ABOUT. THE REALLY CUTS BACK IN
AND IT HAS THE ADDED BENEFIT OF
POTENTIALLY INCREASING THE
PENETRATION IN ECONOMICS OF
SOLAR AND WIND AS YOU CAN YEAH
AFTER A LOT MORE CAPACITIES
REFER ANY PREVIOUS VIRTUOUS
CYCLE OF YOU KNOW- DOWNWARD
PRESSURE ON PRICES. AND ALL
THREE OF THOSE SECTORS. YEAH I'M
IT WAS IS THE CONVERSATION LIKE
BETWEEN GO BIZ AND THE AIR BOARD
ON THESE. THE PHILOSOPHICAL. YES
G. SOURCING CONVERSATION. VERY
CLOSELY ALIGNED SO WE ARE REALLY
LOOKING TO THE AIRPORT FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP LIKE THREE DYSTOPIAN
PLAN YOU KNOW BASED ON THEIR
FUNDAMENTAL ANALYSIS HOW DO WE
GET TO WORK TWENTY FORTY FIVE
ALITY CARTER AND THAT'S THE BASE
AT THE TABLE THAT WE'RE TRYING
TO ORGANIZE AROUND THAT IF THAT
MAKES SENSE AND SO YOU KNOW
THERE'S SOME UNCERTAINTY ABOUT
YOU KNOW HOW BIG OF A ROLE. I DO
ANYTHING WILL PLAY REALLY
FRANKLY AND SO WE'RE TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT HYDROGEN IS
POSITION TO PLAY ITS BEST ROLE
AND EXPAND THEM PROBABLY ENOUGH
REFORMS EVEN WATER PROJECTIONS
ARE. SO IT WAS VERY CLOSE
PARTNERSHIP AND ALIGNMENT YEAH.
I'M OKAY I LOOK FOR IS ALL THANK
YOU. FOR THE PRESENTATION I'M
I'M STILL WANT TO GET DOWN THE
AISLE TO SEE- YOU KNOW WITH
WOULD LOVE TO GO CHECK IT ALL
OUT- WELCOME ANYTIME YEAH I KNOW
IT'S FIGURE THAT OUT I THAT.
EVEN YEAH. VERY COOL I'M SO DID
YOU WHERE WHERE IT SO OUR
HYDROGEN JUST ONE PART OF YOUR
OF YOUR PROJECT RIGHT THERE'S IT
COMMITTED TO. THERE ARE YOU GUYS
WORKING ON AN ELECTRIFICATION
ISSUES TO. SO OUR PRIMARY
FUNCTION AND THE WAY THAT THE
NONPROFIT WAS SET UP. FOR
DEVELOPING GAVE US OF THE ACCESS
TO THIS PROPERTY WAS BECAUSE OF
WORKING IN THE BLUE ECONOMY AND-
SO THAT'S- RENEWABLE ENERGY
OFFSHORE THINGS LIKE WAVE
ENERGY- WE'VE GOT SOME
INNOVATIVE COMPANIES THAT ARE
GETTING READY TO DEMONSTRATE- OF
COURSE OFFSHORE WIND BUT THE
WAYS TO DO THAT THAT ARE. LESS
IMPACTFUL TO THE ENVIRONMENT-
THERMOCLINE CAPTURING THAT THE
DIFFERENCES OF TEMPERATURE AND
CENTROSAURUS ALL KINDS OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY THEIR OF SECOND
CLUSTER FOCUS FOR US IS-
AQUACULTURE AND THAT INCLUDES
GROWING GIANT KELP AQUA FARMS AS
WELL AS ATLANTA AFTER BE TURNED
INTO BIO FUELS AND- AND SOURCES
OF ENERGY AND EVEN TURNED INTO-
INTO HYDROGEN. AS WELL AS FOOD
AND PHARMACEUTICALS AND THEN OUR
THIRD ONE IS IN TECHNOLOGY SUCH
AS UNDERWATER ROBOTICS AND STUFF
THE WAYS OF UNDERSTANDING OUR
OUR PLANET BETTER SO IT'S ALL
VERY INTER RELATED ASKED US
CERTAINLY AS WE PUT OUR OWN
THREE POINT TWO MEGAWATTS OF
SOLAR WHICH IS CURRENTLY BEING
INSTALLED ON A ROOFTOP. I LOVE
TO POWER SEVEN HUNDRED HOMES
MUCH MORE THAT WE'RE GOING TO
USE IT'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO BE THAT CONTRIBUTORS TO THE
GREEN ENERGY THAT WILL BE USED
FOR MAKING HYDROGEN. CRIMES
AREN'T OKAY THANK YOU VEGETARIAN
IN MY FILE QUESTIONS. FOR RANDY
HOWARD AND- TO THE- IS FOR DIED
TO BE THE HAVE I DO WHERE DID.
FIT INTO THAT- WAS THAT IS THAT.
HOW THANK YOU SPENT A GOOD DEAL
OF TIME AT THE BEGINNING A
PRESENTATION TALK ABOUT OAKLAND
. YEAH WELL I JUST DECIDED
OAKLAND OAKLAND IS ONE OF OUR
MEMBERS. AND CBS SO THEY'RE
POTENTIALLY ONE OF OUR OFTEN
OCCURS. THE RAIL LINE THAT GOES
TO WHAT IS AN OFF TAKER I'M I'M
SORRY. SO OFTEN OCCURRED IS
MEANING THAT THEY COULD UTILIZE
THE HYDROGEN FUEL. FOR SHIPPING
FOR TRANSPORTATION PURPOSES DOWN
AT THE PORT OF OAKLAND AIRPORT
IN OAKLAND THOSE ARE OUR
CUSTOMERS CURRENTLY. OR
ELECTRICITY AND SO THEY'RE
THEY'RE MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY
MIKE I WAS JUST TRYING TO
HIGHLIGHT IS WE STILL HAVE TO DO
ALL THE- NORMAL ACTIVITIES IN
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE WORKING VERY
HARD ON THOSE. BUT EVERYDAY NOT
EVERYDAY BUT MANY DAYS WE HAVE
TO CURTAIL SOME OF THAT ENERGY
RIGHT WE DON'T NEED IT. YEAH FOR
OUR PROJECT- WE'RE PROPOSING TO
USE THE ACCESS. ENERGY RENEWABLE
ENERGY WHEN IT'S AVAILABLE TO
PRODUCE HYDROGEN STORED AND THEN
COMBUSTED A WIN WIN SUN. ISN'T
SHINING WIND IS BLOWING. THANK
YOU REGISTER. THANK YOU ALL THE
PRESENTER REALLY VERY VERY
INFORMATIVE MORNING IN AND-
CENTERS PLEASE IF THERE'S
ANOTHER QUESTION THAT POPS UP
PLEASE- JUST- JUMP IN AND- THIS
IS SO INTERESTING CHAU
INFORMATIVE AND SO EDUCATIONAL
FOR THE GENERAL PUBLIC IS ALL-
THE PEOPLE ARE WATCHING- I'VE
GOT A QUESTION- FOR LAWRENCE
GUYVER AND- FIRST OFF I'D LIKE
TO CONGRATULATE YOU AND YOUR
CITY AND YOUR BUS LINE- IN WE'RE
WE'VE HEARD ABOUT- WE'VE GOT TO
EXPAND THE PRODUCTION WE BIRD
BRINGING DOWN THE COST. OF
HYDROGEN- AND YET HERE YOU HAD-
YOU JUST MENTIONED YOU AWARDED A
GRANT FOR MORE BUSES AND SHOW-
SO TELL ME HOW YOU'RE PROMOTING
IT IN ARE YOU SHARING THIS
WEALTH OF KNOWLEDGE WITH THE
OTHER CITIES IN YOUR AREA. WE
ABSOLUTELY ARE CENTER OUTLET AND
WE ACTUALLY HAVE A MISSION
FOCUSED ON THAT WAS PASSED BY
OUR BOARD IN NINETEEN NINETY
THREE THAT WE WILL NOT ONLY
PROMOTE AND OPERATE ZERO MISSION
BUT WILL TEACH OTHERS HOW TO DO
IT. AND SO IT IS ACTUALLY PART
OF OUR BOARD POLICY TO GO OUT
AND HELP OTHER TRANSIT OPERATORS
AND WE'RE EXPANDING THAT TO
THREE OPERATORS ON THE PRIVATE
SIDE. ON HOW OUR BLUEPRINT CAN
WORK FOR ANYONE AND MAYBE NOT
EXACTLY A SUNLINE IS PLANNED IT
AND PUT IT OUT BUT PIECES AND
PARTS OF OUR BLUEPRINT COULD BE
REAP REPLICATED ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA AND ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY FOR THAT MATTER. SO BY
THESE PUBLIC. PUBLIC FUNDING
SOURCES. PROVIDING NOT ONLY TO
THE TRANSIT RIDER THROUGH THESE
INVESTMENTS BUT ALSO HOW WE CAN
MOVE THE HYDROGEN ECONOMY TO
PRIVATE OPERATORS. IS REALLY HOW
WE SEE THIS WORKING AND BACK TO
SENATOR NEWMAN'S QUESTION. YOU
KNOW ABOUT LIGHT DUTY AND HEAVY
DUTY THAT'S WHY WE HAVE A PLAN
FOR SCALING OUR STATION WOULD
ALLOW BOTH. PROVIDERS TO FUEL
FOR BOTH TYPES OF VEHICLE TYPES
TO PREVENT TO FUEL BUT AS WE SAW
IT WAS WE SEE TRACKING POLL OUT
MORE AND MORE TRUCKS ON THE
ROAD. THIS HEAVY DUTY STATION
WOULD BE THE NEXT ITERATION OF
WHAT WE WOULD PROVIDE TO THE
PUBLIC. SO WE CAN TAKE THESE
PUBLIC INVESTMENTS HE'S PUBLIC
FUNDING INVESTMENTS. AND TURN
THEM INTO NOT ONLY HOPING A
PUBLIC OPERATOR. BUT THE PRIVATE
ECONOMY MOVE FORWARD WE'RE
REALLY LEVERAGING THE FUNDING TO
THE BEST OF ITS ABILITY IN MY
OPINION. YOU KNOW WHEN YOU WHEN
YOU MENTIONED THE FUELING
STATIONS. OBVIOUSLY WE'VE ALSO
HEARD. THAT WE NEED THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SO. DESPERATELY
NEEDED. AND OBVIOUSLY WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THOUSAND FUELING
STATION. DOWN THE ROAD UNTIL
THEN- I THINK YOUR YOUR
PRESENTATION ON YOUR MOBILE
FUELING STATION WILL CALL IT-
CAN GO HADN'T. AUGMENT THAT
UNTIL WE ACTUALLY DO THE
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WE NEED IN
CHAU AE I'M POINTING THAT OUT
BECAUSEI THINK THAT WHETHER BE
THE BUS LINES OR EVEN PRIVATE
CITIZENS WERE BUYING THE FUEL
CELL HYDROGEN CARS. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO MOBILE FEW STATIONS
UNTIL WE ACTUALLY BUILT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT I'D LIKE TO
TELL. TURN MY ATTENTION OVER TO-
MR- TO OUR GOVERNOR'S OFFICE- IN
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE GOVERNOR
FOR. HIS REPRESENTATION
OBVIOUSLY- TYSON WE'RE SO PROUD
THAT YOU'RE WITH US IN SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT WE'VE ALL HEARD
RECENTLY IN THE NEWS IS OF
COURSE THE- THE SHIPS ARE ROUTED
SHORT. THE THE FREIGHT NOT
GETTING INTO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND THROUGHOUT THE REST OF THE
STATE AND HOW TO HOW DO YOU
FORESEE HYDROGEN. COMING TO THAT
AREA- OF THE COASTLINE AND HOW
IT WILL PLAY OUT IN IN THE
FUTURE. WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT EUROPE YOUR LETTER THAT'S
IT THAT'S A HUGE OPPORTUNITY THE
POOR THINGS A LOT OF OUR
STRATEGIC ADVANTAGES IN
CALIFORNIA YOU MAY PICK OF THE
PORT OF LA LOS ANGELES THINK
IT'S LIKE. 40% OF OUR CARGO
CAPACITY I MEAN FOR REAL I MIGHT
HAVE THE NUMBERS WRONGLY AT THE
PORT OF OAKLAND IN STOCK IN IT.
WHEN YOU SEE ALL THOSE OTHER
THINGS WE HAVE TO ACT IN A
FOREIGN DIRECT INVESTMENT COMING
IN OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
STATE OF JAPAN FOR EXAMPLE IS A
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN YOU SHOW UP
THE BOARDS THAT STARTED A LECTOR
FIND I DO CHEN. A BUNCH OF THE
DIFFERENT SUPPORT APPOINTMENTS
SO I THINK TO ME THAT'S THAT'S
THE HUGE. HYDROGEN PROVIDES YOU
THE OPPORTUNITY TO OPTIMIZE OUR
PORT OPERATIONS DID YOU KNOW
CLEAN THEM UP AND NOT COMPROMISE
ON ANY. OF REPORT AND SO MAYBE
I'D KICK IT OVER TO T. REDUCE IT
YOU KNOW WITH ALL THE C. RIGHT
THERE AFTER THAT. BEFORE IT. THE
NAME HE WOULD HAVE THE BIGGEST
AFTER. OR SHOULD. ADVANTAGE
ABSOLUTELY TYSON AND- NEW WAYS
OF. DELIVERING GREEN HYDROGEN
INTO THE STATE BECAUSE- IT WE
ARE GONNA TAKE A LONG TIME TO
RAMP UP OUR OUR IN STATE
PRODUCTION SO. I KNOW THERE'S
COMPANIES TODAY LOOKING AT-
CREATING GREEN HYDROGEN IN
AUSTRALIA IN SOUTH AMERICA
MEXICO AND- EVEN SAUDI ARABIA-
WITH SOLAR AND WIND. AND DUST
SEA WATER OR- WASTE WATER. AND
THEN TAKING THAT GREEN HYDROGEN
TURNING IT INTO AMMONIA TO MAKE
IT EASIER TO TRANSPORT- AMMONIA
CAN BE USED DIRECTLY AS A FUEL
IN SHIPS TODAY BUT SOME
MODIFICATIONS OF COURSE BUT- AS
A CLEANER FUEL AND THEN BRINGING
THAT AMONG YOU HERE. RIGHT NOW.
THERE'S AN AMMONIA PLANT AN
AMMONIA TERMINAL IN THE PORT OF
STOCKTON THAT'S BEEN THERE FOR
QUITE SOME TIME- THAT'S CAN BE.
A SOURCE OF INCOMING GREEN
HYDROGEN IN THAT FORM AND THEN
OF COURSE YOU JUST TURN THE
AMMONIA BACK INTO HYDROGEN WHEN
IT GETS HERE. AND I KNOW THAT
THERE'S EFFORTS BY PRIVATE
INVESTORS LOOKING TO BRING MORE
OF THAT INTO THE STATE. BECAUSE
I THINK IT WAS MENTIONED EARLIER
THAT A TYPICAL CAR LIKE THE ONE
I'M DRIVING IT NOW TAKES. FIVE
KILOGRAMS A TRUCK FIFTY. WE'RE
BRINGING IN A- FIVE HOUSE. ARE
HARBOR- TOUR VESSEL FROM SEATTLE
THAT'S JUST BEEN COAST GUARD
CERTIFIED THAT USES TWO HUNDRED
AND FIFTY KILOGRAMS. AND THAT'S
JUST A SEVENTY FIVE PASSENGER
VESSEL OBVIOUSLY LARGER SHIPS-
WILL USE FAST QUANTITIES MORE
WHETHER THAT'S AN ART FORM OF
GASEOUS HYDROGEN OR LIQUID
HYDROGEN WHICH CONTAINS EVEN
MORE ENERGY DENSITY. UP BUT- BUT
THAT'S THE POTENTIAL FOR
CREATING. JOBS CERTAINLY WE WANT
TO PRODUCE AS MUCH AS WE CAN
HERE. BUT THERE'S A LOT OF JOBS
TO COME WITH THAT SORT OF FOR
TRANSPORTATION AND DISTRIBUTION
THROUGH THE COURTS. THANK YOU
FOR MENTIONING THAT JOBS AND WE
KNOW THAT THE TECHNOLOGY THE
SKILL WILL BE NEEDED THAT IS A
NEW TRANSITION FOR THE LABOR
FORCE. AND I KNOW I KNOW- THE
WORK FORCE IT IS WAITING- TO BE
PART OF ALL THIS IN THE FUTURE
IS LOOKING FORWARD TO HI PAID-
JOBS THAT WILL HELP THE ECONOMY
WILL HELP THEIR FAMILIES AND SO
ON. BUT I SEE THAT DIGENIS THEN
HAS YOUR HAND UP SO JANICE- GO
RIGHT AHEAD. THANK YOU- I DID
WANT TO MENTION THAT AMMONIA
WHICH IS THAT YOU KNOW FORMULAS
AND THE H. THREE. IT'S MOSTLY
HYDROGEN WAS THE NITROGEN- IS
USED AS AN- INGREDIENT MAKING
FERTILIZER. AND SO CALIFORNIA
TODAY DOES NOT PRODUCE AMMONIA
WITHIN STATE WE IMPORT ALL OF
IT. GO OF IT IS MADE FROM FOSSIL
FUELS AND HYDROGEN. THAT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO VERTICALLY
INTEGRATE AND PROVIDE. GREEN
FERTILIZER FOR OUR VERY
SUCCESSFUL AGRICULTURAL
INDUSTRY. AND WHAT'S ALSO
INTERESTING ABOUT AMMONIA IS
IT'S POTENTIALLY. ON A LIQUID
FUEL FOR VERY LONG HAUL
SHIPPING. SO MARITIME SHIPPING
MOVING GOODS BETWEEN STATES
CHINA AND OUR PORTS PORT OF
OAKLAND- LONG BEACH- SO THERE'S
AN INTERESTING NEXUS IS HERE-
INTO YOUR EARLIER QUESTION HOW
ARE WE GOING TO GET THE
HYDROGEN. TO THE PORTS THESE ARE
AREAS THAT WE WANT TO
DECARBONISE THERE'S A LOT OF
DIESEL USE. BEING FOR OPERATIONS
TRUCKS- IT COULD BE DELIVERED-
INTERNATIONALLY THERE ARE
COUNTRIES THAT ARE GEARING UP TO
EXPORT AMMONIA ALL OVER THE
WORLD FROM CHILE SAUDI ARABIA.
PERSONALLY I THINK WE COULD BE
MAKING IT HERE VERY COST
EFFECTIVELY AND SERVING ACTIVE
OF THE- THAT'S ONE POSSIBILITY
ANOTHER POSSIBILITY AND WHAT WE
FOUND IN OUR ANALYSIS IS THAT.
100% GREEN HYDROGEN TRANSPORT
WAS THE MOST COST EFFECTIVE WAY
THROUGH A PIPELINE. AND JUST TO
GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF COMPARISON-
DELIVERY OF HYDROGEN ON A TRUCK
WHICH IS HOW HYDROGEN'S
DELIVERED IN FUELING STATION THE
DAY. WILL COST IF YOU DIGEST FOR
THE DELIVERY COMPONENT A FEW
DOLLARS PER KILOGRAM. IF THAT
SAME HYDROGEN WAS DELIVERED IN
VOLUME YOU NEED TO HAVE A LARGER
VOLUME- IT TAKES THE COST DOWN
TO SOMETHING LIKE TWENTY CENTS
PER KILOGRAM SO THAT'S THE POWER
OF INFRASTRUCTURE. AND THEN THE
FINAL THING I WANTED TO SAY IS
THAT HURDLE OF LINES. THERE
THERE'S NO RACIAL RISK IN THAT
IN FACT THE UNITED STATES
ALREADY HAS SIXTEEN HUNDRED
MILES OF HYDROGEN PIPELINE MOST
OF IT'S IN THE GULF OF MEXICO.
AND WE DO HAVE SOMETHING LIKE
TWENTY OR THIRTY MILES OF
HYDROGEN HIGH FLYING CONNECTING
THE OIL REFINERIES IN IN AND
NEAR THE PORT OF LA. WELL THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION AS I
MENTIONED IT'S INFORMATIVE AND
THANK YOU ALL SO NOW LET'S GO
AHEAD AND WEIGH IN ON THE
INVOLVED WHEN I MOVED TO ANYONE
WAITING TO PROVIDE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
PLANNING PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE
CHAIRED. MAY INSTITUTE TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY ALL OTHER
WISHES TO TESTIFY I WOULD LIKE
IT IF YOU COULD LIMIT YOUR-
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS TO THREE
MINUTES. AND THOSE WILL BE OPEN
TO ALL THE PANELISTS OF SO NOW
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE ANYONE HERE
IN ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED. WHO
WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS OUR
PANELISTS AND OR THE SENATORS.
THANK GOODNESS THAT YOUR NAME
AND YOUR ORGANIZATION IF YOU
HAVE ONE BUILDING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR ARCH
LETTER. AND MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
WOODY HASTINGS ON THE ENERGY
PROGRAM MANAGER WITH THE CLIMATE
CENTER TO CALIFORNIA'S
STATEWIDE. CLIMATE AND ENERGY
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION WORKING
TO RAPIDLY REDUCE CLIMATE
POLLUTION AT SCALE STARTING IN
CALIFORNIA. CLIMATE CENTER
BELIEVES THAT HYDROGEN COMPLAIN
A PORTENT ROLE IN ADDRESSING THE
CLIMATE CRISIS BUT ONLY IF WE
CAN CRACK THE CODE ON BRINGING
DOWN THE COST. OF SOLAR AND WIND
ENERGY BASED ELECTROLYTIC
HYDROGEN AS WE'VE HEARD. TOO
MUCH EMPHASIS HAS BEEN PLACED
ON- I'M FEELING INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THE SECTOR TRANSPORTATION
THAT'S RAPIDLY BECOMING
ELECTRIFIED THERE'S LITTLE
JUSTIFICATION AND INVESTING
PUBLIC DOLLARS IN FUELING ITS
INFRASTRUCTURE. FOR LIGHT DUTY
VEHICLES WITH OVER A MILLION
BATTERY EV'S ON THE ROAD AND
MORE EVERY DAY. INVESTMENTS IN
APPLICATIONS OF GREEN HYDROGEN
SHOULD BE LIMITED TO THOSE HARD
TO ELECTRIFY SECTORS IN THE
ECONOMY SUCH AS HIGH ENERGY
INTENSITY INDUSTRIAL USES LONG
DURATION ENERGY STORAGE. I IN
SOME APPLICATIONS IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SECTOR THE STATE
REALLY NEEDS- I SHOULD EMBARK ON
A MOONSHOT TYPE PROGRAM. ALONG
THE LINES OF OTHER SUCCESSFUL
CALIFORNIA PROGRAMS TO BRING THE
COST OF ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN
AND PARTICULARLY THE COST OF
ELECTROLYZER. USUALLY THEMSELVES
DOWN TO A POINT THAT IT MEETS OR
BEATS THE COST OF STEAMER FORMED
HYDROGEN. THE STATE SHOULD ALSO
TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION THE
AVAILABILITY AVAILABILITY OF
WATER- IN SCALED UP ELECTROLYSIS
IN THE STATE EXPERIENCE
EXPERIENCING EXTENDED DROUGHT.
AND NO PUBLIC DOLLARS SHOULD BE
MISSPENT ON APPLICATION PROJECTS
THE IGNORE THE METHOD OF
HYDROGEN PRODUCTION. POSSIBLE
ENERGY BURKE THE BASED HYDROGEN
INCLUDING PROJECTS THAT AIM TO
INCLUDE CARBON DIOXIDE CAPTURE
SHOULD BE DEEMED INELIGIBLE
CATEGORICALLY. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME. THANK YOU
SO MUCH IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN
THE ROOM TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME AND
ORGANIZATION IF YOU HAVE MICHAEL
SMITH THANK YOU SENATOR I'M FROM
RE CARBON. WERE SANTA CLARA
BASED TECH- CLIMATE TECHNOLOGY
COMPANY THAT IS INVENTED AND
DEVELOPED A BREAKTHROUGH PLASMA
TECHNOLOGY THAT CREATES CLEAN DE
. TIED IN OUR COMMERCIAL LEVEL
PROCESSES STRONGLY EXOTHERMIC
WITH NON COMBUSTION PLASMA
REACTION NOT BURNING AND
CONVERTS AND TRANSFORMS
GREENHOUSE GASES PARTICULARLY
CARBON DIOXIDE AND METHANE INTO
A NEGATIVE CARBON. HYDROGEN AND
SYNGAS ON A FULL LIFE CYCLE
BASIS WE'RE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF
THE WORK OF THE OF THE STATE OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON
ESTABLISHING CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN
HUB. WE THINK IT COULD PROVE A
POSITIVE TIPPING POINT OF NEW US
AT SCALE LOW CARBON ECONOMY WITH
CLEAN DECARBONISE HYDROGEN IS A
FOUNDATIONAL ELEMENT. BRIEFLY A
COUPLE KEY POINTS THAT WOULD
<c.magenta>IKE TO EMPHASIZE IN THE DESIGN</c>
WE THINK THE DESIGN SHOULD
INCENTIVIZE CLEAN HYDROGEN
MEANING ZERO OR EVEN NEGATIVE
CARBON HYDROGEN TO ENSURE THE
pCLIMATE GOALS OR IT'S FENCED AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE THROUGH THE
INITIATIVE. SECOND LOCALLY SITES
LOCALLY PRODUCED HYDROGEN SHOULD
BE PRIORITIZED- GIVEN THE
ABILITY FOR LOCAL COMMUNITIES IN
PARTICULAR IMPACT TO COMMUNITIES
TO RECEIVE THE BENEFITS OF THE
JOBS REVENUE AND ECONOMIC.
AFFECTS OF PARTICULARLY
ADDRESSING ENERGY JUSTICE THIRD
RENEWABLE SOURCES INCLUDING WAY
SOURCES LANDFILL DIVERTED
ORGANIC WASTE AND WASTE WATER
SHOULD BE CENTERED IN THE
STRATEGY. OF THE PROGRAM SHOULD
BUILDING TRANSPARENCY THROUGH A
DATABASE PLATFORM THAT CAN
PROVIDE AN OBJECTIVE BASIS FOR
MONITORING OF BASIC BASED ON A
CARBON INTENSITY STANDARD USING
THE FULL LIFE CYCLE ASSESSMENT-
WERE NOT IN FAVOR OF THE RAINBOW
APPROACH WE DO BELIEVE IN DATA
AND TRANSPARENCY. AND FINALLY
THE CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN HUB
SHOULD HIGHLIGHT AND INCENTIVIZE
NEW INNOVATIVE TECH. LIKE WE
CARBON'S NOT SOLELY ARE
REFLECTING A CALIFORNIA'S ROLE
AS TECHNOLOGY AND INNOVATION
LEADER SMR IS AN EIGHTY YEAR OLD
TECHNOLOGY ELECTROLYSIS IS A
HUNDRED FORTY YEARS OLD WHILE
THESE TECHNOLOGIES WILL CONTINUE
TO PLAY A ROLE. IN THE GROWING.
BUT RATHER LOOK AT THE NEW
REMARKABLE AND CLIMATE POSITIVE
TECHNOLOGIES WHICH WILL PROMISE
MORE EFFECTIVE APPROACHES THE
BUILDING A TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
HYDROGEN ECONOMY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO PER-
PARTICIPATING GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISTER SMITH YOUR
PRESENTATION IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE IN THE ROOM TWENTY ONE
HUNDRED LIKE MAKE A-
PRESENTATION. I SEE NO OTHERS.
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN- BOTH OF
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION NOW
MOVE ON TO THE WITNESS WAITING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
IF YOU WOULD PLEASE PROMPTLY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT WE WILL BEGIN NOW
. THANK YOU TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME IN EIGHTEEN T.
SPECIALIST WILL PROVIDE YOU WITH
YOUR LINE NUMBER WE WILL OPEN
AFTER LINE AT WHEN WE ARE READY.
WILL FIRST GO TO LINE SIXTY
THREE. THANK YOU MODERATOR.
THANK YOU SENATOR ARCH ALETTA MY
NAME IS TOMMY REILLY GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS MANAGER ON THE WEST
COAST FOR AIR PRODUCTS. AIR
PRODUCTS IS THE LARGEST US BASED
GLOBAL INDUSTRIAL GAS COMPANY
AND THE LARGEST PRODUCER OF
HYDROGEN IN THE WORLD. WE HAVE
BEEN IN CALIFORNIA FOR OVER
THIRTY YEARS AND OPERATE AND
SAFELY MAINTAIN NINE HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION FACILITIES IN
CALIFORNIA WITH THE CAPACITY TO
PRODUCE THIRTEEN HUNDRED METRIC
TONS OF HYDROGEN PER DAY. WE
ALSO OWN AND OPERATE ABOUT
THIRTY MILES OF HYDROGEN
PIPELINE IN CALIFORNIA MOSTLY
LOCATED IN AND AROUND THE PORTS
OF LA AND LONG BEACH. ALL OF
YOUR PRODUCT INFRASTRUCTURE HAS
BEEN DEVELOPED WITH PRIVATE
SECTOR FUNDING TO SERVE CLEAR
MARKET NEEDS. AIR PRODUCTS IS
RESPONDING TO THE GLOBAL NEED TO
DECARBONISE WITH OVER TWELVE
BILLION IN INVESTMENTS ALREADY
ANNOUNCED TO DECARBONISE THE
GLOBAL HYDROGEN SUPPLY CHAIN
INCLUDING PROJECTS IN ARIZONA
THE GULF COAST CANADA AND
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD. AND WE
STAND READY TO BRING SIGNIFICANT
GREEN HYDROGEN INVESTMENT TO
CALIFORNIA IT IS CALIFORNIA'S
SUPPORT OF POLICIES AND THE
COMPETITIVE PRIVATE SECTOR
INVESTMENT THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
MOVE THE GREEN HYDROGEN MARKETS
TO SCALE AND ATTRACT HYDROGEN
HUB FUNDING FOR CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR HOSTING THIS
HEARING AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH THEIR PRODUCTS LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU AND
EVERYONE TO ADVANCE GREEN
HYDROGEN AND FUNDING FOR
HYDROGEN HUBS IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR- COMMENTS AND
PRESENTATION- MODERATOR NEXT ONE
. LINE. FIFTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS THIS IS SERRA
GROWTH IN ORDER TO ASSESS I AM
CALLING THIS AFTERNOON EMPHASIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF DEMANDING ZERO
AIR POLLUTION TECHNOLOGY IS AN
BOTH THE PRODUCTION AND THE USE
OF HIGHER CHEN AND I NEED
PUBLICLY FUNDED HYDROGEN HUB- TO
START WITH THE PRODUCTION SIDE.
THANKS TO MS LANDS PRESENTATION
ARE THIS MORNING WE KNOW THAT IN
EUROPE- HURRICANE HUBS ARE
GETTING OFF THE GROUND RELYING
SOLELY ON TRULY ZERO EMISSION
RENEWABLE ELECTROLYTIC HYDROGEN-
CALIFORNIA SHOULD DEMAND NO WILL
LEFT. EARTHJUSTICE IS
PARTICULARLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
PRODUCTION OF HYDROGEN FROM
FOSSIL FUELS AND BIOGAS FROM
INDUSTRIAL WIND AND ADLEMAN YOU
WORK ON WRITING COURAGE EVERYONE
IF YOU READ A REALLY FANTASTIC
EXPOSE IN YESTERDAY'S LOS
ANGELES TIMES. ABOUT THE WAY
THAT- INCENTIVES FOR THE
PRODUCTION OF THE NEW WAR AND
THAT THE OFF GASSING THAT NEWER
IS ENCOURAGING INCREASED THE
PRODUCTION AND WITH THAT-
HARMING LOCAL ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES- AND FOR
THOSE COMMUNITIES THE CREATIVE
CARBON ACCOUNTING BY WHICH
INDUSTRY CLAIMS THAT THIS GAS IS
ZERO CARBON. IS COLD COMFORT- TO
THIS ABOUT HOW TO USE HYDROGEN
BONTA PRODUCED- THERE ARE
CONTRASTING ZERO EMISSION WE IS
A FUSING HYDROGEN IN FUEL CELLS.
ARE BUT THERE ARE ALSO WAYS OF
USING HYDROGEN BURNING AT THAT
INCREASES OUR ARMED LONG FARMING
COLLUDED IN LIFE NOT. AND FOR
INSTANCE THE ONE THE REALLY
TROUBLING. BOTTLE TWO ONE THREE
PROPOSALS THAT OFFENDERS NEED TO
BE ON GUARD AGAINST. BEFORE
DOESN'T BECOME A REALITY IS
LENDING HYDROGEN INTO THE GAS
DISTRIBUTION SYSTEM THAT SERVES
OUR HOME AND BUSINESS- BECAUSE
ABOUT HOW. HI IN OUR THE WORD IS
TO BURN THE IN WOULD PRODUCE
MORE KNOCKS EMISSIONS- THAN THEY
ALREADY ARE AND MANY OF THOSE
INCREASE EMISSIONS WOULD CALM
AND SOME OF THE MOST POLLUTED
AIR BASINS IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY. THERE'S JUST NO ROOM
FOR THOSE TYPES OF INCREASED
EMISSIONS. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
THIS AFTERNOON- AND I. REALLY
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION. BOTH YOU SO MUCH
PRESENT. OF THE MODERATOR NEXT
ONE PLEASE. LINE. SIXTY NINE.
YES GO AHEAD. THREE THANK YOU
FOR SIGNING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN BUSINESS COUNCIL THANK
YOU CAN ARTS WHAT IT AND NUMBER
FOR HAVING US ON THE COMMITTEE
AND HOLDING THE- AND A WONDERFUL
INFORMATIONAL HEARING. I JUST
LIKE THE HIGHLY RESPECTED THE
CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN BUSINESS
COUNCIL IS MADE UP OF ABOUT ONE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE MEMBER
COMPANIES AND ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT ARE ALL WORKING TOWARDS THE
COMMERCIALIZATION OF RENEWABLE
HYDROGEN- I WOULD JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT BUT IF THE SESSION
TODAY- WE ENCOURAGE POLICY
MAKERS TO. CONTINUE TO EVALUATE
HOW YOU CAN ON A CARBON
INTENSITY SCALE I KNOW SOMEONE
HAD JUST MADE A COMMENT ABOUT
THAT I WON'T. REALLY GOING FOR
THE GREEN WITH THEM- I DO HAVE A
GREAT THE CARBONIZATION
POTENTIAL ALONG WITH IMPROVING
AIR QUALITY DUE TO THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE A MISSION. WE JUST WANT
TO INSURE ALL MAKERS TO ABOUT
HOW TO UPDATE I WENT ON SAME.
ALL ALTERNATIVES AND
TECHNOLOGIES AND FOR THE IN THE
TRANSPORTATION SPACE. ABOUT
ELECTRIC VEHICLE- THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING THAT HEARING
TODAY WE REALLY LOOK FORWARD TO
ENGAGE ON THE HIGH. OF THE
SESSION AND- WE SUPPORT OUR
MEMBERS EFFORTS AND GETTING
INVOLVED. THANK YOU HAVE A GREAT
DAY. THANK YOU THEN THANK THE
HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE MEMBERS AND
THEY WITH THEIR COMPANIES-
MODERATOR NEXT ONE. BY. FIFTY
SEVEN. AFTERNOON THURMAN
ARCHULETA MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JULIA LEVIN WITH THE
BIOENERGY ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
I WANT TO ADD MY THANKS TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR THIS INCREDIBLY
EXCITING AND INFORMATIVE
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON MY
COMMENTS ARE FOCUSED ON REALLY
ONE BIG ISSUE WHICH IS THE
IMPORTANCE OF INCLUDING HYDROGEN
FROM ORGANIC WASTE AND BIOGAS IN
ANY DEFINITION OR PROGRAM
FOCUSED ON GREEN HYDROGEN OR
CLEAN HYDROGEN AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. LAWRENCE LIVERMORE
NATIONAL LABORATORIES TO REPORT
I'M GETTING TO CARBON NEUTRALITY
TWO YEARS AGO THAT MADE IT VERY
CLEAR THAT WE WILL NOT BE ABLE
TO GET TO CARBON NEUTRALITY
WITHOUT SIGNIFICANT CARBON
NEGATIVE EMISSIONS AND IT BY FAR
THE BIGGEST OPPORTUNITY FOR
NEGATIVE CARBON EMISSIONS IS
CONVERTING ORGANIC WASTE TO
HYDROGEN AD OTHER CARBON
NEGATIVE FUEL AND ENERGY SOURCES
BUT BY FAR THE MOST BENEFICIAL
AND USE. OR ALTERNATIVE TO
LANDFILLING AND OPEN BURNING OF
ORGANIC WASTE IS CONVERTING IT
HYDROGEN AND ESPECIALLY WHEN WE
USE HYDROGEN TO REPLACE DIESEL.
CALIFORNIA IN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
ORGANIC WASTE. OTHER- PILED AND
BURNED PILED AND LEFT TO DECAY
OR SENT TO LANDFILLS ALL OF
WHICH RELEASED VERY VERY
POWERFUL AND DAMAGING SHORT
LIVED CLIMATE POLLUTANT- SO BY
CONVERTING ORGANIC WASTE TO
HYDROGEN NOT ONLY DO WE PROVIDE
CARBON NEGATIVE EMISSIONS. BUT
WE CAN REDUCE SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS WHICH IS THE
MOST URGENT STEP WE NEED TO TAKE
TO ADDRESS CLIMATE CHANGE. SO
HAVING SAID ALL THAT. I REALLY
WANT TO UNDERSCORE THE COMMENTS
THAT CARRIED HIM IN AND HONEST
LYNN. THERESA COOK AND OTHERS
MADE ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
ADOPTING DEFINITIONS OF CLEAN
HYDROGEN OR GREEN HYDROGEN. THAT
ARE BASED ON LIFE CYCLE
EMISSIONS AND NOT. CATEGORICALLY
DEEMING SOME FORMS OF HYDROGEN
CLEAN OR GREEN- BASED ON.
FEEDSTOCK OR SINGLE POINT IN THE
PRODUCTION PROCESS IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT. THAT WE CONSIDER THE
ENTIRE LIFE CYCLE EMISSIONS FROM
DIFFERENT SOURCES AND CONVERSION
TECHNOLOGIES. I AM DOING SO I
THINK WILL REALLY HELP US TO GO
TO CREATE HYDROGEN ECONOMY IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU. AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
MODERATOR NEXT ONE. LINE. SIXTY
SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND DINNER NEWMAN AND TO
THE BEST FLIGHT COMMITTEE STAFF
IN THE BUSINESS MY NAME IS BRADY
BORDERING I'M WITH FUEL CELL
ENERGY- WHERE US THIS
MANUFACTURE- STATIONARY FUEL
CELLS- BRING CONNECTICUT AND WE
ARE DEVELOPING TO HYDROGEN
APPLICATIONS- ONE ON THE ELECT.
SOLID OXIDE ELECTROLYSIS DIED
AND ANOTHER THAT USES- WASTE GAS
LIKE BIO GAS TO CONVERT INTO
HYDROGEN. FUEL CELLS TO PRODUCE
HYDROGEN WITHOUT ANY COMBUSTION-
MEANING NO CARCINOGENIC OR SMOG
FORMING POLLUTION LIKE KNOCKS
OUR SOCKS OR PM TWO POINT FIVE
WE CAN USE RENEWABLE METHANE
FROM WASTEWATER TREATMENT PLANTS
OR LANDFILLS IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND CITIES- AS THE
FEEDSTOCK- WE CAN ALSO COUPLE
THE USE OF GREEN ENERGY AND
RECYCLED WATER ELECTROLYSIS
PROCESS TO CREATE HYDROGEN.
WHICH WOULD TRULY HAVE A MINIMAL
IMPACT ON PRECIOUS. RESOURCES
THAT HAVE BEEN MENTIONED IT
STAYS. AND JUST TO TALK TOUCH A
LITTLE BIT MORE THE BIO GAS. OUR
FUEL CELLS USE CHEMISTRY
INTERNALLY. TO REFORM METHANE
INTO HYDROGEN AND IN SOME CASES
ELECTRICITY AS WELL PREVENTING
THE HARMFUL EMISSIONS AND
PARTICULATE MATTER THAT COMES
FROM. BURNING OR REFORMING OF
METHANE THROUGH. SB METHANE
REFORMING PROCESS WHICH IS MOST
COMMON TODAY. ACTION OF GOVERNOR
GRAY HYDROGEN- THAT'S WHAT WE
THINK ARE BIOGAS HYDROGEN
APPLICATION AT THE MOMENT GIVE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS A REALLY GREAT
OPPORTUNITY TO PRODUCE GREEN
HYDROGEN UPPER EHICLES FOR
EVERY DUTY FLEETS- POTENTIALLY
TO SELL HYDROGEN- AS A WAY TO
GENERATE REVENUE OR OR EVEN AS
AN ON SITE ENERGY STORAGE
APPLICATIONS- INTO BECAUSE
THAT'S THE FUEL CELLS USES BY A
GUEST ON SITE- WE THINK WHICH
WATER FACILITIES CAN REALLY
HARNESS OUR TECHNOLOGY- IN THIS
WAY FOR REVENUE GENERATION. THEY
CAN POTENTIALLY USE WASTE HEAT
RECOVERY TO IMPROVE THE
EFFICIENCY OF THEIR DIGEST HERS
AND ESPECIALLY THIS IS IMPORTANT
AS WE SPEAK OR CENTER LARA'S
BILL AS THE AT THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE COME INTO EFFECT WITH.
ORGANIC WASTE DIVERSION. I JUST
ADDED NOTE. WE ARE THE PROCESS
OF BUILDING A- TWO POINT EIGHT
MEGAWATT FUEL CELL SYSTEM AT THE
PORT OF LONG BEACH IN
CONJUNCTION WITH TOYOTA. AND
THAT PROJECT WILL TAKE- BIO GAS
AND CONVERT IT INTO ABOUT TWELVE
HUNDRED. WITH OVER A THOUSAND
KILOGRAMS OF HYDROGEN TODAY
GREEN HYDROGEN AND ALSO PRODUCE.
GREENLIT TRISTIQUE TO BE SOLD
BACK TO EDISON'S GRAND. AND
WE'RE REALLY EXCITED ABOUT THIS
PROJECT BOTH BECAUSE IT'S AN
EXAMPLE OF THREE HYDROGEN BEING
PRODUCED IN THE MALAY BASIN BUT
ALSO BECAUSE- WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
A LACK OF INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
YOUR PROVIDING INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR IS TO PROVIDE A CONFIDENCE
IN THE MARKET THAT'S WHY WILL BE
THERE. WE SEE THIS PROJECT IS AN
ANCHOR PROJECT IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE ALONG WITH SEVEN
TEN QUARTER ON THE GOODS MOVING
INTO THE AN INLAND EMPIRE ALONG
BY CHANCE. I WOULD LOVE TO HAVE.
YOU SEND REGULATE INTENDED%
NEWMAN AND GENERALITY THAT WHICH
YOU TO COME DOWN TO THE PROJECT
LONG BEACH AND SEE THE WORLD. I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. AND
THANK YOU FOR THE INVITATION-
WE'RE HERE WE'LL TAKE A LOOK
WE'RE BOTH FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SO. ONCE AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR THAT IMITATION. A
MODERATOR NEXT UP. ONE THIRTY
FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON- ARCHULETA
. THAT ARE CENTERED ALLEN YOU'RE
ABLE TO THE- I'M THE CITY
MANAGER WITH THE CITY OF
MONTEBELLO. WE OPERATE THE
FOURTH LARGEST MUNICIPAL FLEET
AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE SIX NINE BUSES
ABOUT THE GAS BUSES. BUSES THAT
WERE GROWING- TWO EIGHTY-
HYDROGEN BUSES SO WHEN THE
PROCESS OF- GOING TOWARDS AFTER
CHEN- ARE ARE CHALLENGES
OBVIOUSLY AS AS MANY ARE SEEKING
FUNDING FOR OUR INFRASTRUCTURE.
THAT'S GONNA BE KEY FOR US TO
GET OUR CONSTRUCTION PLACE SO WE
CAN FUEL OUR BUSES. WILL BE
SEEKING ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR
THAT SO WILL BE- WORKING WITH
OUR PARTNERS THAT I'VE READ THAT
THANK YOU FOR THE MODERATORS-
BILLY WILDER- COMMENT ON SOMEONE
AND THE GREAT WORKING IN THE
MUNICIPAL. BOND INDUSTRY WOULD
DEFINITELY LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THEM AS WELL SO
AGAIN WE CAN ACTUALLY GIVE YOU
LEADERSHIP AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE STATE AND OUR
PARTNERS THANK YOU YEAH THANK
YOU RENEE INTO MY YEAH SHUT OUT
THE CITY OF MONTEBELLO THAT IS
IN MY DISTRICT. AND I'M EXCITED
TO HEAR YOUR FUTURES EIGHTY
BUSES HYDROGEN SO WITHOUT A
DOUBT YOU NEED TO GET WITH THE
PARTNERS WE JUST HEARD WITH- SO
THEN WE CAN GO AHEAD AND GET A
GOOD HOLD ON IT IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND THANK YOU SO
VERY MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION. OF MODERATOR NEXT CALLER. BY
NINE. YOUR CARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AMY BROWN ON BEHALF OF
THE YOUTH SACRAMENTO
METROPOLITAN AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT WE WANT TO
THANK YOU THIS COMMITTEE AND-
YOUR EFFORTS ON HYDROGEN ENERGY
. I GREEN HYDROGEN FOR
TRANSPORTATION AND OTHER END USE
THIS IS A PROBLEM I THINK ZERO
EMISSION SOLUTION AND WE FEEL
THAT CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO DOUBLE
DOWN ON ITS COMMITMENT TO IT.
INCLUDING FUNDING THE NECESSARY
FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT FIELD- VEHICLES OF ALL
SIZES. THE SACRAMENTO AIR
DISTRICT IT IS CURRENTLY WORKING
WITH PARTNERS IN THE REGION. I
TO PROMOTE A HYDROGEN FUEL CELL
SOLUTIONS AND BECAME A MODEL OF
COLLABORATION AND COORDINATION
FOR LEVERAGING PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE INVESTMENT. THE REGION
IS TEAMING UP WITH ZERO CARBON
MOBILITY ACTIVITIES INCLUDING
THE FIRST HYDROGEN LOCOMOTIVE
FUEL CELL RECTOR OF THAT PROJECT
AT THE PORT OF SACRAMENTO- AGAIN
WE WANT TO THANK YOU- WE INVITE
YOU TO COME SEE THIS PROJECT IN
THE MAKING. MADE POSSIBLE BY THE
FUNDING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION AND- WE LOOK
FORWARD TO. ENGAGING WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AND BECOMING A LEADING
VOICE FOR GREEN HYDROGEN ENERGY
INDEED SACRAMENTO VALLEY THANK
YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU AS WE
ARE ALL HERE- THE- CLEAN THAT-
SACRAMENTO CITY CALIFORNIA-
ACROSS THE NATION AND SEE WHAT
CALIFORNIA IS DOING. AND WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THE FACT THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICES IS FIGHTING
HARD TO GET AS THE MAJORITY OF
THAT MONEY THAT- SO. DESPERATELY
NEEDED TO OPEN THE GATES UP FOR
HYDROGEN- INCALIFORNIA SO I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
MODERATOR WHO'S UP NEXT. NEXT TO
NUMBER. NINE GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS MICHAEL WHEELER AND I
LEAVE GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR
INSTACART THANK YOU CHAIR
ARCHULETA IN THE COMMITTEE FOR
ORGANIZING A FANTASTIC AND
INFORMATIVE HEARING AND MY
THANKS ALSO GOES TO GO BILLS FOR
ITS ATTENTION AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO. ATTRACTED
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN GREEN
HYDROGEN TO CALIFORNIA. THERE'S
A POWER THE CLEAN ENERGY COMPANY
ACTIVE IN CALIFORNIA AND AROUND
THE SOUTHWEST. CURRENTLY WE ARE
BUILDING SOME OF THE LARGEST
ZERO CARBON SOLAR AND BATTERY
STORAGE PROJECTS IN CALIFORNIA
WITH OVER ONE THOUSAND MEGAWATTS
OF SOLAR UNDER CONSTRUCTION
MOSTLY ALONG THE I. TEN CORRIDOR
. WE'RE BUILDING THOSE WITH
UNION LABOR US MANUFACTURED
SOLAR MODULES AND US
MANUFACTURED BATTERY SYSTEMS AND
WE'RE ALREADY PLANNING
ELECTROLYTIC GREEN HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION IN OTHER STATES AT
SCALE. AND ARE READY TO DO SO
WITH SOME OF THE SITES THAT WE
HAVE IN OUR PORTFOLIO OF PLANNED
PROJECTS IN CALIFORNIA USEFUL
FOR THE UNIFIED CALIFORNIA
HYDROGEN HOW PROPOSAL. MY
COMMENT FOR THE COMMITTEE HAS TO
DO WITH SCALE. WE BELIEVE THAT
TO SUCCEED IN STANDING UP A
GREEN HYDROGEN INDUSTRY IT WILL
BE CRITICAL THAT THE STATE
INVEST IN LARGE SCALE EFFORTS TO
PRODUCE GREEN HYDROGEN. KEEP THE
LEVELIZED COST OF HYDROGEN DOWN
MAKING IT ATTRACTIVE FOR
CUSTOMERS WE MUST BUILD BIG.
THIS MEANS GIGAWATT SCALE
GENERATION LEVERAGING DEDICATED
SOLAR AND WIND GENERATION WITH
ONSITE ELECTROLYSIS. KEEPING IT
ALL CO LOCATED AVOID BURDENING
OUR EXISTING TRANSMISSION SYSTEM
WITH NEW LOANS IT KEEPS THE COST
OF THE GREEN HYDROGEN DOWN BY
AVOIDING THOSE TRANSMISSION
CHARGES. CRITICAL HOWEVER TO
THIS EFFORT IS THE PIPELINE
TRANSPORTER OF THE GREEN
HYDROGEN PROJECT PRODUCT EITHER
THROUGH BLENDING IN NATURAL GAS
PIPELINES OR IN NEWS DEDICATED
HYDROGEN PIPELINES AND WE'RE
THRILLED WITH THE REMARKS OF A
NUMBER OF THE SPEAKERS TODAY
REGARDING SUPPORT FOR PIPELINES
INCLUDING SO CAL GAS. GREEN
HYDROGEN COALITION IN NOR CAL
POWER AGENCY THANKS AGAIN FOR
THE TIME SPENT TODAY ON THIS
IMPORTANT TOPIC. AND THANK YOU
SO VERY MUCH I WAS INFORMED THAT
WE HAVE TO REMAINING SPEAKERS
SO- THANK YOU ALSO STAND BY
LET'S FIND OUT WHAT THE LAST TWO
SPEAKERS HAVE TO SAY SO-
MODERATOR BRING ON- THE NEXT
WEEK OR. IN SPEAK YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY WRITER WOULD YOU ASK
ONE MORE TIME. A YES WE WILL GO
TO LINE SIXTY EIGHT. HELLO
EVERYONE MY NAME IS CHRISTINE
HOUSTON WITH THE PORT OF LONG
BEACH THANK YOU SENATOR ISOLATED
FOR YOUR ENTHUSIASM AND
LEADERSHIP IN THE ADVANCEMENT OF
HYDROGEN IN CALIFORNIA. AND ALSO
THANK YOU TED PEYTON ACKERLEY
FOR YOUR WORK CREATING THE CAT
WITH THIS INITIATIVE PART OF
LONG BEACH IS A MAJOR ECONOMIC
ENGINE NOT ONLY FOR CALIFORNIA
BUT FOR THE NATION WE PREFER
THAT EVERYTHING RUNS SMOOTHLY
AND THAT WERE NOT IN THE
SPOTLIGHT AFTER THAT WE AVE
BEEN DURING THE PANDEMIC. BUT IN
SPITE OF MYRIAD PROBLEMS WE HAVE
MOVED TO RECORD AMOUNTS OF CARGO
SINCE MID TWENTY TWENTY THE CARD
WILL BENEFIT EVERYONE BUT THE
IMPACTS ARE FELT ACUTELY BY OUR
NEIGHBORS MOSTLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. PARTS OF LONG BEACH
MY ANGELES ADOPTED AGGRESSIVE
ZERO MISSION GOALS FOR OUR
MARINE TERMINALS. AND THE
SUPPORTING TRACKING INDUSTRY.
AND WHILE WE REMAIN NEUTRAL
ABOUT HOW ZERO EMISSIONS ARE
ACHIEVED WE KNOW THAT HYDROGEN
WILL PLAY A SUBSTANTIAL ROLE IN
THIS EFFORT. FOR THE CREATION OF
A ONE OR MORE RENEWABLE HYDROGEN
HUBS HOPEFULLY TWO IN
CALIFORNIA. AND BELIEVE THAT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AS IMPORTANT
AT THE CENTER FOR TRANSPORTATION
IS THE LOGICAL PLACE FOR ONE OF
THEM. IN LONG BEACH WERE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE WILMINGTON WELL
FILLED WITH A VAST NETWORK OF
OIL AND GAS PIPELINES AND IT
MAKES SENSE TO REPURPOSE THE IS
RIGHT THE WAY. PROVIDERS
INCONVENIENCE ESPECIALLY WITH
THE PORT AS TERMINUS SO THAT WE
CAN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE LOWER
CLASS HEADED IMPOSSIBLE IN THE
SEAPORT INDUSTRY. AND ALSO
PROVIDE A CONDUIT FOR THE IMPORT
AND EXPORT OF RENEWABLE HYDROGEN
AND AMMONIA. WE ASK THAT ANY
LEGISLATION PASSED IN CALIFORNIA
ALLOWS STATE AGENCIES IN GRANT
APPLICANTS. TO LEVERAGE FEDERAL
APPROPRIATIONS. NOT ONLY THE
BIPARTISAN INFRASTRUCTURE BILL
BUT OTHERS SUCH AS
REPRESENTATIVE KATIE PORTER
HYDROGEN TRUCK ACT IN HYDROGEN
PURPORTS THAT. SHOULD THEY BE
SIGNED INTO LAW. A LOT OF MONEY
WILL BE NEEDED IN VARIOUS
SECTORS INCLUDING THE TESTING
AND MANUFACTURE OF FUEL CELL
CARGO HANDLING EQUIPMENT A
MARINE TERMINAL. FEEL FELT HEAVY
DUTY TRACTOR BEING DEMONSTRATED
NOW BUT THE COST OF THESE
VEHICLES FAR EXCEED WHAT ARE
LOCAL TRUCK OWNERS WHO NUMBER IN
THE THOUSANDS CAN AFFORD. ALSO
AS CALIFORNIANS INCREASE THEIR
USE OF ELECTRICITY AND AT THE
SAME TIME OUR CLIMATE CHANGES
RENEWABLE HYDROGEN COMPLAIN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN ENHANCING
RESILIENCE AND MAKING UTILITY
GRID MORE RELIABLE. FUEL CELLS
CAN BE USED TO BALLOTS
ELECTRICITY SUPPLY AND DEMAND
BOTH AS A LOCAL ENERGY RESOURCES
AND IN UTILITY SCALE
APPLICATIONS. LASTLY I'D LIKE TO
REMIND THE COMMITTEE THAT WILL
THAT WILL BE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
THE CALIFORNIA STATE THE
AGENCIES ARE FUNDED AS PART OF
ANY HYDROGEN ADVANCEMENT
PROGRAM. COMMENCEMENT BE TRAINED
AND READY TO ENSURE THE HYDROGEN
PROJECTS ARE SAFE. AND THAT
PERMIT APPROVAL FOR THESE
PROJECTS ARE NOT DELAYED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU.
AND THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION AND YES THANK YOU
FOR MENTIONING. OUR FIRST
RESPONDERS- THAT IS SO VERY
IMPORTANT THEIR VEHICLES AND
EQUIPMENT SOMEONE- MODERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE
. WE DO HAVE ONE MORE WILL GO TO
NUMBER FIFTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE- IT'S BEEN AN
INTERESTING DAY IN IT BUT IF I
REALLY I'M THE LAST ONE I GET
THE CLOTHES OUT BY AMPLIFYING
SOME OF THE PREVIOUS POINT. MY
NAME IS DAVE EDWARDS I WORK FOR
A COMPANY CALLED EHRLICH HE'D
WHAT INDUSTRIAL PROVIDER OF
HYDROGEN INTO THE MARKET AND
HAVE BEEN ACTIVE IN THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY TRANSITION FOR
MANY YEARS NOW. I WOULD LIKE TO
BUILD A LOT OF THE COMMENTS THAT
HAVE ALREADY BEEN MADE I LIKE TO
FOCUS ON A FEW FROM AN INDUSTRY
PERSPECTIVE. FIRST OFF YOU MIGHT
RECOGNIZE THAT IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY THE HOME ITSELF THAT
IS MOST INTERESTING TO INDUSTRY
BUT RATHER THE OUTCOME OF A
REGIONAL MARKET SUSTAINABLE WHAT
ALLOWS FOR GROWTH IN A GOING
PRIVATE INVESTMENT MEASURED IN
THE BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AND
WANTED TO INCREASE IT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS IT'S MOST IMPORTANT
FOR US. THE QUESTION OF WHY
CALIFORNIA HAVE ALREADY BEEN
ANSWERED BUT THEY REALLY COME
DOWN TO A SINGLE WORD UNEDITED
MOMENTUM WE HAVE MOMENTUM WITH
THE POLICY GROUNDWORK BETWEEN
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM BUT STILL
BEING PLANNED. CALIFORNIA IS
READY FOR THESE INVESTMENTS NOW
UNLIKE A LOT OF THE OTHER HUB
REGIONS WHICH ARE STILL IN THE
EARLIER STAGES OF DEVELOPMENT OF
POLICY PORTFOLIOS. IN A VERY
GOOD EXAMPLE OF HOW POLICY HAS
MADE CHANGES ALREADY IN
CALIFORNIA IS THE ANSWER TO ALL
THE QUESTIONS THAT CAME UP
EARLIER THAT AND HOW DO WE
TRANSITION TO GREEN HYDROGEN THE
FACT OF THE MATTER IS ALMOST
EVERY MOLECULE OF HYDROGEN IS
GOING INTO A FUEL CELL VEHICLE
TODAY. IS ALREADY RENEWABLE. LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD AND THE
OTHER POLICIES IN CALIFORNIA OUR
STRONG ENCOURAGEMENT FOR US TO
DEVELOP FURTHER GREEN HYDROGEN
PRODUCTION FACILITIES AND
PROVIDED TO THE STATE AND BUILD
ON THIS PLANET THINKS THAT.
PUTTING IT IS ACTUALLY TWO YEARS
AHEAD OF WHERE THE ELECTRIC GRID. IN THE STATE- TODAY. SECOND
QUESTION I RAISED IN A LIKE TO
ORDER. IS HOW TO PRIORITY.
PROJECTS OR THE LONG WAY OF.
PROJECTS WITH THE STATE. WE
WOULD. THAT PRIOR TO THE BE
GIVEN THE VOTE PRODUCTS THAT ARE
READY FOR INVEST. TODAY THAT
HAVE MEASURE CONTRIBUTION TOWARD
THE OUTCOMES OF THE ECONOMY THE
ENVIRONMENT. AND SOCIETY AND CAN
BE ACTED UPON IMMEDIATELY. THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER TALKED ABOUT
THE SCALE OF FANTASTIC
MEASURABLE SUCCESS AND REALLY
DRIVE IN ALL THREE AREAS. WE
BELIEVE THIS COULD BE DONE. IF
WE FOCUS OUR EFFORTS ON A
CALIFORNIA HOW BUILT AROUND
RENEWABLE PRODUCTION. AND THEN
AIMED AT THOSE HARD TO DISPLAY
SECTORS THAT ARE READY FOR SCALE
ESPECIALLY IN TRANSPORTATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY. THANK YOU SIR AS A
VERY MUCH- AS YOU ALL HEARD.
PRESENTATIONS FROM THE PANEL OF
PRESENTATION EVEN FROM THE
PEOPLE CALLING IN. WE'RE ALL ON
THE SAME WAVELENGTH WE'RE ALL
TRYING TO PROVIDE CALIFORNIA
WITH INFORMATION ON THE THIS NEW
TECHNOLOGY. SO BEFORE WE- GO ON
I'D LIKE TO ASK MY COLLEAGUE IF
HE HAS ANY QUESTIONS OR CLOSING
REMARKS. I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY WHO PARTICIPATED TODAY
PERFECTLY THOSE FOLKS WHO CALLED
IN FROM THE PUBLIC- TOWARD THE
END- IF THIS IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION IT'S AN ONGOING
CONVERSATION. I DO WANT TO PUSH
BACK POLITELY- TO THE MISTER
HASTINGS- REGARDING THE ROLE OF
LIGHT DUTY JUDGE I JUST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT IN ORDER FOR
CALIFORNIA MEET ITS VERY
AGGRESSIVE GOALS ON
DECARBONISING OUR VEHICLE FLEET-
THE FUEL CELL VEHICLES ARE GONNA
SHOULD PLAY A PART THERE.
THERE'S A COHORT. OF DRIVERS FOR
WHOM ELECTRIC VEHICLES DON'T
CURRENTLY MAKES SENSE. AND YOU
KNOW IN ORDER TO GET TO THOSE
GOALS WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO MAKE
THOSE ACCOMMODATIONS. HAVING
SAID THAT THANK YOU MR CHEER
ESPECIALLY TO YOUR STEP MISTER
ACTOR FOR PUTTING THIS TOGETHER.
AND I LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU. SENATOR
NEWMAN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION AND I KNOW THAT.
YOU'RE WITH ME A 100% ON WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH HERE
AND BRING- THE PUBLIC TOGETHER
TO UNDERSTAND. WHAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS TRYING TO DO. AND
AS WE LEAD IN SO MANY OTHER WAYS
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE OUR
LEADERSHIP ROLES- ON BEHALF OF
THE GOVERNMENT. I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOUNG- AND HIS STAFF FOR
PROVIDING US. THE WHERE WITH
ALL. TO GO AHEAD AND FIGHT- IN
TO MAKE SURE THAT CALIFORNIA IS
NOT LEFT OUT. WHEN THE DOLLARS
AND CENTS COME THEY'RE GOING TO
BE HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHAT WE
EXACTLY NEED. TO GO AHEAD AND
OPEN SO MANY DOORS. AND I WOULD
LIKE TO AGAIN THANK OUR
PANELISTS I EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU. AS IN LIGHTNESS WITH YOUR
EXPERTISE AND CERTAINLY YOUR
KNOWLEDGE OF OUR FUTURE AND HOW
CALIFORNIA WILL. WILL PLAY A
ROLE WHETHER IT BE. WITH THE HUB
WHETHER IT BE WITH JOBS AND
WHETHER IT BE- WITH THE
UNIVERSITIES THAT WILL BE
PARTICIPATING. AND JUVENTUS BUT
EMPHASIZED THE PARTNERSHIP THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE BOTH PUBLIC
AND PRIVATE. THAT IS A JOINT
VENTURE AND IT'S GOT TO HAPPEN
BETWEEN ALL OF US WORKING
TOGETHER. SO IT IS THE FUTURE WE
ARE IN THE BRINK OF EXPANDING
THE KNOWLEDGE AND THE SKILLS.
AND THE TECHNOLOGIES AND THE JOB
OPPORTUNITIES THAT. WILL BE
BEFORE US SO I HOPE THAT
EVERYONE WILL EMBRACE WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO. AND THAT STAY WITH
US AS WE GROW AND IN THE NEW
TECHNOLOGY. SO NOW I'D LIKE TO
ONCE AGAIN THANK EVERYONE FOR
THEIR TESTIMONY AND
THAT IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO
TESTIFY. VIA TELECONFERENCE-
PLEASE SEND THIS- ANYTHING YOU'D
LIKE IN WRITING. TO THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON HYDROGEN AND
ENERGY. AT OR WAS VISIT OUR
WEBSITE. YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE BEEN IMPORTANT
TO US AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY IN YOUR TIME- WE ARE
GOING TO. HOPEFULLY HAVE MORE
ADDITIONAL HEARINGS- IN THE
FUTURE IT WOULD LIKE YOU TO
CONTINUE PARTICIPATING. SO I'D
LIKE TO THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
PATIENCE. IT HAS BEEN A COUPLE
OF- I THINK BY TWO AND A HALF
HOURS OR SO. BUT IT WAS
IMPORTANT- TO GET THE WORD OUT
TO EVERYONE TO UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND ESPECIALLY TO
ALL THE COMPANIES THAT ARE OUT
THERE WORKING DILIGENTLY TO-
CLEANER AIR TO MAKE SURE THAT-
HYDROGEN. FUEL CELL HYDROGEN IS
PART OF THE FUTURE. TO WITH THAT
I WILL GO AHEAD AND CONCLUDE OUR
MEETING SO WITH THAT THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION.
MEETING ADJOURNED.